donc fa on arrive là pour cette dernière
et ultime partie de la phase on va dire
de pool du champion chest tour avec un
gros enjeu pour ikarou lazavic mvl et
firouja puisque il y a deux places pour
4 exactement exactement alors le mieux
placé pour se qualifier c'est Maxime qui
a complètement son destin en main mais
alira aussi simplement al le problème
c'est qu'il joue contre Magnus et c'est
jamais simple de le battre mais en cas
de victoire d'aller raisant en tout cas
il se qualifierait et il éliminerait
ikarou quoi que ikarou fasse dans son
match contre la zavic c'est un peu ça le
truc et Magnus lui quoi qu'il fasse
finit 2è donc premier 2è on avait dit
hein tu vas en demi-finale directement
donc de toute façon il peut pas finir
premier il peut pas finir 3è donc ça
change rien pour lui donc nous on disait
que si on était Magnus on a quand même
intérêt juste à faire F3 G4 et à donner
les deux parties merci au
revoir on en parle plus comme ça on se
repose on est bien frais pour la suite
et il y a plus d'icaro dans le t là tu
élimines un joueur qui peut
potentiellement être plus gênant ce
serait de la gestion de tournoi et ce
serait assez logique en tout cas c'est
il il s'est bien placé il a le le la
manière de le droit de le faire le
fera-t-il je pense pas peut-être de
manière un peu plus
discrète après c'est difficile à de dire
hein
ouis bon Dee façon on n'est pas dans sa
tête hein mais il a le droit de le faire
ouais c'est pas c'est pas cheval resque
mais bon après euh s'il veut gérer il
gère bah c'est pas chez varè en même
temps c'est efficace hein CER aurait
peut-être dû le faire ouais bah au de te
crever le cul eu gagné pour qualifier
dokovic euh enfin pour moi quand tu as
enfin tu as gagné le droit de le faire
en fait au bout d'un moment hein enin il
avait quête devant Ikar il voulait pas
que ça arrive et Magnus bravo à lui
d'être assuré de la qualification une
ronde de la fin c'était quand même pas
simple il a pour ça gagné 5 matchs sur
six en plus il a plutôt dominé
globalement c'est payer
normalement et puis en plus c'est drôle
pour les réseaux sociaux ah tiens
regarde j'ai
éliminé mais il fait pas la tête de
quelqu'un qui va faire ça en fait non il
fait une tête normale concentré
quoi mais le troll peut être d'autant
plus
beau
tout cas en attend ça devrait commencer
rapidement petit peu de retard
aujourd'hui à l'allumage d'habitude ils
sont pile à l'heure réglé comme des
pendules ça qui a mis le même pull il av
eu plus d'argent
ou alors il a trouvé que lu porté chance
ou je ne sais
[Musique]
quoi en tout cas la chemise à 1800 il
est pas prêt de la ressortir cô je crois
qu'elle a pas fait son effet oua ouais
ou alors elle est cachée sous le pull
rouge je sais
pas quelle année ça termine en quelle
année la phase finale alors là
aujourd'hui tu vas on va tout voir
aujourd'hui ça va ça va enchaîner il va
y avoir énormément de de choses alors
qu'on voit pas les parties ah oui mais
parce que j'ai le désolé j'ai le lien
normal j'ai oublié de récupérer le lien
pour pas avoir le délai B c'est pas
grave on va just raté trois coups au
début et puis on va les reprendre euh
ouais non aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire que
c'estàd quoi là c'est la dernière ronde
de la phase de groupe et après après ça
sera lancé après il y aura les barrages
et cetera et cetera donc c'est une slave
il y a pas eu de F3 G4 malheureusement
j'ai envie de dire
euh petit joueur Magnus ça aurait pu
être drôle
c'est comme faire RO2 c'est très marrant
ah ouais c'est marrant ouais bah ouais
c'est très drôle en fait RO2
ou alors il a demandé de la kayas pour
pas le faire parce que les Américains
doivent vraiment vouloir voir ikarou en
en barrage et peut-être qu'il a si tu me
donnes pas encore un petit 20000 € je
joue même pas je viens même pas me
déplacer
ouais mais donc donc oui non ce soir on
connaîtra les demi-finalistes je crois
que ce soir c'est une longue soirée qui
nous attend avec ouais ça va tre
magnifique ça magique avec du barrage
avec du surbarrage peut-êre j'espère des
petites demi-heur de pause à chaque fois
quand même ah ben j'espère bien puis des
castter de partout qui font des barrages
ça va être très bien quoi et à partir de
demain donc les magnifiques demi-finales
on va pouvoir se délecter là donc quatre
meilleurs joueurs de la saison qui vont
nous offrir un grand
spectacle sur de jours sur de jours
évidemment et puis en bo4 enfin donc là
on va bien savoir qui c'est le plus fort
et et la finale par la suite ça se
finira samedi tout ça donc là bon c'est
pe déception c'est que la finale soit
sur le même format que la demi-finale ça
être en
[Musique]
bo8 peut-être en 37 gagnant sur 5 jours
ouais un truc comme ça çatait plus
ouais bon c'est une
antimérant fou2 qui était pas le coup
historiquement principal norm c'est
plutôt fou 2 ou fou3 ou j'ai quoi 3 qu
trop plutôt
F3 ça retarde
pourquoi
pas il joue avec grand rock ce qui est
pas si fréquent quoi peut-être une
manère de perdre de manière un peu plus
discrète bon faut pas s'endormir Rais
cette
partie non il faut
pas
bah faudrait jouer là faut cliquer A5 B5
si on prend les B5 cliquer quelque chose
quoi c'est5 aussi
ou pas je sais pas t B8
peut-être quoi
l'ARDI 5 aussi
ouais
c'est s que serait pas
mon c'est vrai que 5 c'est pas
bête B on ouvre Touvre le fou quand même
c'est
inroyable mais il vair autant que des
plombes quoi
ouais pere c'est trop 15 minutes pour
pour
ou pas assez on le forcer à jouer non
mais déjà 2h c'est pas assez non plus
donc on le forcer en jouant en
bulette domine il a fait quoi est-ce
qu'on le sait ah mais je pense que ça
vient de commencer le
temp il peut pas avoir fini à cette
heure-ci à mon avis ou alors il jouer un
plot jouer un
plot c'est A6 prépare B5
ouis qui a pas l'air fou c'est
vrai
qui a pas l'air complètement fou
ce 5 vraiment bienprès une fois coupé
vraiment bien il laisse l'inititive au
blanc au centre la prendre
luimême
complètement je pense que mag du mal à
la perdre C malgré son
effort Magus ce sera son seul match
aujourd'hui quoi qu'il en soit oui il
sera qualifié pour les demifinales donc
pour aller se reposer quoi qu'il arrive
pour
demain victoire ou défaite ça change
rien pour lui un petit tour et puis s'en
va tur mais parce que le match ne sert à
rien
robinide
il finit ce premier 3è quoi qu'il arrive
donc je pense qu'il vont faire de nul
rapides un Petiton petit
Armon peut-être même nul rapide aussi
quoi aux enchères
quoi mais dur de faire jouer des joueurs
quand il y a plus a plus d'enux encore
qu'ils ont un peu de chance que là les
joueurs je tomb
ensemble qui est quand même mieuxandme
1000 dollars
qui il fait 5 donc il est complètement à
côté
malheureusement
bon bien que le coup là soit pas stupide
mais c'est c'est dommage de Pasir
faitpavant et domingaz joue en 2000
alors est-ce que tu peux nous tenir au
courant entre cette course acharnée
entre sa et et domingaz DomZ pourrait
gagner un deux parties et simplement
partir pour s'assurer la qualification
candidat Mo que so rejoue rejoue ou
d'autres bah il y a pas RAM aussi qui
est un peu dans
le dans la course mais il doit pas va
être bien jamais
bien maxime est où alors Maxime il sera
de toute façon qualifié après la
question c'est ce qui passe par un match
34 pour un match 56 mais on ira voir un
peu après bon il y a un cas de figure où
il est pas qualifié qui est improbable
mais bon qui c'est c'est victoire Deera
cumulé la victoire de
laavic mais bon et défaite de Maxime
enfin bon faut qu' a tous les
ingrédients non mais genre déjà victoire
de lazavi la voit pas la victoire
d'aliira bon on su on peut aller jeter
un il de toute façon on un peu que ça à
faire aussi donc on a le temps ikaro
contre la Zav ikaro est blanc on vous
met pas les caméras mais laavi qui se
débrouille après on est nous team
lazavic forcément une éliminationarou
bon dernier ferait
plaisir boncoute ça joue quoi d'autre
Maxime B fait Maxime qu'est-ce qu'il
fait dans l'ouverture il a les
Noirs peu on
ver
on espère pour ikarou que la l'année
prochaine le le tournoi soit dans des
conditions plus favorables pour
lui cette année c'est vrai que le fait
le combo jouer sur éik plus jouer en
présentiel lui fait lui fait un petit
peu
mal moins performant Fab
ouais peut-être un peu malade peut-être
je sais
pas est-ce que soit prévuent avant la
fin de l'année alors il a pas intérêt à
jouer lui pour le moment en tout cas
puisqu'il est qualifié à l'éo ou
finement s'il va jouer palmarès je perd
des points bon après ça dépend s'il fait
un tour surmesure avec des plots
peut-être qu'il pourrait prendre encore
plus le large mais mais pour l'instant
il a aucun intérêt à jouer ouais mais
surtout je suis pas sûr qu'il veuille se
qualifier non je crois que lui il veut
pas bon après si les mecs personne lu
passe devant bon ben personne passera
devant quoi la partie domingas démarante
écoute ça me donne envie de jeter un œil
Fab bah tu peux c'est une partie en
réalité vraiment importante en fait en
quelque
sorte contre un 2000 je ça joue pour les
oui mais ça joue pour lesand je sais pas
comment dire c'est un vrai en jeu
quoi je vois
pas il y a qu'une partie en fait diffusé
donc
est-ce que c'est chass ball çaoué
ouais bon 10 coups
déjà il va gagner facilement aujourd'hui
non mais bon 200 enfin c'est clair quoi
peux pas qu'est-ce que tu veux qui se
passe
mais tu penses tu joues deux parties si
tu es lui et tu te barres mais il le
fera pas ça se fait pas mais il pourrait
en ce serait mais il y a une règle qui
t'interdit de le faire je pense pas mais
F ils peuvent te faire un truc ah tu
n'as pas joué le tourno en entier le
tourno je sais pas moi ils l'ont déjà
une fois donc ah oui c'est vrai
qu'il doit jouer deux tournois ah oui
oui oui non oui lui il doit être bloqué
avec ça
ouais
ça l'air d'être bien pour Magnus quand
même je suis pas d'accord avec la jauge
ouais mais double double tranchant quand
même un petit
peu il vraiment le boss sa comment
autant rien Ren à des candidats
la cas bah après je sa pas la cas qu' a
remis un je CIS qu'il a mis un tweet
aujourd'hui à fond il à fond jésuschist
jésuschist
jésuschist sur un tweet il était très
heureux de JésusChrist tout à l'heure
bon il a toujours été peutêtre là il a
retrouvé un peu plus la foi il s'en fout
jésuschist jésusch jésusch quoi ouais je
sais pas enfin il est cyclique on sait
pas trop dur à dire je qu' plus
jésus-chist Kas ou peut-être cas pour
jésus-chist c'est
possible
non il s'en fout de tout pas jésuschist
non c'est pas quelqu'un de matériel
voilà pour donner il veut
donner faire
plaisir candce que
Jésus ob
complèement
qu'
pourquoi pas écoute je crois vraiment
que j'ai vu le tweet peut-être quelqu'un
pourra nous le
remettre écoute tant mieux s'il est
heureux comme ça c'est tout ce qu'on lui
souhaite à
Wesley sur veut quoi juste F
G4 je pense ouais tu peut-être pas mé
contontent de en
fait
dis faut trouver une idée pour les
blancsçon tu vas juste faire tour C8
sinon et un
moment so B5 B4 prend 4
toi-même je crois je prendrai de plus en
plus les noir en
fait
plus tant mieux tant mieux pour
Westley
en tout cas la kayas il va la
prendre déjà au moins 50
K plus
6 plus
déjà non ça va s pas mis trop trop mal
au temps on fait un petit tour allez on
peut on peut il se passe pas grand-chose
grand-chose pour le moment Maxime qui
est déjà complètement
foutu euh
ouais qui se fait complètement marcher
dessus en
fait ça se passe plus si bien c'est
greenfeld c'est loin qu'on puisse
dire c'est peut-être pas grave mais du
coup est-ce que une victoire de laavic
commencerait pas à faire mal à Maxime
parce qu'il a l'air plutôt bien lazavic
là avec les Noirs contre ikarou ikarou
qui n'est que l'ombre de lui-même
peut-être malade comme
moi on nous met le tweet tu vois
[Musique]
de Good morning
to the glory B now and to the day of
Eternity bless to be bless be the
Lord
Glory ouais bon voilà ok il très heureux
quo il hyper heureux ouais je pense que
les candidats on a absolument rien à
en fait
ouais ça sent pas qu'il se dit est-ce
que domingas va me dépasser quoi c'est
pas son mais il a raison tu sais quoi il
a raison en
fait ouais les Français qui sont loin
d'être impressionnants hein dans ce dans
ce je te dis avant qu'on aurait
peut-être pas en demi-finale tu étais
plutôt confiant mais là après le début
de match euh non mais confiant enfin en
gros j'estime à 50 % c'est pas ouf hein
mais mais euh mais bon benah peut-être
enfin 50 % euh ça va dans un sens ça va
dans l'autre hein il y a aussi 50 % de
chance qu'on en est
zéro en gros c'est kata bah Maxime il a
2 sur 6 et il a un sur 6 quoi enfin oui
c'est de la merde je sais pasoi on a 3
sur 12 là les Français donc bon ça va
qu'ils prennent 6 joueurs sur 8 et que
et que tout le monde se fait cartonner
parce que tu as s à 100 % et Carls plus
ou moins aussi donc comme ils battent
tout le monde tout le monde su et même
en suant tu as les chance de Calif mais
g on peut pas dire qu'ils font des bons
tournois
quoi mais bon comme il suffit de finir
6e sur 8 bah bon normalement tu peux
peut-être y arriver parce que tu as
quand même encore deux mecs qui ont que
que un derrière et passé et puis après
bon bah sur un match tu fais un bon
match et hop là pouf bah ça y est tu
esis en demi
quoi mais euh comme je disais à keV quoi
ça ça me ça me fait penser à un tournoi
un vieux tournoi de Linares en fait
caspf avait défoncé tout le monde
c'était un match àerretour il avait fait
au moins un et demi sur deux contre tout
le monde et les autres s'étaient jamais
battu entre eux donc en fait tu avait un
mec dans le tournoi B kasperov qui avait
survolé qui avit gagné largement et le
second du tournoi finit à 4 et demi sur
10 personne 50 %
donc là c'est un peu ça le scénario quoi
si tu vas te qualifier tu vas être en
demi-finale avec avec deux points sur 7
quoi
enfin mais c'est c'est comme ça c'est le
tournoi qui a voulu ça dans son
scénario
est-ce que tu as deux joueurs qui sont
quand même nettement plus forts quoi
voilà pour l'instant qu' joue très bien
après le truc dommage c'est que Maxime
Grono en fait il était à deux doigs de
gagner le match et peut-être ça
changeait pas mal de choses pour la
suite he après bon il a perdu il a perdu
quoi mais Maxime il a quand même un peu
trop de parti où il passe complètement à
côté comme celle bah hier contre Carl
c'était ouais ouais c'est fait j'ai
rarement vu ça en fait et là aujourd'hui
bon la suit pas trop mais le peu qu'on
voit ça pas l'air de bien se passer et
assez vite quoi ve dire qu'il se fait
poncer le B voilà quoi non
mais mais je sais pas quoi dire d'autre
quoi
non bon les qui a donné un pion mais qui
bon reste dans la partie le pion est
bien bloqué c'est des rocoposé il a les
pièces pas mal sorties on va voir quoi
en tout cas moi j'ai vraiment hâte Fab
d'arriver au demi-finale hein match
comme ça couprè là qui vont arriver avec
les les meilleurs et on rêve en ce
moment maintenant que qu'on en est là
d'une finale quand même Carl
senso bah là oui ça serait la belle
finale les deux joueurs en forme du
tournoi Magnus qui pour essayer de
prendre sa revanche sur sa qui l' quand
même battu dans le tournoi donc c'est
pas rien sa qui est tenant du titre en
plus hein h gagné l'an dernier oui
Magnus jouait Magnus ne jouait pas mais
il avait éliminé ikaro nakamira en
demi-finale Wesley avant de battre NiAl
Sarine je crois en finale NiAl Sarine
qu'il avait complètement explosé et
c'était en réel hein sa peut-être
meilleur joueur en réel h sur
internet non mais s je souens il a déjà
joué de le feu de Dieu à une époque
alors après comme d'Able les Américains
étaient dit tir en Bic ah c'est nouau
ficher
ok' mais il était monté à plus de 28 200
quoi et il jouait hyper bien il
défonçait tout après il a hyper mal joué
endormi bon bah là il te refait un
tournoi un peu de comme à son grande
époque quoi donc il peut avoir des
fulgurances quoi j'ai l'impression que
lui c'est plutôt un problème mental ou
parfois il explose un peu par peur ou
quoi mais je crois que sinon c'est il
joue bien niveau talent pur j'ai
l'impression que c'est quand même très
très costaud lesou bah mais genre toute
façon on sa Vlad respecte quoi n avz dit
qui gagnera une fois les maintenant je
n'ai jamais dit en il l'avait
dit mais du coup si VAD
respecte c'est pas c'est pas rien quoi
je n'avais jamais dit
ça il a dit hein
mais toi tu crois et puis quand tu vas
arriver
rappelle-tu toujours su mais non non il
avait dit ouais on va appeler le
pétrrocian
moderne ouis c'est un peu ça ou
mériterait d'aller au candidat pour moi
Wesley quand même mais plus l'envie Fab
qui lui manque qu'autre chose peut-être
bon en tout cas pour l'instant il a le
strapontin si a trouvé son équilibre
avec Jésus-Christ tant mieux pour lui
écoute
alors il a reculé son petit fou en
H4 lazavic joue bien écoute nous on est
pour une victoire de lazavic bien
évidemment on est à la barbe
d'ikarou sa qui avait été champion du
monde de 960
ouais
et il avait vraiment fait une partie
impressionnante bon d'ailleurs qui est
dans le dans l'Almanac contre Maxime
avec un
tour ok c'est juste hyper dur d'y penser
c'est pas un thème qui existe aux échec
puisque vois tout à fait la partie je
m'étais dit que c'était une des plus
belles parties de ma vie quoi que
incroable ouis c'est ou et ok d'avoir
fait
ça ça montre quand même le talent du
gars quoi mais juste trop souvent il
s'en fout il veut peut-être juste ne pas
perdre ou il manque d'ambition et c'est
comme ça enfin pe importe c'est comme ça
il est fort il est fort quoi ENF ah il
est très très fort on ditarou pas super
bien écoute on va aller J je crois que
il il se remet mal au temps comme d'hab
Maxime il essae de lutter il va
peut-être Russ m ma que ce que ça eu
étéarou bon il se enfin oui bon
c'est il allait bouffer un pion il va
respirer à défendre
quoi bon le C 3 est magnifique hein il a
pas l'air au top Paro mais il va la
tenir contre un tel que la
zavic nous habitu tellement à défendre
plein de choses ikarou
que j'imagine la tâche ne lui fait pas
peur même si la position est difficile
pour le le commun des
mortels en fait tout est bien sauf la
gestion du
temps après j'ai envie de dire dans
cette partie là c'est pas des coups
évidence c'est pas une position simple
je peux comprendre le problème c'est
qu'il fait ça tout le temps ah mais oui
dans cette partie peut-être mais en fait
ça peut pas être dans toutes les parties
tu es moins bien autant ou mais ouais
benah si comment ça s'améliore ça
Fab je pense qu'il faut se faire
violence faut se faire violence et sinon
il faut pas comment dire c'est une
histoire de confiance aussi et sinon
jouer jouer les coups quand tu dois les
jouer je veux dire parce que des fois en
fait tu connais ton premier coup mais tu
plombes quand même à regarder qu'est-ce
qui va se passer après en fait faut que
tu le joues et au pire tu réfléchiras
bah le moment échéant mais des fois en
fait tu vois les coups forcés et tu
commences à réfléchir et ça faut se faut
pas le faire
quoi non non il faut clique un peu h il
clique pas assez genre la même tour1
soit faut prendre C3 soit tour e 8 il a
3 minutes 3 tu peux pas passer plus de
25 secondes sur ce coup je crois que
j'aais prendre C3 moi oui mais genre
c'est pas un coup si lourd de
conséquence probablement
non par que par là c'est que tu vois par
rapport à la situation du temps là ça
fait déjà 20 secondes qu' plomb dessus
moi je trouve que c'est beaucoup tu peux
pas donner 25 % de ta pendule sur un
truc sans conséquence il y a des
conséquences mais les deux coups sont
bons donc peu importe là encore j'ai
mauvaise langue parce que si tuenchaînes
par G5 après tu te trompes à
priorias réfléchi pour prendre une
décision moi je pensais pas qu'il jouer
G5 je pensais qu'il allait juste un
blocage sur case noir après c'est contre
trompé côté ou alors personne s'est
trompé c'est la c ça l'air hyper fort en
fait c'était pas mal sa tuas un pe ch F4
qui arrive je sais pas pourquoi il a pas
fait d'ailleurs
Magnus peut-être qu'il veut perdre en
fait il arrive pas fait fou H7 quoi
donne-nous ce fou quoi tu sais qu'il une
contrainte j'essayie de per j'essaye
j'arrive juste
pas
non là j'aiéta mauvaise
langue mais alors attention parce que
cette victoire d' il pas gagné une
victoire d' contre Magnus laavic pas mal
contrear ça pourrait nous mettre en
danger tout ça après il faut ne pas
perdre il est pas obligé de perdre le
match non plus
de toute façon si on est dans un
scénario un peu comme ça on aurait si
Maxime pre on pourrait avoir un match
entre Maxime et alira pour aller
chercher la le quart de finale puisquil
serait 5e et 6e et on aura un match euh
ouais alors à condition quiiko gagne
hein parce que si laav gagne c'est
vraiment enfin je sais pas trop mais
alors si lazavic gagne mais que aliera
perd on sera dans un départage à tr
et du coup je crois que c'est ala et
Maxime qui passe quand même
ok ça dépend des score de leur match bon
ouais bon un peu compliqué on verra bien
de toute façon on contrôle pas tout ça
on peut rejeter un tout petit œil jet un
il Maxime bon il se bat Maxime bon c'est
pas grandiose mais il se bat et la zavi
qui a joué G5 et çach depuis chez ikarou
à tank B oui c'est un peu dangereux ce
G5 qui pass en G4 et la dame qui
pourrait passer le pion qui pourrait
aller jusqu'à
G3 le ouais les pièces coulisses du jeu
il y a du jeu après à voir allez la
zavic il G4 en tout cas le
lasavic Magnus qui rejoint petit à petit
la
pourule il joue C4 c'est ça protège le
pion
hein il do pas y avoir de C prendre des
5 à cause de fou H7 prendre des 5 dame
prend reprend C de et F reprend on a une
pièce de moin au final après on peut
peut-être faire x 4 si mais peut-être
peut gagner une qualité mais que il te
la donne puis il te dit ouais je mets la
D en
B2 tuas un fot case blanche qui tient
bien la baraque il pas une ligne de fou
genre FO 4 dame B2 fou D1 dame F6 dame1
fou E5 al attends qu'est-ce qu'on faire
comme
couver pire al seul coup F B3 roi B2
dame D2 prend B3 dame prend
D32 h non mais en fait le problme coup
oui mais je sais mais tu peux le rater
côté blanc oui
oui5 on est un peu débile
oui bon du coup cavalier 5 ça c'est
logique en fait
bon il se trouve que leord dit qu' a fou
E5 F6 fou E4 mais gen c'est hyper
compliqué c'est compliqué ça c'est pas
D5 alors
peut-être F c'est marrant parce que sur
cavalier B4 il a il y a F H7 mat je sais
pas c'est rare
ou c'est le fou matre comme ça
c'est quand même pas souvent non non non
pas
trop de tout façon il va faire fou 5
c'est sûr bah parce qu'il y a quand même
k C3 qui menace hein bah oui c'est pour
ça tampêche k C3 tu te replace bien tu
évite de te faire enfermer mais par
contre là un peu pareil que ce que tu
dis en fait tu peux quand même le jouer
tempo
oui bah tu enfin il faut
ou rien de mieux à faire après peut-être
qu'il
vérifie F H7 3 H8 F E5 ou dans un autre
ordre
ouais non si peut-être il vérifie ça en
fait tu vois il
fait alors c'est ro H8 ou c'est ro G7
bon je dir ro H8 parce ro G7 tu as
peut-être plus de F6 la dame VI en G6 H8
c'est
mieuxou 5 F6 j'imagine ouais jouer à
tempo et il a trouvé la manière de
perdre là puisque c'est perdant Alce qu'
cherchait comment perdre en fait non
mais je suis premier degré
fa bah fait bravo que là en fait c'est
assez
discret tu peux pas l'accuser ben non
d'ailleurs même nous on est on sait même
pas en fait on sais
pas serait
beau
et au pire si c'est vraiment tu arrives
à l'armagadon tu mets une enchère à une
minute
quoi ver funny
oui donc là le problme pour Magnus c'est
que sur fou B2 il y a cavalier
B4 la dame attaque à 2 la dame elle doit
reste au contact du Fou h 7 euhfin kb4
sur un peu tous les coups je dois dire
mais enin ça ressemble un peu à exprès
quand même
he après il y a peut-être des tours
prend des 7 à certain genre tu te fais F
super mal a temps
tu c'est beau qu'on voit le mal partout
en fait mais pas vraiment le mal parce
que moi j'aurais fait exprès de
perdre CER a payé quand même très cher
alors que bah tu as le droit en fait tu
fait un bon tour tu as droit de décider
qui tu qualifies et qui
t'élimine il ramène son
F4 alors il peut y avoir k B4 il peut y
avoir la position reste compliquée en
fait hein je veux dire par le seul truc
qui gagne c'est quoi c'est F fou prend
fou F5 fou E4 et dame B4 échec ok
trouvable tu peux ne pas trouver aussi
mais tu peux ne pas trouver et quoi et
c'est quoi et F tour des 5 c'est
toujours pas possible y a tour en l'air
donc ça OK ou ça c'est facile
et fe pion pr prend C
f tu forces ouais ça c'est obligé tu le
bouff je pense c'est moi qui jouer ça ou
ça ouais tu bouffes là et tu as une
bonne finale quoi il prends tu prends
une très bonne finale
ou il prends tu prends il se cache on
sait pas où et tu F F2 peut-être
j'aurais bien fait7 histoire de sortir
de cette 7e HM alleors on va voir ce qui
joue salut de joue après F
rate je n'arrive même pas à perdre
t c'est terrible de tout le temps se
tromper quand
même
je sais pas si c'est parce que les
parties sont compliquées ou quoi ou
c'est plus rapide 15 + 3 que que 15 + 10
qu'on a habituellement mais je trouve
qu'il se trompent beaucoup
quoi
non as c pas facile hein il y avait
beaucoup de choix non mais
disons en fait c'est pas simple à
trouver en soi mais de jouer ça c'est
hyper bordelllique Messi quoi comme il
dirait en anglais alors que tu as
l'autre tuasas ta finale qui a l'air
très cool quo il va là il est perdu
ouais en fait c'est juste étonnant de de
choc autant ouais de faire ce choix là
en fait tu as pas envie de lui laisser
le fou B2 en vie quand même qui pourquoi
tu préfè F4 qu'un fou en B2 enfin
j'arrive pas à comprendre le processus
mental juste quand c'est que du calcul
tu trombe dans le calcul c'est pas
arrive à tout le monde
mais là en fait c'est de laisser enve ce
fou B2 qui bon ch le monde quoi enfin il
protège le roi il attaque le roi faire
l'affaire de d'un d'un certain
ikarou mais bon là pour le coupaza peut
s'en prendre qu'à lui-même
ouais il a eu la
position Magnus a pas fait une grande
partie
is fou B5 t B2 fou prend
B5 on sait pas les deux sont Z not alors
peut-être qu' va se passer des choses en
tout cas c'est mieux blanc ça paraît
oh alors peut-être t B3 non ouais ouais
mais F prend quand même si on prend
ouais mais t prend F2 enfin t prends F3
t prends F3 t prends B3 alors
peut-être discret
Magnus non mais bon il fait exprès quoi
enfin c'est
magnifique ah il est tombé juste il
donne les parties en fait c'est beau
quoi
discrétion
discrtionide Maxim qui a l'air de s'en
sortir
ikarou on va voir ikarou quand même
avant Maxim Maxim va s'en sortir ça va
faire
nul mais ikaro il doit pas être bien là
ikaro éliminé en fait ah mais en fait ça
dépend plus de lui hein si si si gagne
le match c'est fini mais là cette
position de toute façon bon il a quand
même des pions pour sa qualité mais mais
bon la tour la dame il y a des colonnes
ouvertes quoi mais c'est beau quo il a
perdu ça VAgnus c'est vraiment
ouis
bah ouais enfin c'est quand même un
peu perdu ça me bute franchement s'il a
fait exprès c'est extraordinaire on
saura jamais
mais il y a une vraie chance qu' fa de
toute façon on va voir aussi comment il
joue la deuxième
partie genre si tu fais une berlinoise
et que tu laisses d des4 d'AM 4 alors
quen bon
ben mais bon après il a pu
faire
une position parce que la position était
compliquée et il y a plus de temps et ça
peut arriver aussi enfin on peut pas
l'accuser de mais peut-être que oui mais
moi j'accuse parce que j'aurais fait
exprè de perdre donc
att que c'est qu'atention quo enfin pour
moi c'est normal de faire exprès de
perdre c'est pas normal de gagner en
fait il a quand même des pionsar des
peut-être quand
Mme il va peut-être la gagner
quandmear je suis pas s grandit d' doné
B7 contre G5 mais on va voir les pions
blancs vont qu' s avancer mais le roi
vient un peu
euh on va voir bon ça l'air mieux
blancin je prendrai les blancs tous les
jours moi mais mais rien n'est
fait fa quand même pas faire du roi des4
tu peut-être faire ah ah j'allais dire
fallait faire retour à 7 d'abord et roi
des4
après 7
A6 D4 B4
ouis tu su
B5 tu su en
fait bon ah c'est dur là la position
ouais mais je croisf j'en Saien c'est
juste pour savoir juste il y a quelques
coups que le moment critique c'est je
sais pas peut-êre c'est déjà critique
mais faut pas aller donner B G5 quoi non
là c'est pas net la position je sais pas
trop ce qui se passe mais mais de coups
après là une fois qu'il y a ça bah les
pions blanent tout seul quoi non ils
sont pas censé s'apprécier Carl je crois
qu'il se déteste hein je crois car il
n'aime pasar enfin il le prend pour un
débile quoi pas il le déteste je il le
prend pour un con quoi
mais après je veux dire des fois tu as
des intérêts communs si tu peux
organiser un match à Vegas avec de la
cayas tu es content
mais mais mais dans le fond là ça te
rapporte rien qu'il continue sa route ou
pas
alors c'est quand même dommage parce
qu'ils ont était vraiment déçu de pas
pouvoir avoir organisé ce match qui
était fait pour le bien des échecs gros
de Game et tout mais ils ont pas pu
l'organiser notamment parce qu'il y a
pas assez d'argent ah oui même dommage à
chaque fois mais qu' pas assez d'argent
tu peux pas assez bien faire le bien des
échecs c'est ça c'est quand même dommage
tuux vraiment faire le bien des échecs à
fond et après il y a pas assez de budget
pour te payer et du coup tu peux pas
faire le bien des éche dommage c'est pas
de bol bon du coup fin de cette première
manche maxime a sauvé la nul a priori il
était pas trop bien mais il s'est bien
battu avait gagné la première ronde avec
les noir contre Magnus bravo à lui et
ikarou s imposé contre laavic donc on
verra on verra en tout cas là ce va se
donner après actuellement si ala fait
nul on a les deux Français qualifi quoi
qu'il en soit donc bah c'est tout ce
qu'on souhaite et puis on verra la suite
ikarou pour être sorti de l'équation
mais ça fait quand même plaisir enfin
genre c'est quand même une belle
nouvelle ouais B on verra tout à l'heure
oui mais genre quand même très souriant
à la mi-temps on est bien voilà on est
très heureux non enfin je sais pas si
vous êtes souriant dans le chat mais on
est souriant on vous laisse pour la
pause plus c'est même pas tant contre ik
c'est surtout que ça nous permet d'avoir
les deux Français qualif bien sûr
important parce que sinon bon tuis ouais
bon ce serait dommage là bon ben quand
même on préfère avoir de français s'il
peut aller très loin peut-être remporter
cette compétition de prestige ça serait
dommage là on disait tout à l'heure 50 %
qui est personne en demi là
peut-être les étoiles salines en a deux
en demi quand même peut-être on sait pas
Maxim babdou gagne tout à l'heure firou
nous fait une
remontada SAP comme jamais avec sa
chemise feu et on est tous là
quoi donc donc voilà on va voir
euh ben on vous dit à tout à l'heure
c'est la petite paette entre les deux
rondes et on revient se délecter
ensemble par la
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va repartir à
fond alors attends je je je suis
complètement à côté
là je bien cliquer y a plein de caméras
de machins différents de lasavic
de
de de Fab de Carlsen c'est c'est
complexe il faut du score alors le score
un petit point côté
ALIR
bon je pense ça va plus trop trop tarder
à reprendre les j sont en
place attend
départ si gagne il faut que Maxime gagne
il est éliminé ouis mais le truc c'est
qui va pas gagner en fait B non c'est ça
qui est important à
savoir
qu'il fasse LAN de la berlinoise quandme
ser
extraordinaire je pense qu'il va être
discret Magnus il est
discret après qu'est-ce qu' va nous
jouer là des fou B5 qui normal son assz
tranquille Mme
des4 c'estorf tu peux trouver des des
belles Nules
il réfléchi
déjà bon on doit faire c
des7 je suis pas tranquille j'a préféré
que soit déjà nul en
fait
ouais B ça pas l'air très dangereux mais
bon après non mais ça peut jouer c'est
pas une nulle direct en force
malheureusement
[Musique]
bon3 il vaver cas noir faire grand rock
j'imagine après ça jouei fait de mal
dans l'ouverture mais c'est pas un truc
qui sèche
direct
nous on aurait espéré la
nul sans histoire sans histoire
ouais 5 Ron Dame des
TR Naka absent attends juste un un œil
sur les cames
Fab
éliminatoire pas mais alors est-ce qu'il
a le se peut-être de voir que Magnus
fait peut-être exprès de perdre
ouis mais sait rien enfin Magnus peut
aussi égaliser gagner son match
et mais est-ce qu'il a le seum bah
sûrement mais bon
après jouer F7 côté noir sur cavalier
f6utorise fou
G5 ce serait pas une bonne nouvelle pour
Maxime si carou fait exprès de perdre de
son côté
oui mais pourquoi il fer exprè de perdre
parce qu'il a le se dame C6 OK
entendu d'ailleurs il y a non des
tournois où tu as pas le droit d'arriver
en retard tolérance zé ouais c'est ça
existe plus ça fait longtemps que j'ai
pas vu
he tu as souvent un quart d'heure une
demi-heure ou je sais pas
quoi donc dam C6 bon je sais pas trop
j'imagine qu'il veut éviter qu'après
qu'il a des5 et des fourchettes sur
B6 euh bon'est qu'on faire avec les
blanc en C D5 quand même je dirais un D5
A4 tour à3 ouais tu pourrais
ouais profiter de C dame en
C6 il arrivé à iarou je j
un toujours pas ah ils ont déjà fait nul
ah non ça c'est sa c'est extraordinaire
ah si il est là ah non il fait pas
exprès de perdre
dommage
mais s et Carana c'est magnifique en
fait là ça fait nul très vite
là ils ont enlevé les chou et
chiqués bah mais bon quand ni l'un ni
l'autre ne joue pour rien c'est jamais
simple hein pourquoi
s'embêter
ils ont
raison j'ai bien compris si Magnus for
son match vs il est 300 % ah oui si Ali
gagne son match c'est c'est
terminé
on attend le le coup d'Alera qui comme
d'habitude bien son temps
ouais en fait je trouve qu'il prend
vraiment trop de temps à des moments
comme
ça évidemment c'est un gros choix mais
en vrai tu vas est-ce que tu vas
vraiment gagner ou perdre par tu 3 F G5
D5 ou petit
ou à
4 mais il a choisi de faire petit
rock jouer assez vite
menace C4 quand même
discrètement et tour D1 tour sur la
colonne évite l'enfil après F
C4 c'est bien
joué
est-ce qu'il y a du public pour ce
tournoi
non bah il faud faudrait pas
déconcentrer les joueurs quand même
ouais bah ils ont ils ont raison c'est
ça ils garde une ambiance quand même
très feutrée on voit qu'il travaille sur
sur la qualité de l'air on voit
que le la salle a l'air assez sil il ont
même déplacé qui gne un tout petit peu
les joueurs en parlant avant la partie
dans le concentration donc tout est fait
pour pour que les joueurs soi dans des
conditions optimales et c'est c'est tout
à fait normal pour une fin de tournoi de
ce
calibre envie dire heureusement
non fa peur il va la
perdre hy per hyper je sais pas quoi
dire c'est comme tout à l'heure pere
luimême
bon un
moment apr tu peux faire F
G5 il laisse faire prend5 c'est ça à
quoi je pensais
je5
B5 mais on c'est pas assez
discret
on fait à
il est quand même régulier Magnus dans
le
jeu il est souvent là
hein est-ce qu' a to de ha niveau avec
des spectateurs alors très rarement
c'est
rarissime peut-être un peu Vik
ouais mais c'est spectateur vite fait
quand même oui c'est spectateur vite
fait ENF il y a pas des tribunes je
pense tribun il n y a pas
de globalement
non mais même quand il y en a il y a pas
de public de toute façon qui se déplace
donc au moins
ouais moi je suis allé une fois voir un
tournoi avec ma femme à
Moscou moral tal ou un truc comme ça
ouais alors déjà c'était pas des gradin
si tu vouis juste rentrer dans la salle
et ma femme a éternué il y a tout le
monde qui s'est retourné ma F c'est la
dernière fois que je VO un tourno
d'échec c'est insupportable du C on est
plus jamais allé voir un tournoi quoi
bah de je pensais que c'était sympa je
me suis tiens regarde il y a des grands
joueurs ENF c'était un T hyper fort il y
avait tous les meilleurs et tout ouis et
et du coup on a passé vraiment 3 minutes
dans la salle ma femme j'ai jamais vu ça
en fait c'est pire qu'une bibliothèque
oui ENF énué donc automatiquement ils
peuvent plus jouer donc mais son les
conditions optimales
ouais mais ouais c'est la seule
fois o on a fait
l'expérience et Magus en retard bah là
l'ordi il préfère les Noirs he petit à
petit mais parce que il va avoir la
paire de fou et il va être mieux en fait
ala il fait de nouveau une mauvaise
partie mais
ouais alors pourquoi pourquoi se passe
si grave le développement c'est qu'en
fait on peut pas ouvrir le jeu le RO au
centre c'est très grave si des lignes
sont ouvertes qu'on peut ouvrir le
centre et qu'on s'en prend à roi et et
voilà mais en fait c'est tuas un
avantage de développement mais que tuen
fais rien que tu tournes en rond bon tôt
ou tard l'adversaire va finir le
développement et et ben ton avantage de
développement qui a un avantage rppel
temporaire va va
s'envoler par contre des avantages plus
long terme bah comme avoir la paire de
fou eu ils sont toujours
présents
ça c'est c'est fragile tu su quand même
même au blanc pour faire
nul mais tu te remets mal autant comme
d'hab
mais c'est beau que c'est dégoûté ma
femme je les gens qui rebondissent dans
le chat on a un peu de retard mais ça
vraimentf c'estent l'unique et seule
fois qu'elle est enfin ça l'a vraiment
dégoûté des échecs mais qu'est-ce que tu
Allis faire si tu peux pas faire un son
et que déjà qu'elle s'en fout en fait de
de voir ça l' choqué négativement dit
j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie enfin c'est
genre non mais je veux dire de pour te
faire plaisir et légère curiosité mais
elle s'en fout quoi ouais bon benah tu
viens une seconde on t'emmerde tuas pas
envis de revenir quoi tu dis bon bah
c'est des cons jouer à votre jeu et puis
puis moi je fais autre chose quoi enfin
c'est bon d'avoir réusster quelqu'un en
2 minutes
quoi et c'est
gratuit même gratuitement tu veux pas
aller
voir
gen c'est rare d'avoir un spectacle
gratuit que les gens veulent pas aller
voir spectacle c'est vite
dit des gens assis qui se cur le nez qui
boug des bout de bois
quoi spectacle relatif quoi normalement
les gens des trucs gratuits sont très
heureux quand mê d'aller parrios mais
c'est beau quoi les échecs en
fait mer
nul
d quand les grand j d'autres sport se
plignent du public il passe pour de
suite pour des divas aux échecs c'est
normal ouais B après dans les autres
sports il faut quand même que le public
y aille pour que il
Râ c'est le public qui fait quand même
beaucoup de bruit non puis ça dépend
quand en fait en plus c'est codifié
genre au tennis tu fais du bruit pas
pendant les points normalement ou genre
wou enfin c'est pas des tule pas à faire
chier les gens et euh par contre quand
les points sont finis ça applaudit
machin il y a du bruit c'est normal
c'est accepté j'avais vuinkka une fois
s'énervé mais parce que il allait servir
le mec parle dans son non mais ça c'est
parce que ça c'est autre chose mais
genre même au tennis si tu as des très
beaux points à la fin oh machin en fait
c'est toléré voilà juste faut pas faire
exprès d'embêter ouais c'est ça faut pas
que soit volontaire comm si tu ternu tu
ternu c'est pas volontaire on comprend
bien mais c'est vrai que que le gars
dans le public juste derrière qui à
chaque fois que tu lances ta balle fait
exprès de crier pour te gêner ça c'est
c'est différent mais parce qu'il y a une
volonté de nuisance
ou même tu vois c'était le dernier match
de la journée CIT Bery parlait ah oui
mais 3è set c un c'est un politique
ouais je crois que c'est un politique il
Ava dit si le match'intéresse pas dégage
mais enfin oui mais ça c'est différent
mais CIS c'est pas un bruit c'est pas un
éternument c'est pas un cri de joie ou
allez c'est un mec qui te respecte pas
il est là dans la salle et il parle dans
ton dos nonstop enfin surtout cô tu peux
quitter et revenir
oui et donc D5 bien logique hein de la
part de de Magnus qui va ouvrir son son
fou f8ite mais je pense qu'il va se
faire défoncer à rard bah il est moins
bien après bon si en face ça montre une
technique un peu poussive moins bonne
qu'elle accoutumée ça peut tenir quand
même c'est fou quand même comment il a
régressé Alera ça meenfou à chaque FO
que c'est parti
quotidien hein non mais en fait tu es au
courant mais je suis dit mais comment
c'est possible mais me faire nul au
blanc ça devient un problème
h comment tu as pu passer de de crack
absolu
quoi sur c'est idem par un bruit euh non
moi j'ai regardé du snooker le public
applaudit entre les entre les coups
c'est pendant les coups qui peux pas
faire de bruit mais pendant tu laiss les
gens se concentrer
mais mais le bruit ça peut faire partie
de certains sports genre bon les
fléchett je pas il y aura pas de public
sera de la merde tu AAS de mecs jeter
trucs pointus dans des cibles on s'en
fout en fait mais là l'ambiance dans la
salle le One et tout ils sont comme des
fous ça ça rajoute
quoi
d que Maxim a une belle position ça peut
être une bonne nouvelle je vais aller
voir je aller voir cette info chat alors
Maxime il est blanc m rugby tu as une
tradition qui se perd mais normalement
avant que tu tires une pénalité tu fais
le sil dans le stade tu as des
traditions
après bon ok il est plutôt mieux mais
c'est pas encore
gagné on a vu
carou pu bon il y a une marge entre pas
faire de bruit et que même éternué d
enfin je sais pas comment dire les
échecs c'est vraiment insupportable
quand tu vas voir c'est
horrible maispè au joueur de bien se
concentrer après c'est une habitude
hein mais moi par exemple clairement je
serais favorisé s'il y avait du bruit
mais moi j'aime bien ça me favor j'aime
bien je sais pas si j'aime bien mais
je me souvens d'une fois où je pas jeai
déjà dit mais on joue en Coupe de France
avec Mao avec montpeler à l'époque il y
avait une technarade un truc à la con
dans la rue et on jouait donc au club
tour de la babotte là dans le
centrreville de Montpellier et les
vitres sont assez fines donc ça coupa
aucun bruit en plus ça vibrait mais bon
je m'en foutais en fait j'ai très bien
joué ma partie j'ai gagné Mao aussi
enfin mais en fait en fait je me
souviens que moi ça m'a juste jamais
dérangé parce que même sans parler
d'échec quand quand j'étais lycéen que
je faisais les devoir j'allais au foyer
il y avait la musique à fond le babyfoot
à côté bon j'étais très bien j'étais
dans mon élément donc j'arrive à couper
enfin ça me je m'en fous en fait jeou
c'est une qualité après enfin quand les
gens dis oui mais machin le bruit c'est
difficile de se concentrer je trouve que
c'est une qualité aussi de réussir à se
concentrer dans toutes circonstances ça
fait partie du bah ça rajoute une
qualité que tu dois avoir je sais pas
comment dire Bull quoi enfin c'est pas
grave il y a du bruit du bruit enfin se
couperper des éléments extérieurs je
trouve que c'est quelque chose de noble
aussi
quoi bon après il faut dire aussi que
souvent on dit les joueurs ça gà nou
quoi mais quand quand tu es payé 50000 €
pour 5 jours de trava quand vous allez
travailler vous aussi parce que
j'entends souvent cet argument quand
vous allez travailler tous les
jours tu es payé pour je sa pas comment
dire ça fait partie de ton métier quoi
mais en fait moi je te pas ton avis
j'organise mon tournoi si tu veux pas le
jouer tu joues pas je prendrai quelqu'un
d'autre sera très bien aussi j'en ai
rien à ENF non mais gen je sais
pas comment dire tu es pour moi quand tu
es joueur d'échec tu es tu produis un
spectacle quand tu joues tu produis du
divertissement quoi tu es pas en train
de de régler la physique quantique quoi
non non
oui donc si ça fait partie du spectacle
bah tout en restant quand même dans
certaines limites tu vas pas tu vas pas
taper sur leur tête tu fais pas des
trucs qui sont complè mais tu fais des
choses normales c'est
tout mais d'ailleurs c'était probblement
comme ça avant parce que en fait là on a
vu une photo tout à l'heure de de Fisher
que j'ai comp avec pas mal de gens ouis
ou il éta pas là suer parce qu'il y a
des gens à mettre de Ch
quoi j leur partie
s'entraîn avec la radio à il s'entraî
avec ça il s'entraîn ave fum qui luias
le droit de fumer mais oui pour moi ça
fait c'est un SK en fait d'être capable
de se concentrer dans des situations
difficiles même au contraire dans
situations de stress exprès
pour c'est aussi ça le sport je trouve
c'est de pousser les limites quoi le
sport le jeu ou quoi c'est de de voir
qui résiste mieux dans des situations
difficiles qui est tellement au sommet
de son AR qui peut s'afranchir des
conditions
quoi
bon comment Magnus va faire pour ne pas
la gagner après on la tient notre vidéo
de
demain on ver peut-être qu'il y aura
d'autres trucs à dire mais peut-être non
mais c'est non mais fa on va faire le B
pas possible Carsen fait exprès de
perdre point d'exclamation tu fais tu
fais fou pr C3 enfin 5 3 B reprends
reprends ouais et puis B ah merde tu es
bloqué mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
s'autobloque hein tu l' joues très
longtemps et tu te
bloques
qui monte un petit peu son
roi donc il est pas contre évidemment va
fr C
tr
faire un tour sur les autres
parties une
dame plutôt sympa mais rien de faire
ik partie il est plus dépendant de cette
partieutre chose c'est pluss égal devra
gagner son
match et donc ce qui nous intéresse
c'est cette partie
principalement non il y a zé pour Magnus
F 10 pour pour
fierou j'ai des commentaires quoi
c'est
ça me fume regarde en plus qu'il sur
Twitter en fait
c'est non il joue quand même pour
gagner prendre avec l'autre tour c'est
peut-être plus discret quand même que
l'utre vraiment tu veux pas
gagnerire B4 et cetera et CEA
dis c'est moi tout le monde trouve que
je trouve que tout le monde est dur avec
Al bah en fait c'est parce qu'il a un
talent incroyable he qu'on est dur avec
lui c'est dire c'est parce qu'il aurait
le potentiel de d'être champion du monde
en fait qu'on est dur avec lui s'il
était nul on serait pas dur avec lui
i tu es nul tu es nul bon es nul ou ouis
tu te vas bien tu fais ce que tu peux
bon ouais bon tu c'est juste qu'on sait
ce dont il est capable
tu es plus dur avec bappé
qu'avec un attaquant de pointe de
Saint-Étienne quoi ouais alors je suis
déjà dur avec eux mais non
mais il avait le niveau des mecs de de
Saint-Étienne en équipe de France bon
j'ai te dis bon arrête le foot
quoi c'est normal tu es toujours plus
dur avec quelqu'un qui a plus de talent
enfin oui bien sûr comparativement à ce
qu'il peut faire en fait mais c'est
exactement ça
les mecs sont des
nazes c'est comme si c un mauvais
entraîneur quoi
est-ce que tu es dur avec lui tu dis bon
de toute façon mec ne comprend rien au
foot bon
t qu' dégage quoi oui oui mais c'est ça
mais genre tu en veux pas vraiment quoi
le
mec il va perdre c'est
fou
est toujours plus dur avec les joueurs
exceptionnels c'est normal maison c'est
vrai que là il est un peu moins
exceptionnel que ce qu'on ce qu'on
espérait il a un an ou de
quoi un départage à croix c'est firouja
qui sera éliminé maintenant
oui si per ce match il
Perou doit gagner le match contre Magnus
ou c'est on dit c'est pas c'est pas un M
c'est sûr que si c'est le niveau d'All
cette partie on crier au
génie alors qu'Arnaud on lui demande
déjà de pas donner des pièces en un quoi
c'est ouais
là déjà bravo bah Arnaud j'aurai une
partie de ce niveau là avec les Blancs
on CR auogénie
hein
mais
d'ailleurs souvent c'est une preuve de
méocrité d'être content de soi alors que
tu fais de la
merde les mecs qui en veulent vraiment
et qui sont à haut niveau son toujours
hyper exigeants bah ouais Mbappé très
souvent il critique ses propres matchs
euh tu vois tu le vois rarement dire
ouais c'est génial machin et même s'il
te fait un trip ouais j'ai quand même
raté le 4e enfin bon il est très
exigeant quoi donc les gens qui sont
très contents de résultat très médiocre
bah très souvent c'est qu' c'est eux
même des médiocres quoi après c'est
normal s don le maximum de ce que tu
peux faire donc tu es content de toi
quoi c'est pas que nous qui som dur ou
quoi j'espère que lui-même serait
mécontent de de ses résultats qui dirait
pasandme j'ai très bien joué j'éta
vraiment pas loin là c'est bien ce que
je
faisant
gen là c'est quand même bah mauvaise
partie quoiou oui mais c'est oui c'est
toutes les parties sontais dire oui bah
c'est beaucoup de mauvaise parti mais
c'est beaucoup de de mauvais tournois ça
fait ça fait longtemps que ça
dure c'est vraiment une explication
cette baisse de niveau là quand
même assez dramatique cette BA de niveau
Fab mais bon c'est pas encore perdu
cette partie on verra il souffre il
souffre beaucoup il devrait la
perdre il a pas encore de P de
moins il s'accroche mais oui il y a des
faiblesses à droite à gauche on voit le
pion A5 le pion B2 stroi qui
s'ffite qui raconte une anecdote sur ti
mais oui mais voilà mais ça c'est un
monstre du jeu quoi et et tu Devens pas
bon par hasard tu as un niveau
d'exigence et bah quel que soit le sport
que ce soit bah le foot parce qu'on en
parlait mais bon j'imagine au tennis les
échecs c'est évidemment pareil aussi
mais après je vois je enfin je remarque
que pour pour les échecs pour les autres
sports il y a beaucoup de gens qui le
comprennent pas et qui pensent que on
peut se contenter de la médiocrité
oui non mais pas pe dire que tuas fait
un bon tournoir que bon tu t'es fait
déchirer et tu dire oui j'ai quand même
fait un très bon tournoi ben enfin non
non mais si les gens comprennent pas
après pas rien c'est comme c'est les
gens pensent que c'est du ouais c'est
mais juste ça se voit normalement si si
tu regarde quoi ouais mais bon les gens
sont pas obligés de mais après oui si tu
as jamais fait de sport que tu as jamais
été compétiteur de rien que tu as jamais
suivi aucun sport aussi à côté bon bah
peut-être à un moment tu tu peux croire
ça ouis oui mais genre tu as beaucoup de
gens qui le croient aussi hein oui mais
sur qui suiv rien alors
pour Magnus est en train de se dire
comment pour ne pas gagner non
franchement sil perd la précédente et
qu'AG pas celle je te jure on fait la
vidéo Magnus faitprè de perdre tu fais
comme c'est ta cha mais on le fait je
veux bien il pas problème es Chud pour
le faire ou pas ouais mais en je dis on
va attend voir après départages les
machin par va passer des
trucs c'estand
mêmeanch fait un demi sur de les de
positions qu'il a
bonit de se poser de TR questions il va
la gagner
C des questions sa pas quoi mais
d'ailleurs on sait toujours pas on sera
pas pour ça on fera deux points
d'interrogation est-ce qu'il fait exprès
de perdref la question quoi chacun c'est
vra qu'on se questionne quoi on est là
on ne sait pas nous on sait jamais rien
après il active un petit peu le
roi de toute façon c'est
c'est quand même une marque de fabrique
des vidéos qu'on fait ce qu'on ne sait
jamais
ouais je pas
l'info ah ouais ce qu'il faut trouver
c'est pas facile mais c'est pas très dur
c'est Al est-ce que dans cet ord là ça
marche aussi puis on prend et tu fais
tour
C3 peux faire quoi en fait son G4 en
fait va faire tour C3 t reprend C5 et G4
et k G1 k H3 évidemment il est à côté
mais euh bon je pense que bus qu' prenne
quoi
pardon comment je gagne pas contre un
tel quoi je dois encore trouver les
seuls coups pour ne pas finir
c'est
[Musique]
terrible mais on sait pas en faitutre
que juste de toute façon le fait qu'il
soit pas motivé qu'il finisse second quo
qu'il arrive ça le fait juste moins bien
jouer sans réelle volonté de perdre non
plus hein en
c'est c'est le problème en fait de ces
formats tout ronde ou quoi c'est que
selon l'ordre des matchs tu joues pas
les joueurs avec la même volonté de te
battre c'est c'est par la même chose
dans le championnat de France de foot
quand tu joues Paris la journée 10 ou la
journée 36 ils sont déjà champions et
qui t'aligne les joueurs en vacances et
et il perdent 02 au parc et ils s'en
foutent quoi
euh B là faut bien tank du temps pour
pouvoir gaâffer en gros not quoi mais je
veux dire voilà enfin ça peut arriver
sans la réelle volonté de de mal faire
quoi c'est juste bon tu as pas la même
motivation la même non non mais bien sûr
pas faire mal
pareil on saura jamais en fait oui mais
bon ça peut nous faire ça nous fait des
clics on prend du fric enfin on
absolument rien à non mais de
toute façon la question peut être
légitimement posée en fait c'est M pas
c'est pas
une les gen on est très heureux ah bah
oui maxime a priori il va finir en nul
il y aura un arme Gayon je
pense il a fait FG il a encore joué une
elle pas fait t mais bon du coup al a
pas fait t C3 quand
même
malheureusement que c'est dans son
intérêt en fait de
perdre non mais c'est un peu enfin bon
c'est vrai que c'est pas habituel le
format du tournoi il y a un tour qualif
et après joueur se qualifi en demi et
cetera c'est comme le Masters de tennis
et en fait quand tu es déjà qualifié ce
qui est son cas bah tu peux en perdant
ça favoriser un plutôt qu'un autre et
donc bah s'il perd ça ilimine carou quoi
à coup sûr mais carou c'est quand même
un joueur plus dangereux surtout sur la
forme du moment et les résultats des
dernières derniers mois dernières années
même on peut dire voilà après ça
l'arrange bon peu importe ça t'empêchera
pas peut-être de
rejouer plus tard et peut-être de perdre
mais euh mais l'un dans l'autre si on te
dit tiens si tu retrouves en finale
ikarou ela qui tu préfères a priori tu
préfères jouer à la kikarou en finale ou
même en demi donc voilà c'est pour ça
que on se pose la question de bah est-ce
que ça ararrangerait pas de perdre et
voilà et com d la question est légitime
après on sait pas si s'il fait ou pas
quoi encore de
faire par contre complètement unesens
avec le roi aller vers G3
pour pour G4 gagner H3 complètement à
côté
nonstop après c'est pas facile à chaque
fois mais je c'est non mais le truc en
fait on demande pas des choses faciles
tu es censé être un joueur de haut
niveau et de faire des choses
dures il se bat bien Magnus quand Mme
pour pas
gagner
4andme ch les
tours tu peux pas tu
prends pe pas ne pas gagner quoi
non pour donner une
chance
mermeop c'est trop quoi oh c'est
trop mais ça nous enlève notre vidéo
quoi il y a l'armé
gedon il en a quand même beaucoup
faitirin pour
perdre B Tchin et malheureusement se
Fage va être trop dur à arrêter
quoi il en a beaucoup fait
ALARA il y a pas un tour g tour h6 il
réussi quand même à se faire arrêter le
pion h mais bon il il a quand même les
deux de l'autre côté ou mais est-ce que
tu peux troll encore ou
pas ça la question est-ce que tu as
encore une manière de faire assez de la
LA4 mais bon mais
ouais mais4 je crois que cétait vraiment
débile 4Z bah oua c'est de nouveau nul
B4 c'était mais j'aurais jamais jou B4
c'est impossible tu te mets dans
le par que là maintenant sur T
éche3
bah ouais non mais bon qui se ramène qui
avance t tout bloqué B c'est ridicule
quoi C elle était quand même dur à pas
gagner
ouais en plus il se met bien la tour en
B4 pour pas avoir tour G4 important
quand même il fait vraiment tout pour
pas gagner c'est oh le actor studio ah
c'est extraordinaire il fait vraiment
exprès de perd en fait c'est wou
ouais bon ok il a fait il a fait exprès
c'est sûr genre tu te retrouves
quasiment perdant quoi
oui en partant de loin en partant de
très très
loin il rejout de trois bons
coups prendre le pion quand même ouais
ouais
bon il va Esser
tour devir l'avoir quoi
cell prend un
moment là franchement vu comment ça joue
oui là c'est quand même vraiment
possible cétait déjà possible au vu de
la précédente ouis mais il a quand même
tout fait pour pas gagner quoi mais
après comme on disait ça peut être le B
cognitif tu t'en F et tu arrives
pas et tu arrives juste pas à te
concentrer pour jouer hein ça existe
pour le
coup et c'est parti t B8 non ça l'
professionnel ramener le fond de B5 pour
passer le roi petit à petit je pense
qu'il se'est défendre Sala sûr
hein c'est pas facile quand même he tour
contre tour bon la défense c'est pas
très dur mais ouais ouais mais non mais
j'ai déjà perdu en fait donc et moi je
l'avais jamais regardé euh depuis je
normalement je serais censé savoir plus
ou moins faire mais avec peu de temps à
la pendule tout est
possible en fait j'aime bien la la
méthode cocrane de défense c'est la 7è
ouais puis quand le RO se débarque tu
pars de l'autre côté en
fait défense 7e avec les pates elle est
bien aussi tu as quand même de deux
belles méthodes
il va la
perdre il va la perdre quand même on FAA
faire exprès de perdre l'armagadon il
sait pas défendre en fait il connaî
pas non mais là peut-être qu'il va y
arriver enfin de toute façon petit à
petit va se remettre le roi à la bande
et
euh tu VO faudra défendre avec Tor 3 G5
quoi
les autes parties s'est passé quoi je
sais pas je
vaiser fait nul ou quoi je pensa que ça
fer nul vu la position mais ok Maxim a
fait nul
[Musique]
ikarou
il0
gagn on arrive fatidique le RO blanc va
petit à petit aller vers la bande il
mettre la tour
G7
ça sent ça sent la
défaite
le niveau de la partie ça me but il
part pour la
défense la défense il la perd en
fait faire que tu tombes là je pense
non moment en fait je te
bat
genre si je gagne celle-là je gagne
l'armagidon parce que bon c'est comme ça
quoi il bizarre là il est
tombé il a il y a un décalage quoi il s
il s'est fait
B c'est
trop c'est trop il a perdu ça en C
ouais mais là je ouais franchement
je il est même pas très
contentus c'est la victoire la plus am
merde de sa carrière quoi mais du coup
pour
l'armedon je sais pas moi j'aurais envie
de de gagner à sa place
bon tu peux parler d'un mvel dans une
mauvaise pass j'ai pas l'impression
perso B tu dois pas écouter les stream
en fait simplement
là c'est drôle quoi là partie
il a un qui va Maxime quand il joue mal
on le dit hein faut arrêter de dire
l'inverse mais genre là quand même
perdre ça c'est
exceptionnel c'est wouh
mon père tour fou contre fou avec une si
position 25 coups c'est quand
même bon après comm je dis avec peu de
temps ce peut arriver mais bon le
problème c'est que ça arrive tout le
temps un truc quoi chaque
jour une explication mais
ouais B écoutez on verra on va pour
l'armedon pas de partedon je pense celle
quoi le match notre fil rouge ah
ou Maxim
qualif sait on est sûr donc après à
quelle place ça sera tout
l'en pour Maxime et pour sa survie si
qualifi sinon
ex
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with
theiciallection from ch.com M them ins
withol magnet kit swap them whenever you
like make your move get an exclusive
discount on all metal posters shop now
with the code chess
[Musique]
displate.com
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est de retour ça va
repartirireza contre
Magnus qui a les
noir
Magnus doit faire
nul pour ne pas gagner pour ne pas
gagner pas obligé de
perdre on verra s'il
arrive mais ça a pas l'air si facile de
pas gagner contre alirea
ouais sans que discr quoi
ou non mais là pour le coup à sa place
j'urais pour gagner celle-là ça m'aurait
saoulé enfin s tentait qu'il est pas
fait avant mais vu le contenu on
pourrait penser qu'effectivement non
mais à un moment je me dis bon ok ça va
tant pis je dois
punir on va voir mais il avait même pas
l'air très content d'avoir gagné la
partie d'avant non
ça ça l'amuse il
repart
mais B pour ceux qui voulaient une
réponse sur enfin moi j'avais déjà déjà
un peu parlé mais sur les finales d'Alia
c'est pas
mieux mais on a déjà vu que c'était pas
mieux du tout oui je sais on avait déjà
vu là il est parti instantanément à la
faute il a même pas fait illusion de la
défendre
ça pouitre difficilement gagner plusite
pour les blancs à moins que tu donnes ta
tour en un
quoi les blanc pour les noir pend
d'ailleurs
là je pariris sur une victoire de Magnus
moi écoute on va voir
hein et Maxime on sa si les blancs les
noirs on s'en fout
aussi juste demande au chat si jamais
ils savent ils nous répondront
je crois que so est
noir par que là c'était vraiment très
très très marrant bout en train car qui
a mis 18 minutes
c'est aux enchères on se délecte on se
délecte on s'amuse c'est un M game
intéressant ces enchères
là F les commentaires en anglais on
regarde pour les PA en anglais c'est bon
le match ne sert à rien il le sont
qualifiés ils ont pas envie de jouer sur
extraordinaire ça me dépasse en fait ils
avent fini avant même ne s'assoit ouais
ouais mais ils sont contents quo en fait
d'ailleurs de ça
ça va les trucs américains c'est c'est
tellement
différent r noir en armagon ça pu moi je
pense que non il fallait absolument
qu'il les Noirs ENF avec les Blancs
j'imagine pas gagner avec les noir c'est
difficile d'imaginer faire nul mais il y
a quand même une chance un petit
Pat
et
pourche Casa il gagne pas le tournoi
c'est juste là c'est la phase de Calif
après il y aura des des demi-finales et
cetera il y a même un barrage ce soir
restez bien avec nous ça va être
fantastique mais Magnus est déjà
qualifié pour les demi-finales quoi qui
se passe voilà c'est juste ça donc il
peut perdre il peut gagner ça change
rien à sa place il finira second quoi
qu'il arrive et donc les deux premiers
sont qualifiés donc donc voilà il sera
il sera de la partie pour la suite du
tournoi dès demain alors D4 donc 9
minutes F3 ça j'ai jamais
vu
pourtant je joue ça depuis
longtemps j'aurais fait E6 sans trop
réfléchir que de toute façon tu dois
faire
ouais qu'après ouais je vois avec l'ordi
prop G4 H4 mais j'ai envie de te dire de
toute façon aussi je vais le jouer
donc commence parer c'est peut-être pas
idiot
bon la Magnus c'est plus obligé de faire
exprès de perdre faire exprès de faire
nul
h mieux de faire s
prender faut rester discret
Fab
4 FO H7 on imagine c'était l'idée de H6
plutôt bien joué ça pour le
coup mais j'ai jamais vu la VaR de enfin
tu vois ça m'inquiète un peu
quoi dis peut-être tu vas devoir
affronter ça H4 je me disais ça ça ça ça
ça ça et
ça
ah encore tour dame F3 mais en plus je
sais pas tu dois faire HG avec les noir
ouis je peux faire cavalier H5 aussi non
c'est HG HG cavalier machin peut-être
que je fa autre chose je laisse pas fou
C de et tu es pas content d'êre clouer
quoi je faire G6 je te donne le pion
faisg é tout BL cadeau et je fais F4 à
F3 je sais pas quoi jeais quand même
plutôt content avec les noir de sortir
l'ouverture comme ça après moi je
toujours des positions pourries donc
mais en fait dans la slave don tu rêves
plus ou moins de base c'est quand même
d'échanger ton F de CEE blanche parce
qu'après tu as ta structure et en plus
le Fou est resté derrière la structure
de pion donc en fait c'est idéal oui bon
là en plus pion prend tu vas faire eu
prend alors ça généralement c'est une
petite règle c'est prend généralement
quand tu as mis le cavalier en D7 tu as
bien reprendre de bah d'illeur c'est
fautein ah c'est une règle en fait je
sais mais peut-être que il avait peur
des deux grands rocks G34 dans ce cas
fait cavalier prend mais moi je sais pas
enfin mais normalement c'est prend c'est
jamais en fait HM oui i le8 oui
ouais puis est parti de Rubinstein il y
a déjà un bon moment
déjà sentend qu'on sait ça ah ouais
ouais bien
d'ailleurs ah mais tu joues à l'envers
de la structure en fait là en ça semble
aller encore même si l'ordi donne petit
avantage
blanc
après je dis quand tu alira tu dois
quand même paniquer hein d'avoir perdu
tes échecs par qu'il le
sent ça va pas être facile dans la tête
non parce que là c'est lui le premier
dégoûté de ce qu'il fait
hein j'imagine bien enfin come on disait
lui il doit être exigeent avec envers
lui-même et donc comprendre qu'il y a un
truc qui va pas mais je CIS pas qu'il
estit pas corrigé les finales par exle
justement céit une exigence envers
toi-même que tu as une ambition tu
travailles sur ton point faible et ça
fait plusieurs années que c'est identif
est-ce que c'est possible qu'il y arrive
juste
pas je sais pas comme si tu sais c'éit
un truc qui pouvait pas régler juste je
sais pas physiquement je sais pas trop
comment dire tu r en cassant je veux le
dire ok peut-être le feeling pour M
jouer finale mais une finale théorique
que tu perds en C coups non quoi ça tu
le travaill même si tu comprends rien tu
fais quoi tu fais ton C crâne tu fais ta
défense 7è rangée et tu sais quoi tu
sais tu sais tu peux rien c'est comme tu
y a des joueurs amateurs qui réussissent
après que tu es pas le feeling d'aller
au bon endroit avec ton roi bon ça s gr
autre chose de bien pousser tes
majorités de j'en sais rien moi bon ça
peut arriver différemment mais là ça
donne juste l'on qu'il a juste pas
jamais arer la position de sa vie quoi
la manière dont il a défendu ça donit
l'impression qu'il avait jamais vraiment
étudié donc euh je suis d'accord avec
toi donc là en fait pour le coup c'est
que tu travailles pas
[Musique]
enfin
parce queent pour savoir la défendre il
faut simplement non au pire méaniement
tu pars dans la bonne direction tu te
plantes mais là je pourra expliquer par
le manque de temps et que merde tu as
deux choix et que les coups se ressent
tu sais plus trop bon ok ça peut arriver
mais là c'était faux direct je suis
d'accord avec
toi
et donc je sais pas en fait hein
finalement qu'est-ce qu'il veut vraiment
avec les
échecs très difficile à dire c'est très
très difficile à dire oui je je sais
vraiment pas en
fait c'est très très difficile à à
dire il a aucun doute sur son talent
naturel et tout ça et qu'il est beaucoup
travaillé plein de phases du jeu qu'il a
un très beau jeu vers l'avant offensive
normalement que les positions sont
compliquées il calcule bien il a le sens
de l'initiative des sacrifices ou quoi
au final bon c'était pas trop ça mais il
av va bien le masquer à un moment ça a
été identifié mais en fait de ne jamais
l'avoir corrigé même a priori essayer de
le corriger
ben
ça pose question quoi
la Magnus va juste
le terrasser
ouais on va voir s'il fait jusqu'au bout
mais mais ouais je serai Magnus j'aurais
envie de gagner cette partie en
fait je suis d'accord avec
toi pour punir la
nulité
ça sent vraiment la partie bon après
c'est pas facile pour lui puis il a peu
de temps et là Magnus fait sa partie
doncon c'est un peu différent
ouais mais ça se passe pas trop bien
ouais des fablesse un peu ici ou là
après bon Magnus peut se tromper malgré
tout c'est une position quand même un
petit peu
irrationnelle mais bon ce cavalier bah
il a envie d'aller vers C5 à priori hein
on n pas envie de faire pris en passant
à ramener les pièces adverses C H5 il
est complètement koos maintenant il a le
P 6 un peu
faible pas
facile je français qui sont complètement
à côté
Fab je vais regarder Maxim parce qu'en
fait moi je l'ai complètement en direct
là il est complètement foutu Maxime il
s'est fait déchirer
c'est que G4 je sais pas d' il sort
maisc blanc on va jeter un il juste
parce que
c'est ça allit plutôt
bien bon Mme là ça joue ENF je dire je
sais pas trop s'il est bien ou pas bien
mais
ouais pr une petite
tactique ou bon c'est pas génial pour
Maxime mais c'est pas grave il est
qualifié juste il avait l'opportunité
d'être 4e et de jouer qu'un match enfin
de pouvoir gagner un match sur deux et
là il va être barragiste barragiste donc
il devra faire deux sur deux pour pour
aller plus loin probablement contre
ikarou voilà ou si jamais Magnus venait
à se
tromper mais là ouais Maxim en comme ça
ça va être dur contre ikarou hein ouais
il va se faire déchirer comme ça ikarou
qui peut-être va va passer entre les
mailles et se retrouver quand même après
qu'il bte Magnus ça lui apprendra quoi
enfin faut faire exprès de enfin je sais
pas faut vraiment y aller fa vraiment y
aller ouais fa enfin faut vraiment
perdre
quoi et parce que là en fait quand tu
voas à jouer tu tu as envie qu'il se
qualifie quoi bah oui non mais bon c'est
c'est un
penalty j'ai en fait là tu enfin
franchement sans vouloir être méchant ou
quoi mais tu te dis ala ou lazavi je
sais même pas lequel j'ai plus envie de
jouer honnêtement c'est Bonet blanc et
blan bonnet
quoi on mainant ce que fait Magnus ENF
moi en tant que pourriture absolue
j'aurais j'aurais j'aurais vraiment
juste donné la game
quoi fait F3 G4 et j' attend les
Américains vraiment vraiment très drôle
je vous faire ça regarde je suis
drôle aprs moi jeis une
pourriture n pas tous obligés d'être
pourris
hein non Maxime ça va pas du tout non
plus he là son Nive de je
c'est cataclysmique hein mais il a gagné
quoi il a gagné deux matchs Maxime
B
carou
et non il joue pas bien Maxime ce tour
ça va pas du tout Maxime pour le coup
c'est je sais pas c'est vra un tourno
pas bon il
avait une année 2023 pas si mauvaise bon
quandme pas de qualif candidat donc ça
reste non plus pas génial hein enfin on
va pas dire que c'est fantastique son
année mais il y avait une peut-être un
semblant de mieux à un moment et qui
pourrait se confirmer en 2024 ou quoi en
tout cas ce tournoi là c'est peut-être
un de ses pires paren plus il a perdu
contre la zavic quoi ouais non elle a
vraiment mal joué après après bon ça
peut arriver heinpr si on a un peu moins
dur avec Maxime c'est que c'est moins
kata sur les derniers mois là c'est un
tournoi à côté Alera c'était quand même
vraiment cata la sinkfield cata grand
Suisse Maisa c'est dans la continuité on
va dire
maxime est sur ouais c'est ça sur
courant alternatif mais mais bon le
tournoi il est pas bon il est pas bon
après bon lui au moins il est encore
qualifié et puis ben on sait jamais tant
que tu es encore en vie bah il peut il
peut se passer des bonnes
choses mais
bon mais oui normalement tu retrouves
pas la forme en claquant des doigts
juste parce que d'un coup c'est les
barrages c'est ça sent pas très bon quoi
alors après cararou je pense qu'il peut
le faire
il va être motivé mais enfin des fois
enfin tuas beau être motivé des fois je
cro qu'il est mieux que Maxime quand
même sur ce tourno quoi qu'il en soit il
Caro ouais donc après tu vas Maxime puis
il te reste un B Abdou ou quoi tu peux
enfin marniier kata côté français
globalement
ouais on a pas trop
rêvé ni d'ailleurs chionat d'Europe par
équipe non on a été cata de A à Z et là
va même perdre autant au final puisqu a
une
42 fa que Magnus fasse exprès en fait
non là si fait reprend
pas
G6 là faut vraiment faire exprès pr tu
envie de faire tu reviens sur la
colonin D5 dame C3 enfin je sais pas
bonend peut-êre il va faire
mais
on va
voir qui peut-être avec sa main
seulement peut faire des
choses non mais c'est
dommage mer après un joueur pétri de
talent un peu à l'image d'un Nasri
Samir h pé de talent non bien bon mais
mais qui a peut-être pas fait la
carrière escomptée dire il a fait une
belle carrière quand même oui mais il
fait pas non plus une carrière horrible
attention fait que commencer normalement
mais non mais il a quand même déjà gagné
le grand Suisse a déjà un petit palmarès
he il a déjà joué les candidats ouais
voilà c'est pour ça que j'ai un peu
comme un pour le moment un Nasri Samir
ou un BenArfa
Atem
prend G6 ou
pas
ou le je sais pas
trop on va
voir mais ouais non qui bon en équipe de
France pas eu une grande carrière on va
dire mais qui a quand même
[Musique]
joué City Arsenal qui bon ça va c'est
une car sympa quand même BenArfa
beaucoup de talent et ouais plus en en
club ça été moins
ça
kakutagel ouais lui lui prometteur mais
promur pr une très belle carrière kakut
Gael pét de talent qui joue làen je
crois il fait le bonheur de de am en
Ligue 2 de la
Licorne et pqueta alors qu'est-ce qu'
qui devient P Quieta je crois qu'il joue
en Angleterre il joue il do jouer
à je sais pas est-ce qu'il est à West
Ham je suis pas trop il un scandale non
de de de de de Paris truqué sur les
cartons jaunes non avec Paqueta mais
ancien
Lyonnais mais pas en plus
pet Guimar aussi à Lyon qui parti je
crois Newcastle
[Musique]
ou 5 bien placer central ça dur de tenir
avec une
minute attaque la
dame qu'ilasse
exprès le RO qu'une
case aller pourqu tu joue tempo ah
il joue quoi mais désolé hein
mais il te reste 27 qu avec une nuit de
20 tu peux pas investir 10 secondes sur
R G8 en
fait qu' peut une fin avec P de moins il
prend G6 il prend 5 prend 7 7 pr 5 vite
en B3 bon le problème c'est que c'est
son compartiment du jeu pas ouf maison
de toute façon tu mets la tour en B3 tu
vas quand même tu montes le ouais il est
quand même capable de la perdre
évidemment mais c'est mieux de se faire
matter bon Magnus qui en tout cas aura
pas été impérial avec sa position
magnifique
mais il va la gagner quand même et qui
joue quand même qui quand même voilà
avantage à la pendule
mais il su trop et et de
l'attaque qu' a plus que une seconde par
cou il lu reste 26 cou à jou en une
100 MC6 bon je sais pas je plusieurs
coup de va
aller il fait G5 pas mal vous chasser ce
cavalier allez tour D8 dame D7 alors
peut-être dame F6 non ouais tu veux pas
te prendre D5 échec dam 7 peut-être dama
7 k C 5 6 ah il fait k 5 quand même bien
joué G6 on peut ou pas j'aurais jouer ro
G6
ouais h
50 secondes 22 coups pour récupérer la
seconde donc c'est quand même assez
important allez ça va en fait enfin
c'est pas du tout infaisable tour des 5
peut-être pour tout bloquer j'ai 4 j'ae
bien compliqué mais pourquoi pas enfin
j'aurais pas fait mais bah ça perd tout
de suite
non
juste
as juste donné un pion mais bon ça se
trouve c'est pas si grave mais c'est ou
regarde il pas
vu pas vu quoi il a pas vu puis on prend
qu' pitendre 5 regarde ça la
caméra ça va ça SAU encore un peu les
meubles il a du damage de peut-être qui
arrive il va encore mettre des plombes
pourer il fa vite il fait des petits
échecs ici ou là à tempo quoi mais il va
juste tomber en fait
pris Dame des ouais bon je sais pas
c'est compliqué avec cette dame qui D3
peut-être pour se blinder mais
ou il va juste perdre a temps parce que
il a secondes une seconde parcour mais
sa gestion du temps elle est vraiment
horrible il y a rien qui va remonte faut
jouer faut jouer
mais il joue
pas qui va monter mais prends vite mais
joue a 12 secondes 15 coups c'est encore
faisable mais faut arrêter de de
réfléchir
là des TR peut-être ou 6 E6 jouer par
carlen D F5 peut-être dame5 pour bloquer
les échecs ou ou roi
D6 10 secondes pour 14 il va juste pas y
arriver mais bon gestion du temps une
nouvelle
fois on a vu
mieux 3 des6 jouer il va tomber
ouais Magnus aura tout fait pour pas
gagner mais il est pas arrivé mais il
est pas arrivé
ouais là il a 4 minutes pour être
précis 7 secondes pour 13 cou et une
position
4 ou quoi bloque le pion prend la roi on
pourra faire E7 au coup
d'après en D3 bon aussi il va juste
tomber en
fait tomb je pense à ce
non mais bon
c'est c'est perdant mais c'est
c'est catastrophique en
fait5 mauvais coup en fait pas si mal au
vu des coups mais en fait tu dois pas
faire c'est just trop compliqué
n'importe quoi t
D5 c'est bien ou moi je pensais à du G4
après là non c'est là en fait mais4 ça
l'air sympa tu veux faire damage 4 tu
non mais ça c'est un coup bien agressif
et bien mais tour D5 pour stabiliser par
réfléchir j'aime bien aussi quoi ça en
vrai c'est
cool
bon c'est chaud mais au moins tu peux
mettre des échecs et jouer
vite bravoarou qualifi malgré lui non
lui ce qu'il il a battu laavic Maxime
qui on imagine et c'est quoi fait contre
il a perdu contre ça change rien fait
pas le score parfait fait pas la
performance de gangster attention
écoutez on a un peu le
se vraiment l'impression que pour pas le
gagner celui-là fallait faire des
efforts quoi ouais ouais ouais mais bon
ben c'est fait euh donca éliminé qui
pourra bon ben rentrer en de son P
nord-américain qui s'est pas très bien
passé et je sais pas quand on le reverra
dans un échiquet je crois que c'est
inscrit au champion du monde rapid et
Blitz voir sa tête sur la fiche vera
sûrement du 26 au 30 Fab alors on va
mettre la petite interview Puma et on r
après on se retrouve bah dans pour les
pour la suite hein pour le barrage là
maintenant c'est le plus intéressant qui
arrive là déjà c'était cétait c'était V
génial
mais on va monter ouais on va monter
dans
étage how does 7 and half hours on the
touch to you today thanks to Puma we're
bringing two geniuses together from the
world of football and the world of chess
we are joined by Pep Guardiola and
Magnus Carlson thank you for joining us
we're going to take a look at your
greatest moves and let's start with a
clip that many City fans will probably
remember yeah I remember this season
close and everyone you see the image and
everyone is in his position and you said
you in the left side you know and now
attack right side he had to be quicker
so now you need this kind of situations
you know actions one against one be
patient in the right moment punish them
how is the moment here go left m in the
right runs in behind and finish 46
passes in that move Magnus that's um
very very impressive how important is is
patience in chess as well cuuse PEP just
spoke about the the patients and the
buildup and and stuff like that as well
that's often what happens in chess you
maneuver you maneuver try to find
weaknesses and then crack appears and
then it all you know goes very very
quickly but once you mentioned that it's
fen against the forest i I remembered
the I was really looking forward to the
last move buuse it's really beautiful
another display of attacking mastery
what do you remember about this Magnus
this was like a typical C counterattack
like I was being pressured most of the
game then he made one mistake four five
uh quick moves you know was Checkmate on
the other side it was indeed but you
actually played a game against Ian which
lasted so so long seven and a half
hours
136 moves first things first how were
you feeling after that marathon when you
played against i good I was to I was to
play more yeah because that's because
that was the key breakthrough that was
the moment I've been waiting for for the
first six
um games of of of that match and I
remember like I was so calmed so focused
for the last two two and a half hours I
was playing with fair little time on my
clock but I knew like this is my chance
like if I win if I win this game i'm
probably winning Another World
Championship so I knew that that was uh
that was my moment and uh I was ready to
go like three more hours if if I needed
to I was I was going to get that wi how
does seven and a half hours on the touch
sound to
you no way no
[Musique]
way
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors les amis ça va reprendre euh ça va
reprendre ça jou ça repris mais en fait
ouais c'est ça ah oui moi j'ai pas tu es
pas dans le bon tournoin ouais mais
attends euh je crois que j'ai que j'ai
un que que j'ai un truc à changer
ouais voilà et là c'est bon voilà
alors pourquoi on a le délai parce que
tu as peut-être pas le truc adminine ah
ouais j'ai pas le truc
admin est-ce que tu as un lien secret
pour aller
dessus bah j'ai pas plus les
parties euh
ouais alors là je sais pas quoi
faire bon vont arriver au pire on aura
du retard par rapport à la cam et puis
voilà
ouais je suis d'accord avec toi HM donc
bon l'enjeu juste pour vous expliquer
hein Maxime affronte Ikar Nakamura
euh ils sont euh le loser bracket
quelque part on va dire que pour faire
simple quatre joueurs sont dans les
barrages pour deux places qualificatives
il y a un match entre carwana et ydu
satorf le vainqueur de ce match sera
qualifié pour les demi-finale et le
perdant jouera contre le vainqueur de ce
match là pour la dernière place
voilà alors le truc c'est que l'autre
partie
marche est-ce qu'ils l'ont mal mis
quelque
part bon pire c'est pas grave on regarde
l'autre hein bon on regarde l'autre on
regarde l'autre
euh je un œil hein mais
ça peut être là-dedans en MO il mal mis
mais ouis non non je crois qu'il y a un
un bug ah ça y
est ok
ok on va voiraro en petite forme Maxime
aussi
ouais
ouis j'esère que Maxime se sublimer pour
pour ce match c'estra qu'il nous fait
petite impression pour l'instant depuis
le début de ce tournoi mais euh écoute
arrivriver RB finale ça serait bah une
belle grolation quoi il y a quand même
50 K à aller chercher voir plus c'est
infinité
ouais Maxime qui se lève déjà mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il clique et que il se
barre dans ce tournoi non c'est ça c'est
qu'il joue vite bien ou pas il s'en fout
ou il joue juste il veut pas calculer
andme il a pas
tort
il fait comme il veut il pas il y a pas
de
souci ah ouais il clique il clique tempo
c'est tout ce qui l'intéresse c'est de
cliquer
ouais il clique clic clic c'estes coups
qui lui
plaisent donc la partie euh bon on peut
se refaire les premierers coups
peut-être moi je les j'ai fait tu as pas
bon c'était une une Rimo ça je sais mais
ouais ouais avec D6 c'est ça
D6 norm en bo2 plus arm magadon B je
crois hein oui c'est la même chose que
ce qu'on a vu jusqu'àors
ch pas une équipe qui gagne pour la
finale seulement demi-finale la demi
déjà c'est c'est les 7 en qu partiesou
mais la finale c'est pas encore plus non
non c'est
pareil partir de demain partir demain ça
changera ce sera qu parties et un
Armagedon pour un set et il y aura de
set il va garder tout son énergie pour
aller chercher le titre de champion du
monde de Blitz j'espère l'impression qu'
manque d'énergie Maxime j'espère qu'il
va réussir à se refaire la serise entre
maintenant et le 26 décembre il a de
semaines faut bien dormir faire un peu
de sport et voilà mais il est
loin difficile des fois ça fait
longtemps que tu es pas chez toi il
mangit des fruits et des des
courges des légumes de saison tuppte les
nutriments dont tu as besoin
maintenant doit être assez confiant je
sais pas quand tu as joué relativement
mal que tu es passé avec le bol et tout
j'ai l'impression que ça t'enlève poids
quoi tu dois tellement pas être là ouais
après il a ouais dans leur matchup en
général il a un bon score contre Maxime
alors il a quand même perdu l'autre jour
le
affrontement mais historiquement c'est
vrai que c'est pas un adversaire qui a
aussi très très bien Maxime dans ses
champion de chest tour et
compagnie en plus Maxime en petite forme
et ikarou il est passé il s il a dû se
voir éliminer à plusieurs reprises ikaro
aujourd'hui déjà Cera c'est incroyable
qu'il a perdu le match contre
carlen cage de jouer multifonction peut
laisser le passage à la dame peut
préparer F4 mais surtout pour jouer
cavalier hg4 pour aller échanger le
cavalier F6 qui est un défenseur de la
case D5 pour peut-être venir s'y
installer euh par la suite il est
peut-être mieux là quand même Maxime
ouais mais pas de beaucoup de toute
façon c'est une position solide pour
il va falloir faire le travail côté
français on espère en tout cas
qu'ilimou nakamoura mourra pas dans ce
tournoisz on peut rentrer C2 préparer du
déco à
TR c'est que du bonus pour ikarou
mais des fois quand tu es libéré comme
ça ouais
justement pourquoi sque la belle de
forme des Français bah Maxime c'est un
peu l'âge et alira sûrement qui
travaille pas beaucoup voire pas du
tout choisi F des5 Plô que c c'est bien
aussi que en cas d'échange en 5 disons
du Fou peut-être du P C 5 mvlesque en
dehors de la Chiquet Max qui connaî bien
c'est cavalier A5 tu va peut-être
pouvoir lui faire subir le même sort que
qu' a subi lui-même par le
passé
dés choses qui me font
rire aussi qui
rigole
H7 boner nous déployer tout ça j'a bien
le plan de l'ordi de revenir vers F5 du
coup pourquoi pas
3 B4 bien aussi G4
peut-être cavalier
G5 l'stant de toute façon il y a pas F5
donc on s'en fiche un peu de ce cavalier
H7 il juste passer son F G5 je sais pas
ce qu'il
ve qu' veut F
g5is en tout
cas3
et du coup k F1 fou G5 il veut
quoi just G3 ouais prends 3 mais tu
reprends quand mêmeprès je prends des5
je fais F5 je veux
dire bon on verra si le
jour
ouis une question intéressante sur la
limite physique d'âge à partir un moment
où tu peux plus peut-être jouer à haut
niveau
oui et non en fait je dirais on a vu
Adam par 52 ans gagner le le tournoi à
Londres c'est pas un tournoi de top
niveau mais c'est quand même face à des
joueurs pas mal et qui ont 20 30 ans de
moins que lui
euh juste en fait tu contrôles plus trop
ce qui se passe et si tu vas pas bien
enfin si ton corps répond pas il répond
pas pas tu contrôles plus tout ça quoi
donc tu es encore capable de de belles
performances si en fait tout s'aligne
bien et que bah je sais pas c'est le bon
ça s'aligne bien
ouais mais tu peux moins planifier ta
forme je pense c'est ça surtout le truc
principal deuxième chose après bah c'est
ça dépend de chacun mais c'est à quel
point tu ares à garder ta et ta
motivation avec le temps qui passe parce
que bah tu as déjà joué tellement fait
tellement de tournois tellement fait
d'efforts d'entraînement deci de là un
moment tu en as marre et c'est même
chose même en sport où des fois certains
prennent leur retraite parce que leur
physique ne peut plus répondre et qu's
sont soit des blessures soit il courent
moins vite machin moment il ok c'est bon
j'arrête mais tu as des gens qui
arrêtent relativement jeunes mais parce
que usé aussi mentalement et cetera quoi
et puis cognitivement tu es quand même
plus lent après hein toute façon oui
quoi qu'il en
soit ça c'est connu et reconnu
hein çaerveau molit avec l'âge mais
c'est un tout en fait tu as moins de
motivation tuas physiquement un peu
moins bien ton cerau qui molit
etpr je pense que c'est aussi lié tu as
aussi moins de motivation parce que tu
sens que tu es plus mou que tu es plus
lent enfin c'est tu sais que tu vas
faire moins bien ça te fait chier aussi
ou un vieillir ça fait pas plaisir on se
sens plus plus plus plus
bête tu le sens tu le sais hein tu sens
ta bêtise non ouais alors c'est
différent après tu es plus sage entre
guillemets si on veut tu as sûrement
plus d'érudition même mais euh c'est
plus dur d'apprendre des choses
nouvelles de te lancer dans nouvelles
disciplines de d'avoir de nouveaux
apprentissages ouais ou mais même mettre
à jour ses connaissances quand les
choses évoluent et tout
ouais mais tout dépend à quelle vitesse
quoi si ça suit un rythme pas trop
soutenu que c'est des micro mis à jour
ça va aller si c'est
révolutionnaire ça te fait même chier en
fait quoi tuas pas appris à faire les
choses comme ça ça rien à
voir bah on vieillit tout simplement
niveau calcul est ce que ça se ressent
bah ouais ouais puis niveau énergie à un
moment tu dois jouer la 4e heure de jeu
5e heure de jeu être encore
précis pas évident hein non non mais làâ
c'est vraiment un naufrage
hein non
mais c'est réel
hein
que le cerveau qui molit ça va ouais
aussi mais tout qui molit avec
l'ge tu voisancien exact clairement plus
lent hésitant ouais des fois tu deviens
aussi bête c'est terrible
l'âge il est juste temps de de laisser
la place
Fabien disparaître en quelque
sorte le cycle de la vie cycle de la vie
et c'est tant mieux laisser la place aux
autres
bon après encore faut-il qu'il puisse la
prendre par des fois faut laève tu dis
oui bon fautil qu'il puisse la prendre
mais c'est l'ordre des
choses quelque part voir la politesse de
disparaître si tu ne sais pas partir
ouais ça je
FA
pitesse
déc niveau depuis sa naturation et sa
vie à Paris je pense pour ma part que
les envis de jeunesse ont pris le dessus
sur son travail en ambition aux échecs
qui le sens de ses déclaration il est
devenu un joueur dilétant c'est comme ça
après c'est normal tu as tu as tu as 19
20 ans tu gagnes un million d'euros par
an ou je sais pas combien de millions
plus cass
enfin tuas desain VI de furieux
c'est cool
hein mais après donc je sais pas à quel
point il est diléant totalement ou pas
mais peutêtre pas dil je peux comprendre
les meufs la mode enfin surtout les
meufs un peu la mode ou un peu la mode
beaucoup les meufs enfin je sais pas tu
vois
mais tout façon Paris c'est une ville
qui a coulé beaucoup de sportifs en
réalité Ronaldinho par exemple combien
de footballeurs se
sont en allant à Paris Paris c'est
vraiment une
ville coul détruit les gens
fait
c'est vrai faut faut avoir la force
mentale de pas de pas se détruire là-bas
Mbappé se détruit pas trop un peu quand
même un peu carrière carrière mais
mais ronaldho il un peu fait le foufou
mais bon ça pas empêché d'aller Brill un
peu après quand même il a pas mais quand
il est parti maisantil était à Paris il
était catastrophique
même
bonjou c'est une ville qui ser s
paillettes faut avoir une une force
mentale pour là pour Paris c'est une
ville qui te tire vers le bas je
dirais mieux d'aller jouer à
Saint-Étienne en fait tu peux êre plus
focus quoi sur le
terrain c'est comme
ça après évidemment à cet âge là c'est
tellement facile
de de se laisser séduire de se laisser
séduire
ouais mais un peu comme dans du Las
Vegas hein un truc comme ça ça do ça
être facile hein les Vegas je vois pas
comment tu pe vivre il y a rien bah
justement non mais tu justement tu peux
pas enfin non mais c'est vraiment pire
que ce que je pensais
hein parce que normalement ça te vend du
rêve tu vois ça de loin tu vois ça êre
mais en fait euh
en fait non enfin je vous déconseille
quoi
ouis nmar aussi ouais Mar ouais non mais
c'est pas Famar il s sacrément détruit
he
mais c'est un peu le syndrome Paris
quoi c'est pas le premier pas le dernier
he à
non à
sombrer alle on va reprendre ce pion pas
mal hein
Maxime qui
est je pense motivé pour la partie hein
il joue pas trop il se met pas retard la
pendule il gère bien pour l'instant
c'est bien non Maxim fait sa partie
clairement belle partie pour le
coup qui veut casser ce
centre à av on n pas obligé de de trop
réagir
car qui suit un peu quand
même bon il essaye hein de casser CRE
mais voilà mais je pense on peut se
laisser prendre 4 pour faire d pr et
maintenir ce beau fou D5 bon juste F pre
ça va menacer le fou en F4 tout seul
donc bah so on fait un C comme dame D2
mais on sera peut-être s D4 qui
arriveront se on retire le
fou même t F1 peu bizarre ma fois mais
pourquoi
pas
dam coup ouis va attaquer ce cavalier
C6 Maxim parisien on dit aussi pass
c'est peut-être ce qui lui a coûté à un
moment donné de sa carrière d'ailleurs
faire la
différence c'est
ouais c'est comme
ça
en fait je suis en train de cacher un
truc
débile ça ça ça ça ça ça tu prends le 6
et tu fais le
5 parce que c'est M mieux tu menaces
vraiment Caval 5 mais t C8 qui F3 en oui
mais du coup je c'est une
menace tu ro H8 ou quoi mais du coup
c'est une
ouais c'est même les f je sais pas trop
qu'il y a le fou F4 en l'èord dit que ça
tient mais oui enfin normalement tu vas
pas non ça tu ouais mais enfin tu vas
pas commencer à regarder dam enfin ça tu
vas jamais
jouer bon normalement non non mais
peut-être à la non mais tu fais ro H8
mais oui normalement tu fais tour C qui
F3 ro H8
ou c'est la partie hein il va faire ro
H8 ou tour
F6
et il va Miami c'est
ça sympa Miami je pense j'ai jamais mis
les pieds mais ça ça me dira
bien do faire assez beau toute
l'année
ça être assez joli ouais
Miami sorte de canne des États-Unis
peut-être un peu moins bien quand même
probablement ça va êre en dessous quand
même
était New Yorkais on nous dit c'est bien
aussi abusé que Paris çaempêché en
rien certes mais disons en fait tu peux
réussir de partout selon qui t enfin à
Paris c'est just que tu te mets des
bâons dans les roues quoi Zlatan pas
gâcher sa carrière à Paris par exemple
mais
euh comme il y a plus de sollicitation
et cetera potentiellement c'est plus
possible et c'est arrivé plus souvent al
c'est même factuel en fait he c'est même
pas et donc ficher en fait il aurait pu
être n'importe où sur la planète de
toute façon c'était un moine qui pensait
qu'X échec on va dire ou puis bon en
terme de longévité que une cha comme fr
c'est pas non plus bah oui c'est mental
il a pas non plus très bien fin aussi
cette influence peut-être aussi
oui mon ficher il a peut une vie
magnifique quoi quand
même en tant que joueur d'échec il est
légendaire
mais le dit a pas aimer Maxim aime bien
prendre les
pions
en tout cas c'est clair que pour un
joueur d'échec l'environnement est
important
ouais même pour tout sportif je pense en
fait hein mais pour un jur d'échec ouais
il faut être en phase avec ton
environnement et et pouvoir t'entraîner
t'épanouir être
être
relâché Maxim un pion de
plus Onir qu' moins de 5 minutes
maintenant
globalement les grandes villes c'est
difficile pour les
sportifs aussi la la pollution de l'air
la saleté tu peux tomber plus facilement
malade
j'en sais quelque chose les ou côté
pollution de l'air sale tu vois ça te
ralentit aussi le cerveau bah oui d' on
sait quelque chose grâce au boîtiering
complètement ouis qui nous renseigne
très bien ce
sujet et oui la qualité de l'air c'est
aussi important Fab d'aurs elle est
comment la qualité de l'air aujourd'hui
elle est bonne je vois beaucoup de vert
mais un petit truc rouge peut-être quand
même qu'est-ce que c'est c'est la
température 25°gr
il faudrait une température à quoi 22 23
peut-être maxi peut-être même 19 ou 20
Fab est-ce que l'empourrissement de
Miami
va va coûter éit plus cher que celui de
Paris en fait dans cette partie c'est la
question
Fab je pense Miami tu quand même un
meilleur air quoi tu tonnes sur la mer
euh par plus de vent doit balayer tout
ça en
fait après je sais pas trop he n de
surmulot présent à
Miami
en tout cas qui sur mais ça se sent
qu'il est pas en forme dans l'attitude
quand tu vois à la caméra ouais jeis TR
très stressé dans son dans sa partie
contre Abd satorov hier paniqué tremblé
on voit pas trop comme ça d'habitude on
le voit dominant très sûr de lui et même
en interview à dire que de toute façon
c'était pas important parce qu' don et
tout ça d'ailleurs et là il avait l'air
de de quer
quoi to cette attaque la dame qui vend
assist bonne nouvelle pour lui s'il se
faisait éliminer rapidement là c'est
qu'il pour aller jouer le title Tuesday
ah oui le Late et
oui peut-être retrouver des sensations
pour se refaire un peu la cerise se
rassurer sur
Internet
ah il a l'air de suer hein ça se
voit
dur de faire pire que Paris ouais après
il peut y avoir des
candidats Pkin ça a l'air aussi assez
compliqué alors là cavalier5 ça doit pas
marcher parce que le cavalier doit se
faire enfermer en F7 après gen dame D6
C7 et bouff
ouais on juste reprend sinon
hein
ce qui est peut-être étonnant pour dans
le choix de la variante c'est que là tu
laisses quand même l'option C 5 ouais et
aend 4
ouais alors que dans l'autre sens tu
faisis pas t d'abord 5 par complètement
débile
quoi peêtre un truc qu'on a pas compris
hein
ça l' de bien se passer pour Maxime
quand même il pourrait prendre le lead
Chion de plus pour l'instant c'est
bien il la son pion de
plus il est en train d'oblitérer ikarou
il menace qui 5 un ikarou minuscule dans
ce tournoi l'ombre de
lui-même il a plus qu'une minute à la
pendule après peut-être qu'il est déjà
en mode préparation pour les candidats
est-ce que c'est possible d'après
toi ah oui qui se prépare les candidats
à sa place je le ferai parce que il a un
shot pour essayer d'être champion du
monde et B c'est une chance d'une vie en
fait j'ai envie de dire donc faut faut
la prendre tu peu quoi
euh que tu pens que ça le démotive un
peu pour ces tournois finalement
c'estans grand enjeu pour lui maintenant
parce qu'il est quand même évalué il do
avir plus de 50 millions d'euros sur son
compte en banque he déjà donc 200000 de
plus de moin mais du coup enfin c'est
pas enfin au pire viens pas alors oui pe
Tu Vi juste voilà parce que euh je CIT
es là après tu joues quoi mais il joue
là
oui mais tu joues du mieux possible
comme tu dis tu
joues de quoi il joue il
joue il joue il joue tout tout tout
trouve un joli coup
tu peux pas faire GF t PR 6 tour8
cavalier F8 F D6 sur T pr F3 tour F1
prise prise et le cavalier rest finito
oua G5 un truc comme ça tu peux sûement
garder un petit pon de
plus et tour 8 c'est tour F8 et ça
défant ou mais tu restes avec ton
plus
que8 pr F3 bon c'est d quand même ok
pere5 qui arrive mais bon j'ai du mal à
croire que c'est si dramatique ah je
vais faire T8 direct
ouis mais T8 tu reprends8 puis on prend
tu reprends F4 peutre oui c'est ça mais
je bon de plus5 je vois mais
bon c'est pas de chance si si c'est si
simple pour les
Nord Maxime qui va dans
celle-là il un P de plus en final c'est
très bien Marant que tu fasse pas
le quel touloulou je sais pas
bien et la bonne nouvelle c'est ce pion
B6 sur cas noir fixé
là-bas le Roi peut monter le fou va
essayer de faire une petite focale au
cavalier le pion à 4 à un
moment on peut
travailler K a toujours besoin d'argent
c'est sa raison de
vivre je penseil serait content de
prendre un peu plus d'argent et
peut-être que là il a justement il est
dans la peut-être la seule phase de sa
vie où l'argent bon reste quand même le
truc le plus important bien évidemment
mais où
euh quand même si de champion du monde
je pense que ça peut avoir plus
d'importance pour lui que la Cillas
parce que ça peut l' de la caas après en
de tempss c'est pas de la cayas
immédiate c'est de la caas à venir
peut-être que dans son calcul tu vois le
jour j'ai vu en interview ilandit oui
qu'est-ce que tu fais entre les parties
ou quoi je regardais la bourse tu vois
tu bravo monsieure fr quoi
CP 500 il est là
ouais beaucoup plus intéressant quoi de
très belles
[Musique]
valeurs est-ce qu'il y a air
Liquide a liquide
américain
exon sûrement il doit avoir he je pense
je pense qu'il y a du
exon et quand même étaé il avait dit
hein qu'il avait été en grosse vente à
découvert sur Tesla
donc mal joué en
fait allez on active le roi c'est bien T
g au prochain
coup devrait l'emporter 18 secondes
c'est dur de bien défendre ça on l'a vu
hier contre Abd vraiment suer une finale
plus simple mais bon là il a quand même
le rajoute temps de 3 secondes alors
c'était que une seconde ça fait quand
même une différence une TR fois plus
tap donc on pe pas prendre à
45 il faire8 F5 des cou comme ça
sur5 c'est
déb pasar pas mettre le punch final
quoi
on prend t B5 j'imagine
ouais il se dit qu'il a foir à tout
moment qu'il a les
douuches prend fou prend C6 F C3 tu
reviens et D4 D5 et tu est-ce que tu
arrives pas
sûr euh benah faut regarder tour a 5
tour prend fou prend k C6 F C3
à2 il a préfère le jouer comme ça ok bon
ça va pas changer réfléchiss aussi bouf
bouf k C6 fou C3 à 2 en fait sur D4 il
veut peut-être qu'ille B4 il prend le
roi C2 cel dit tu peux monter ton roi
donner ton fou contre a de et euh tuas
un cavalier de moins mais tu as les
pions le roi et compagnie mais ça
devrait ressembler à ça parce qu'en fait
sinon ok D4 on y va D4 qui D4 qui B4
qui5 on pas F5 ah peut-être plus fort F5
G5
F6 je crois que je fer des 4 ouais je
commence aussi par D4 k B4 OK et on te
fait soit D5 soit 5 ouais C2 ro F6 ou D5
C5 prend
F4 TR attends mais comment ça 5 des TR
ok bon ben je reviens en le4 ils V en B4
et je ferai des 5 tant pis F2 ah il nous
emmerde quoi fais des coups normal
normaux mais je fais du
il a fait 5 en fait3 qui éta la variante
m de l'ordi mais tu arrivrives pas à
enfermer le
truc l'impression qu'
B3 je m'en fousoandis C5 quand tu fais
dou je je te
bloque dit que c'est nul mais je trouve
pas que ce soit nul quoi ça pas l'air
nul ça bug évidemment parce que c'est
des réel donc on peut pas voir les fin
de partie comme souvent
c'est dommage mais c'est la la loi de
des échiqu f c'est dommage qu'on a pas
au moins une caméra quoi pour ouais mais
après il est sur c'est sur la prode
américaine secouer la tête il est pas
arrivé à faire dame en tout
cas la je est bien remonté on pensait
qu'il était très bien AC les blancs il
va pouvoir jouer avec C6 c'est le bon
pion à pousser qui va s sur case blanche
le fout sur case noir il travaille bien
de concert ensemble attention on a pas
des donc il faudra après
peut-être pourquoi pas les bouffer fait
de un moment tout à fait C6 jouer
peut-être un un roi
C4 cavalier E3 et je ferai ro C55
ouais c'est de
D6 bon on va pas tout pr non le RO B3
ouais r B3 très bien bon C5 çare pas si
mal non aussi dé bien ro B3 mais ro B3
tuouffer le P ouais mais c'est c'est
bien enfin genre je rien contre le coup
euh bah là j'ai envie de te faire des6
ouais c'est ça PR6 prend6 machin on
transpose bon D7 doit pas être trop mal
vient là quand même
encore 3 pour JIR des G4
atttion et on met le le fou
peut-être il va faire G4
là et
H3 onre 7
F5 3 D5 encore
ro des 5 ah mais ro D5 C7 H2
C8 H1 et D8 dam ok tu fais deux dames
deff quo là F5 ça devrait faire c'est
bon le fou défond
h26 on le prend et next c'est fou C7 bon
un
peu j'ur fait F F4 aussi pour interdire
cavali 5 et maintenant monter le
roit et voilà et voilà victoire de
Maxime bien joué Maxime bon ma petite
pause jusqu'à la partie suivante mais
très bien regard ikarou
ikarou qui bat Abdou alors il y aura une
partie retour on verra mais Fabi qui
pourrait être en pass de se qualifier
pour les demi-finales et le vainqueur du
match entre Maxime et ikarou retrouver
peut-être Abd sat on va voir en tout cas
très bonne chose de faite pour Maxim de
batter
carou faudra tenir dans la seconde ronde
mais écoute sur ce qu'il a montré là on
est
[Musique]
confiant
dis now
from.com m in mag and swap them whenever
you like make your move get an exclusive
discount on all metal posters shop now
with the code ch
[Musique]
displate.com
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les amis on s'est complètement fait on s
fait battre par le début c'est vraiment
difficile d'antici
les horaires les horaires ouais c'est
très très
difficile bon toujours estil que Maxime
allez noir il mène à zé et Ikar ah Ikar
je ventre du répertoire facile voà c'est
F5 si ma le répertoire facile F5 d'2 et
tu lu BCES
binco tu va partir connais max s non non
mais F5 c'est sûr dame 2 c'est sûr et
normalement c'est Dame C7 qu'il faut
jouer j'ai 3 B5 je crois mémoire tu es
pas obligé le B5 mais c'est le le coup
le plus
fort en tout cas F5 c'est
garanti c'estèement garanti
ouais c'est quoi fait vraiment facile
quoi Carana il jou les 4 D4 il te fait
ça bah
ouais F5 je crois qu' été joué par
Maxime si je crois voir la caméra donc
les ne doivent pas prendre en passant
parce que c'est trop trop simple pour le
Nord qui aura le centre et gagner encore
du temps sur la dame la dame doit partir
en
E2 les choses les choses sérieuses
commenceront vraiment en demi-finale
hein fa demain ouais mais bon déjà il
faut y
être il faut y être je crois qu'il a
joué F5 he comme tu dis mais
malheureusement on a le bon lien ou ah
on a peut-être pas le bon
lien mais pourquoi j'ai pas le bon lien
tu
r désolé en fait les liens se
ressemblent non il a fait C7 coup on se
retrouve parfois sur le
mauvais C7 je suis un peu inqu de ce que
fait Maxime je comprends pas en fait
connais peut-être pas tout simplement
non mais c'est pas possible con
pas que F5 ça plus le même sens REP en
ou quoi tu bloques plus le F F1
tuux quand même jouer avec D6 non mais
ça va tu joues aux échecs mais les
blancs ils ont ce qu'ils veulent le fou
il peut se mettre en batterie avec la
dame tu as l'espace dangereux quoi c'est
la force du répertoire facile Fab normal
de bas c'est censé être moins bien avec
les Blancs
quoi sur le je noir al r facile en fait
tu es pas tu es pas super foutu c'est un
bon répertoire il est fait pourouerers à
1300 1400 qui évidment vont rien
connaître
mais
comme quoi
Fab ne pas sous-estimer les 1300
1400 5 c'est bien
joué on prend F prend on se développe
non il prend pas ça va être une
structure plus de
françaises mais des7 il ve fut F4 et F6
peut-être
fa5 mais bon à
voir B4 aussi intéressant faut B5 fa
D7 pourrait changer ce fou B4 ouais le
pion c'est
tropcloué écoute on verra mais ouais
peut-être cette décision de dame 2 de
prise en
passant peut avoir des petites
idées ça l'air assez bien joué de la
part d' carou quand même il a une
position
une 40 11 40 pour Maxim il pr un peu de
retard au temps pas habituel dans ce
tournoi non mais bon pourquoi pas pour
le
coup non juste c'est pas habituel pour
lui ici non mais bon justement est très
motivé pour ce match après éliminer
cararou fait toujours plaisir à tout le
monde he ouais puis là c'est c'est les
matchs coup PRS quoi donc tu as plus
trop le droit à l'erreur autant avant
bon tu fais ton t
abon là tuas plus le droit à
l'erreur d'ailleurs c'est intéressant si
Maxime Alencar je sais pas si so
déciderait plutôt de jouer contre Maxime
ou contre
caroana j'ai Maxim c'est pas un super
matchup pour so ouais mais Carona non
plus je sais pas en fait soit il prend
Maxime parce qu'il l'a battu dans le
tournoi et qu'il a perdu contre carwana
pour éviter le mec qui t'a battu d'utre
côté Maxime l'avait s dominé pres ouais
soit soit soit ils s'en fous et il
demandent l' de Dieu quoi tu vois il
fait il est temps de voir des signes et
et il choisira je sais
pas G6 suppose être une
faute un peu bizarre G6 G6 aussi ça fait
pas très bon ménage en général mais bon
bon pi trog il ne sait pas où trouver la
facile il ne l'a jamais vu il est pas
que contre la il surtout sur la chaîne
Blitz stream mais ça fait déjà plusieurs
années qu'il est là après YouTube met
pas trop en avant ce type de conten
c'est dommage il met plus de la merde en
avant mais B
important quand même il met en avant ce
que les gens
regardent mais bon c'est pas trop dur de
chercher en fait enfin mais bon qu
faut-il savoir ça exist ça c'est pas
forc non mais c'est pas forcément vrai
c'est pas forcément facile VO même là on
avait fait le super
répertoire sur le système de Londre avec
les noirs pour commencer avec Matthieu
cornet quand même tu bon là youtube il
te met en avant répertoire où dès le
deuxème ou 3è coup les coups principaux
sont déjà plus analysés beaucoup plus
intéressant plus facile oui bon bah s
tout est plus facile ça te donne des
pions et des dames au lieu de de jouer
des bon coups surtout que si on te
toutes les marantes sauf cell qui réfute
ton truc je suis un truc qui est censé
être mauvais et on te montre tout sauf
le truc qui fait que tu es mal doncpr tu
regardes bon tu es très heureux
mais genre c'est facile quoi comme ça
c'est bien ben ouis mais bon oui bravo
vraiment très bon contenu facile à
prendre c'est sûr
ouis
mais mais ouais écoute c'est comme ça
Fab donc j'ai j'ai euh écoute on trouve
pas ça joue ouf mais euh mais ils font
ce qu'ils peuvent euh Carl senso ont
survolé les califes caroana pas l'air
trop mal après ça suit un peu plus mais
on verra à partir donc surtout de demain
les demifinale où où où le spectacle va
être à son
comble sera le vrai début du tournoi
pour moi demain là on est quand même
dans un échauffement quoi échauffement
qui prend quand même déjà la moitié du
temps mais ouais ils seront bien
échauffés comme ça ouais mais c'est là
qu'on va arriver à la au moment
culminant c'est un comme la phase de
califre de la bcup ETH
ouais et ouais pour gcar non j'ai 6 6 ça
va pas trop ensemble bah simplement tu
vois bien que tu fais des trous et le
dragon tu touches pas au pion tu mets le
pion D6
pas6 al après des fois tu peuxir des
ventes ù ça va bouger mais c'est des cas
particuliers et l'un dans l'autre non ça
fait pas bon ménage ensemble mais là
Maxim il va perdre
he il fait pas une bonne partie après
bon je sais pas il peut s'accrocher il
est pas foutu mais effidemment avec les
Blancs tu as des plans très simples
c'est H4 H5 voilà H4 H5 tu peux bouger
ta toour le F1 G3 et d tout ça euh et tu
as pas de contre J clé noir qui B6 pas
grand-chose tu as pas ton jeu sur E5 F6
que tu peut-être faire un moment là ça
pas l'air trop bien passé rien que pour
pion prend pr F4 puis on prend G7 et tu
fais des mauvais échanges c'est la
partie mais tu vas être faible sur case
noir horrible la partie donc au moins tu
te fais pas maté mais juste tu es faible
stratégiquement
là bon suff d'éviter le 5 avec les blanc
bien sûr hein
bah non pas trop dur je dire oui F B5
bien
joué tu vas faire un échange d'un F un
cavalier après tu as deux cavaliersô les
cas noir contre le Mau cas blanche c'est
ce qui est bizarre un peu dans ce c'est
qu'on a vraiment des parties
cata c'est étonnant ouis on a rarement
eu un bon niveau de jeu des deux côtés
en même temps
ouais on a eu mauvais jeu des deux
côtés
et là c'est encore une partie un
peu pi TR en fait il connait non on a
pas faiten noir on av fait le dragon
mais pas la sienne en entier et on est
fait française facile aussi on fait
scandinave facile beaucoup de choses
facil
ok Maxim garder le C on est là quoi bon
même qu c'est compliqué mais du coup
quand c'est
compliqué c'est ça peut plus pu être
forcément du contenu YouTube comme
ça al ce que tu as fait avec Vlad c'est
c'est pas facile en soit c'est du bon
contenu si un jour nous on fait des
vidéos payantes ça sera du beau contenu
moi j'en ai fait sur d'autres
sites voilà c'est pas c'est niveau bah
j'essaie de faire le le mieux possible
mais là en fait c'est très très très
bien ce qu'on a fait je pense jusqu'à un
certain niveau et euh
fait aussi le répertoire agressif
carocan
pas mal de gens qui m'écrivent qui me
disent que ça leur donne des bons
résultats franchement ta vidéo en 30
minutes sur les cossè que tu avais fait
est très bien enfin c'est bien après bon
ben bien sûr si tu joues des grands
maîtres peut-être c'est pas assez
mais en fait le répertoire a été fait en
fonction aussi pour pour un certain
niveau quoi c'est pas un rtoire que tu
vas garder forcément toute ta vie mais
pour commencer pour avoir un jeu
structuré pas te faire surprendre par
les ordres de coup et cetera ben on
pensait que c'était bien
quoi en ikarou qui a une excellente
position maintenant il faut transformer
l'essai pour lui et ouais bah ouais
c'est ces cases noires qui sont très
faibles non Maxime il veut faire A6
chasser le fou B5 ramener le cavalier en
C6 et cetera dit quelque chose de très
intéressant dans le chat Fab c'est que
Maxime est peut-être en mode sous-marin
car ça avait marché pour être champion
du monde de Blitz peut-être qu'il fait
exprès de faire des mauvais débuts de
partie difficulté comme ça je vais faire
un armagon pour bien se chauffer et
ouais les gens ne me voient pas remonter
non c'est c'est une technique tilisé
aussi dans dans Dragon Ball en fait ils
s'alourdissent exprès en début de combat
pour être un peu dans la merde et
maintenant je suis bien échauffé je vais
pouvoir me mettre juste à 50 % de ma
puissance non mais c'est vrai que c'est
une technique qui est pas que nous on
utilise pas souvent c'est pour ça qu'on
a jamais été champion du monde de rien
voilà
ou
deux cavaliers très bien de cavali après
je crois c'étaitattaque un peu mais avec
C4 au deè
coup G qui m' dit
180030 18 coupso
1h 10
minutes déjà
perdu ah c'est très
efficace3 l'ORD a pas trop
[Musique]
aimé tu fais à toute façon tu veux
chasser ce fou qui était pas mal
placé C6 à voir mais en F7 il est très
bien peut-être qu'il couvre même mieux
le roi pourquoi
pas6 ou mais ça donne
envie ça dégage ce fou et
h on va voir on va
voir joué bien joué Maxime allez il seet
en place et s'il arrive à faire au 5 il
aura rétabli tous les problèmes ouais
puis s'il est obligé de faire cavalier 5
et prend 5 prise 5 prise 5 tour 1 il est
vite alors est-ce qu'on fait tour 8
est-ce qu'on fait fou D7 et tant pis on
se développe un peu et en retard de 5
mais on fera tour A8 et quand même on se
place un peu et après pourquoi pas G5 G4
on vire le C de F3 et cetera et cetera
on va voir Fab on va
voir
on va jouer donc
je peux faire fou 7 pour tour à8 ou je
peut-être G5 après franchement pourquoi
pas mon micro est trop bas bah c'est pas
ce que dit le retour régie en tout cas
j'attends ludwiig quand
même pour vérifier ça pas l'impression
que ça
donne alors juste pour dire domingas a
bien gagné sa partie la première ronde
de ses-êre jou une deuxième et il se
qualife quoi il se
barre
qui met pression à carwana il est mieux
je suis du coin de l'œil comme ça voir
ce qui se passe mais pourit peut-être
égaliser5 c'est change tout en fait
oui don c'était l'autre option F des7
peut-être plus
direct on veut on veut 5 a
noir carou il fait vraiment pas un grand
tournoi parce que
là il a pas fait grand-chose quoi B
c'est s'il se fait égaliser en trois
coups après la position qu' av après 15
coup
incroable c'est qu'il est complètement
hors de forme ok je sais pas quelle que
soit la raison mais il n'est que l'ombre
de lui-même après il a commencé à l avec
la patronne hein je crois ça peut faire
mal patronade ouais ça ça peut faire
patronade ça peut faire très très mal
hein a pri le son ça va ouais mais je me
méfie l'expérience fa quand même du chat
qui fait exprès de de te B pour pour
gêner mais ça c'est l'expérience change
tout met le F6 le fou en D7 B d'abord
finir le
développement je su même pas sûr que tu
doiv faire 5 en fait tu es content en
soi mais fait c'est ta seule faiblesse à
défendre tu dois PIR y arriver même sans
faire trop
quoi
bien truc de 54 quand même cavalier F6
c'est non mais s'il a jou c'est sûr
qu'il doit vouloir
faire mais je pens P peut-être faire fou
des7 quand même Fab
ouais non il a raison de s'activ bon
Maxime qui toute façon un jeu vers
l'avant donc c'est c'estoup plus son
style écoute on y croit là il il est
revenu dans la partie mais il estata
dans ce tourno pourrait la perdre malgré
tout c'est pas fini euh genre c'est pas
qu'il caracole dans la position mais
d'où il vient caraco il caracole pas
mais euh vu d'où il vient euh c'est
c'est beau et c'est important de savoir
d'où on vient pour savoir où on va ouais
exactement crabni qui doit regarder
interesting
game bah il se lève ikaro il l'air
complètement sueur en fait c'est un P
ikaro ikaro ALARA même combat
Bonez vigilant c'est pas fait mais ok
c'est cool parce que on est plus
vraiment moins
bien il y a un très très beau title
aujourd'hui gagné par
martinos par mon ami jospem 2è Wonder
full time on profité de l'absence d' car
pour lui chiper la première place des
beaux joueurs spécialist de ce tournoi
qui oui bon qui sont pas là par
hasard on aimerait les voir aussi à ce
niveau de la compétition parce qu'on a
eu la zavic cette fois-ci spécialiste
mais qui a pas passé le premier tour
mais mais là Jos SP et wonderful time
sont de joueurs qui ont encore de
meilleurs résultat que laavi sur
Internet ouais et donc ils ont un peu de
championest quand même un peu mais non
ils arrivent pas au champion
chestur plus spécialiste title alors
title
Arena plus de seconde zone mais qui
gagne très souvent c'est tellement dur
de gagner un title gritu l'avait dit
quandme éta numéro 2 mondial quand même
gritu qui vraiment très dur à gagner
mais pas pour
eux sont quand même très très réguliers
on aimerait les
voir j'espère l'année prochaine les voir
en finale champion
csour peut-être un peu dommage de faire
cette phase en présentielle
qui te force à te déplacer avir ces
bouts de bois là alors tu es moins bien
concentré quoi quand même que de de bien
voir sur un écran tu peux régler la
luminosité tout bien mettre tes réglages
alors je demande pourquoi E4 F3 l'ordi m
pas cavalier E5 qui
g pourquoi pas B6
sinon pourquoi pas B6
ouais B6 F B7 en place
ouais B6 B7
fa
facile
dis pasé ridicule de la Davic
il a gagné un match sur 7
quoi non non mais en soit c'est dur ce
tu peux faire zé sur 7 moi je
m'attendais à zé mais bon il a quand
même fait un il a fait quelques nuls ici
ou là ou quoi
mais mais bon il il a plutôt été dominé
quoi dans l'ensemble que en fait il a
fait la pression qu'on pouvait attendre
par rapport à son héophine mais vu que
d'habitude il nous habitu à mieux dans
tous les tournois de qualificatif ou
quoi il est quand même là alors qu'il y
a pas nepomashi par exemple euh des
choses comme ça on pouit attendre que
peut-être soit la révélation et et non
en fait moi j'attendais déjà très fort
au grand
Suisse on l'attend on l'attend on espère
qu'il soit meilleur l'année
prochaine on espère le revoir à ce à ce
niveau de la compétition l'an prochain
qu'il a un petit peu progressé encore et
qui revienne
meilleur Max qui a les cour Max qui met
qui met à mal iaro non mais très sin max
il boit
tranquillement niveau pendule ça va il a
un léger retard mais rien de rien de
dramatique et surtout sa
position bien quoi enfin tient son
centre c'est dur de se faire attaquer
les pions
euh donc écoute pour l'instant ça va
c'est vrai qu'il fait peu de grimace il
a vraiment pas l'air dans son assiette
déjà là il s enfin il s'est qualifié
avec vraiment beaucoup de bol il avait
plus du tout son testtin entre les mains
et même contre la zavic hein il était
proche de perdre le match quand même
alors surtout la première ronde oui mais
c'est mais du coup cétait mené un zé
ouiit pas beau après bon une fois qu'il
a gagné la première ça un peu bon ça
allit
mieux fou F1
ok bon probablement que fou B7 doitêtre
le c'est bien mais Maxime que j'aime
bien sa gestion du temps est toujours
excellente il plante pas pour rien alors
ok il va nous attaquer le C D7 oh il a
raté Maxime
ouais il a raté c'était gaffe en fait7
il a joué vite mais il a
raté quel
dommage c'est bien et en faitous ouais
euh fallait faire quoi par par curiosité
du coup c'était bien joué son F F les
car ah c'est
terrible4 ouais qu'il fallait jouer
depuis un moment en fait cétait vraiment
le moment
[Musique]
maintenant bon mais du coup ça perd un
pion et là c'est plus tout à fait pareil
évidemment de perdre ce pion terrible
Maxime quand même gaffe comme
ça
ah ça va être dur à tenir mais bon allez
a a le seum la maxime estce qu' sait que
ça c'était un truc évitable mais bon
écoute c'est comme
ça il a déjà abandonné
il a trop le
SAM allez cheingam d'IKO qui passe a pas
l'air ravi non plus ah le niveau de jeu
est cataclysmique he dans ce
tournoi voir Carana qui est mal qui se
fait défoncer aussi
ah mais le niveau de jeu est vraiment
kata
quoi mais c'est pas grave on va avoir
des armes à Gadon quand même et je sais
pas pourquoi ça joue aussi mal je sais
pas si c'est pas la cadence en fait hein
qui a un peu un entre
deux non mais ce F B7 c'est DOM ou le
coup paraî tellement logique mais c'est
vrai que si on se questionne 2 secondes
sur pourquoi faut F1 mais l'air
tellement innocent c'est c'est c'est un
joli coup de belle marlouterie
ouais tu dis ouais bon peut-être tu veux
utiliser la colonne D pour attaquer des5
je me F en BC voilà enfin tu réfléchis
pas trop et euh ouais joli coup bien
joué bravo ikaro qui malgré tout
continue à rester en vie incroyable
parce qu'il est vraiment il jou vraiment
mal par rapport à d'habitude mais
bon Fab est-ce qu'il va survivre à cette
partie donc il met les barbelés tant
qu'il peut alors évidemment les fot C
reposé on l'a déjà dit plein de fois
mais ça favorise l'attaque donc
clairement bah là les blancs he qui ont
les pièces vers le RO adverse il y a des
trous encore faut-il conclure tout
ça non Maxime il est vraiment pas en
forme non plus he dans ce tournoi par
qu' on a fait beaucoup de GAF he comme
ça non mais là
enfin non je il y en a dans ce tournoi
il y a une quantité de G qui est
incroyable truc qui m'étonne c'est ces
ouvertures surtout il est souvent très
mal très
vite là c'était encore le cas oui mais
contre Abdou aussi il a fait une énorme
gaffe dans l'armée
gison il est complètement à côté de la
plaque Maxime mais il car aussi hein
c'est qu' joue vraiment tous super mal
enfin tous quasiment
tous tu m il nous casse tous le Bou
quand même oui mais c'est t pareil en
fait c'est sur le même truc c'est
féérire il va faire un mauvais match va
perdre contre Top 12 mais il va quand
même te défoncer parce que tu sa juste
pas enfin c'est toujour pareil en fait
ça veut rien dire de dire
ça comm Fab il est probablement plus
fort que 99,9 % des gens sur la planète
au tennis mais il est complètement nul
ah ça oui mais bon bientôt il Fall dire
que c'est très très
fort
non nordirbeck ouais il est il est il
est bon ce nordirbeck il se bat bien
pourant je pense qu'il est encore un peu
en dessous des des tout meilleurs mais
mais il arrive gentiment il est
travailleur sérieux voilà faut compter
sur lui
hein sinon peut-êtreils ont tous le rhum
moi j'ai un gros rhume aussi je rend pas
bien peut-être qu'il qu'il sont mal je
sais pas en fait mais ils jouent
vraiment mal globalement h mais je pense
la cadence aussi jou joue un petit peu
ou la chaleur
quoi je sais pas en tout cas il y a il y
a quelque chose qui fait que mais après
le truc de 15 + 3 c'est que c'est un
entre deux c'est tu as pas la qualité du
25 + 10 moi j'aime bien le 15 + 10 j'ai
l'impression que le + 3 fait que ça joue
quand même moins bien et du coup c'est
tu un peu entre deux entre du Blitz et
du et du et du
semiraapide je pense 15 + 10 tu mets un
peu plus de temps mais quand même la
qualité de jeu est nettement plus haute
quoi quiit à
ouais bon de toute façon pourquoi joue
en rapide un tel tournoi c'est peut-être
un peu dommage de pas pas leur donner
euh 2h et cetera
quoi rajouter du temps au 40e au
60e mais mais ouais peut-être c'est une
cadence à laquelle ils ont pas
l'habitude de jouer et que ils ont pas
encore
le la bonne gestion du temps et tout
çadouut top 10 Mo oui oui probablement
fut top 10 ça m'étonnerait qu'il soit
jamais de sa vie
quoi et en gros Abdou ce qu'il fait là
c'est qu'il ouvre un second front sur
les c'est sur les lois ça se passe très
bien mais la dame F7 nous gêne un peu
parce qu'on aimerait bien faire dame F6
à maté et donc s'il se passe des choses
de l'autre côté de les chiqué à un
moment peut-être tu es pris en étau tu
peux pas être au four et au moulin et ça
se passe
mal C tu es 30 ouais m peu moins même 32
3 tu dois quand même être dans les 0,1 %
des humains les plus forts au tennis
mais en fait je joue très peu enfin j'ai
pris une licence il y a 2 ans et j'ai
fait peu de tournois quoi déjà tu es
plus fort que tous les gens qui ont plus
de 70 ans c'est sûr tous les gens
évidemment qui savent pas jouer au
tennis pas sûr il y a des vieux qui
peuvent te ouais bon il place les balles
juste en dessous les gamins là quand
même je tape fort et puis voilà ou non
mais non mais je je suis nul au tennis
quoi quand même dans le top je me
débrouille pour un mec qui a jamais joué
quoi voilà
mais je peux pas me concer comme joueur
de tennis quoi
enfin et si je joue contre sa au tennis
échec je me fais découper normalement
parce que échec alors on va dire que
c'est équilibré mon tennis il joue bien
ça il 15 enfin il a jeté un point de
moins je crois il est plus fort aux
échec en plus oui mais je peux gagner
aux échecs quoi mais je veux dire le
problème c'est que faudrait que je gagne
vite aux échecs et ça bon c'est
dur dans échecs je peux résister quoi
mais tennis bah je suis moins bon et
clairement
quoi ça bien tout le temps qui est parti
sur sa trop longue et là quand tu as un
format plutôt rapide on se plain encore
bah c'est pas on essaie juste de
comprendre en fait on s'en fout
complètement je te rassure on essaie
juste de comprendre pourquoi le les
joueurs réussissent pas à performer
parce que globalement ça joue mal
ouais on essaie de comprendre est-ce que
c'est parce que c'est le moment dans la
saison est-ce que enfin essayer de
comprendre c'est pas se plaindre en fait
juste on constate quelque chose on
essaie de savoir pourquoi est-ce que
c'est parce que bah du coup ils ont du
mal à s'adapter comm c'est un peu un
entre deux est-ce que enfin on sait pas
en
fait mais on a quand même le droit de se
poser des questions essayer de
comprendre c'est quand même
intéressant mal j qu'ils en ont rien à
enfin je sais pas moi il peut y
avoir peutre c'est complèement la fin de
la saison Carana est déjà qualifié au
candidat l'autre ENF Championnat du
Monde en oubékistan chez lui qui est
nettement plus important que ça c'est
évident pour lui aussi carlen façon il
s'en tape plus ou moins
ouii gag gag je sais pas moi peut-être
que ikarou il est en fin de saison il il
s'est qualifié pour les candidat a
besoin de souffler Maxime clairement il
est fatigué c'est sûr il a quand même
beaucoup enchaîné la fin de l'année
enfin R de toute façon ça fait un moment
que c'est comme ça donc pas juste ici
hein peut-être c'est la cadence
peut-être c'est juste que ben voilà ils
sont un peu ils en ont un peu marre et
puis parce que vu l'argent qui est en
jeu vu tout tu t'attendrais à ce que
ça d'ailleurs ikarou son répertoire pour
ce tournoi il est il s gamb Mora quand
même oui mais c'est ce que je te dis
c'est des 4 D5 c'est 4 C5 c'est ouis
c'est5 F3 F6 qui prend5 qui prend4 enfin
c'est on essaie de comprendre les
raisons de de de tout ça de tout
ça c'est peut-être un mélange de tout
hein pour le
coup possible dans ce cas ça joue mal
oui ça c'est sûr par rapport à ce qu'ils
peuTent faire il joue mal et c'est pas
parce que la partie est rapide ou quoi
c'estàdire que desfond les vois jou en
blitz mieux que ça
quoi
B car fait ce qu'il peut sa est vraiment
dur disait il y a st ro qui est faible à
tout moment il a le second front à l'AME
avec le pion passé et faut contrôler les
T B7 et
compagnie c'est pas facile quoi mais bon
Fabi en fait il fait ce qu'il faut pour
essayer de tenir c'est de pas donner la
partie en un coup j jamais perdre direct
puis bon c'est ça craque ça craque toute
façon il peut rien faire de mieux sa
position est toute pourrie mais tant que
l'adversaire trouve pas le gain tu es
toujours là à
résister ça c'est le rôle des
commentateurs de se poser des question
bah oui c'est pour ça n on se pose des
questions enfin en fait de base sinon on
regarderait pas quoi enfin h tu
commandes pas en
fait il donne H6 mais ve tour H3 la dame
part on prendra H7 c'est un pion
empoisonné il revient en D8
mais franchement c'est pas enfin on voit
que c'est censé gagner pour les blancs
mais il y a pas de truc qui tue directo
défend bien Fabiano là pour le coup on a
parlé de quand ça joué mal mais là c'est
vrai qu'il défend bien donc il a dû
jouer mal avant pour se retrouver là
mais là il se bat bien
C6 C6 pourquoi c'est6 mant par que si la
tour prend il va rentrer par B8 et par
H8
et
par là on a un petit problème de
je sais pas peut-êtreon a rattrapé c'est
dur à dire mais non c'est bon on a
rattrapé en fait mais tour h donc c'est
bien le scénario quoi c'est passer par
les LAM pour aller sur les
LO su ça la caméra trouve pas de bon
coup plus que quelques secondes c'est
S qui va égaliser qui va aller enir de
nouveau deux Armagedon on a beaucoup
d'armagedon je dois dire oui
limite tu vois ça aura pu être un tour
d'armagedon
peut-être certain nombre de partiestn a
quasi à chaque fois quent à chaque fois
ouais là c'est encore deor
magadon bon bien sûr on se focalisera
sur celui de Maxime euh bien jou dirbec
ouais qui revient qui revient qui qui
Vaillant en tout cas
euh donc bah
ça on espère une belle partie Maxime
dans la prochaine qui nous a déçu là
avec cette gaffe énorme il va falloir
qu'il arrête de gaffer Maxime pour
réussir à gagner des match tout
simplement et reste en vie dans ce
tournoi exactement allez on se retrouve
bientôt pour l'armagedon à tout de
suite quel est le meilleur moyen de
suivre n'importe quel événement échikien
tupat du monde au tournois des candidats
en passant par le speedchess ou les
title today
chess.com/events Courouvre tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez et
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables base
retrouverz toutes les infos essentielles
comme le programme les horaires des
rondes les prix les résultats les contre
rendus quotidien les bios des joueurs
les règles des partages et plus encore
vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur
chess.com/events aussi bien sur le site
internet que sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour vivre votre passion comme
nulle par
[Musique]
ailleurs
[Rires]
[Musique]
al les amis on est de on est de retour
et ikarou qui renvoie ça sa même ptrop
j'espère que Maxim a quand même jeté un
œil hein que c'est pas ce serait dommage
de pas l'avoir fait quand même là ça
serait un manque de professionnalisme
j'ai envie de dire ouais je pense qu'il
a quand même jeté un œil à ce qu'il
fallait faire il a vu ikarou qui le
jouait
à mon avis il a jeté un œil et donc le
score c'est un partout il va
falloir
l'update donc c'est l'armagedon Ikar qui
a moins de temps et qui clique Maxime il
a regarder c'est sûr ce qu' joue
vraiment vite là
l'ouverture il a la réputation Fab bon
après j'imagine c'est une réputation
tout relative qu' va être et puis ben
faudra conclure mais en tout cas c'est
bien il fait pas un truc insipide sur
cette
variante mais le truc c'est qu'ikar a
l'air de connaître hyper loin
ends mais Maxime connait encore
aussi regarde il connaitt super loin
h
là ça il connait plus peut-être mais si
il connaî encore je crois mais ça a
l'air une rutation toute
relative en tout cas je suis curieux de
voir la résultante du truc mais ikarou
ça se voit dans sa gestuelle il est pas
il pas pas comme d'hab et Maxime il
connaît
encore c'est beau
ça regarde comme c'est beau ça peêre fou
des deux comme ça on pour mettre le en
cas d'échec
is j'espère qu'il connaî encore bah là
moi je connaissais pas et j'ai proposé s
rien connaître donc
ouais mais j'espère quand même qu'il
connais non mais il a bien il a fait son
travail maison Maxime c'est bien c'est
bien
ouis il a pris6 il adore trop ça do être
gaffe
ouais ça do être horribleah j'en sais
rien mais juste ça a l'air beaucoup plus
dangereux d'être comme ça que faire fout
de ouais bah l'ordi déteste mais normal
en fait c'est une sele gueule le coup
ouais c'est horrible com il a fait pour
faire une telle
faute je sais pas c'est pas perdant
c'est juste que bon si reg la Jae il est
redescendu mais
un peage tellement pas envie de jouer
une telle position avec un roi comme ça
et un peu à l'image du tournoi de Maxime
finalement des erreurs évitables un peu
incompréhensibles
ais ben il s'est fait éteindre
Maxime partie
horrible non mais vraiment
Fab
on il va peut-être se faire matter
rapidement si ça continue
là fait hyper peur sa position c'est
incroyable d'avoir aussi mal joué
juste je comprends pas en fait fa le
problème après on tient notre vidéo de
demain
Fab le titre non mais genre là c'est
vraiment à l'image du tournoi la
partie étonnant quand même hein et là
c'est pas une question de cadence c'est
pas ouais on arrive pas à comprendre en
fait qu'est-ce qui se passe à Toronto
pour que les joueurs jouent si
mal il a pas de chance il a pas de
chance je sais pas si de toute façon tu
as fait une potion pour mais tu pourrais
croire qu'c C3 tu vas cacher ton roi
petit à petit mais j'ai l'impression que
C3 tu te prends soit fou C8 soit même
tour
D6 tu peux pas aller cacher tr
mais c'est incroyable de pas cacher le
roi quoi enfin c'estuc on va remontrer
le moment important parce que là c'est
c'est ça va vite en plus il connaît
jusque là donc c'est son premier coup on
imagine h connaissance il a joué très
vite en fait il fallait simplement
commencer par fout des deux échec fait
roi C1 ro B1 cacher le roi donc on
imagine peut-être un coup comme dame C5
ce qu'on veut T1 B4 peut-être je sais
pas
moi on a plus on a un pion de plus il y
a pas d'attaque et bon fa encore gagner
on verra mais complexe on est mieux
quoi recu et puis voilà bon on est
content quand même quoi dans
l'autre oui non mais c'est intéressant
aussi pour raro c'est une position qui
se
joue mieux blanc
quoi il a fait à
4 c'est juste perdant après C6 parce qu'
a fou c'est8 bah en même temps c'est
enfin à 4 son idée elle est claire c'est
Dame B5 échec d'échanger les dames
donc c'est pas si dur à trouver voilà
c'est joué à
tempo bon tu peux faire encore B3
mais F B4 prend
B3 partie absolument kata oua horrible
mais incompréhensible en fait il y a une
jolie varander fou B4 C3 dame prend B3
çaou C8 dame prend C6 dame prend D3 ma
des épaulettes c'est quand même assez
rare exactement on peut
l'aider 900 ppm de CO2 dans
l'air c'est la raison hein l'hiver au
Canada une fin de saison très intensive
les conditions sont réunies pour des
erreurs humaines ouis enfà c'est
ridicule en fait là les deux dernières
parties c'est Laesser FO H3 c'est
ridicule et ça c'est enfin bon ça c'est
pire on va
dire Caro qui va se
qualifier encore qu' le match d'après
mais peut-être incroyable carou qui
risque de continuer son bonhomme de
chemin G7 gaffe encore di cararou tour
B1 du coup il a pas vu fou B4 échec C3
et dame prend B3 qui était pas si facile
quand même non Maxime reste dans la
partie alors peut-être alors
peut-être une partie d'un niveau de jeu
fabé on se croirait
Fabien un jeudi soir du côté de de
geoffro
Guichard pour un match Saint-Étienne
Paris
FC cé
triste et maintenant maxime est de
nouveau mieux
parce que B4 dame Pras peut-être des
cavaliers C5 qui vont RER
puis fais fou B2 fou pr reprend bon es
là tuas peut-être B5 tu vas lui défoncer
son roi quoi tu es tellement
là alors
peut-être d Wes si Max retourne ça je
dis chapeau non il faut comprendre en
fait un truc dans les échecs on en
parlait juste avant avec Fa c'est qu'il
a qui écrit Magnus c'est un génie des
finales parce qu'il a gagné tour fou
contre fou contre tour c'est pas être un
génie des finales c'est je sais pas
c'est pas parce que l'autre fait
complètement de la merde que tu es fort
en fait après faut
savoirir c'est les opportunités mais
c'est pas parce que tu es un tu es un
magicien des finales là c'est juste que
en face ça c'est pas défendre une nul
théorique donc enfin et là c'est un peu
pareilf là il rate enfin il fait fou B4
échec dam pr B3 tu sers la main donc
mais tant mieux enfin je c'est pas nous
on
es pas un génie ou quoi que ce soit
c'est comme au tennis tu es mené tu es
mené 4000 service adverse tu dois
débrequer le mec te fait 5 doublees
fautes bon tuas débquéonou bravo mais
j'ai dit des retours de service
quoi maisarou là ça voit qu' a fait n
pissu
complètement mais on peut encore des
rebondissement enfin là je sais plus à
quoi
m'attendre
lâche ça carou on nous écrit on
comprends la partie assez compliqué just
ils ont joué vite le on a bien vu qu'il
avait raté
après après tant mieux pour Max en plus
nous non seulement on est hyper content
que Maxim on est hyper content qu'ou
perde donc là pour nous c'est je c pas
meilleur scénario il y a pas meilleur
match pour nous c'eston est c'est notre
joueur préféré contre le joueur qu'on
aime le moins donc
c'est mais juste moment obligé de dire
la vérité on est quand même des
passionnés des échecs avant tout et on
on comprend pas
quoi je TR plus intéressant à suivre que
des récitations de prépa bah non enfin
une questionitation de prépa que si tu
peux paser part me DESP non mais
d'habitude en fait je veux dire soit
prépa prépa ation il a joué 15 coup quoi
quand il joue en
960 il joue mieux enfin il joue bien
c'est des parties construit tout quoi
c'est il y a vraiment des grosses
erreurs quoi inhabituell pour des genss
de ce calibre et il y en a beaucoup et
ça se voit même à l'attitude des joueurs
enfin j carou il est pas du tout dans
son dans son attitude
habituelle Maxime il est tranquille
maxime est très tranquille pour le coup
il suit pas tant pis il gagne gagne il
pas per bon en fait
al est-ce qu'on peut jouer la finale
est-ce qu'il va nous faire dame à 3 pour
dame enve un peu moche de ma 3 quand
même estce que tu laissera la case D4 à
l'adversaire le match g de ce match se
faire exploser contre fabine ou Abdou
ouis c'est même pas sûr pas l'air
terrible non plus
hein ils seront pas favoris quoi mais
bon il peut se passer plein de chose
hein vous êtes dur les fautes fait
partie du jeu c'est aussi le but de
cramer le cerveau de l'autre oui non
mais ouais mais là bien mais oui c'est
le but la faute c'est le but de tous les
jeux comm je il font 40 doubles fautes
par match c'est peut-être le but de
pousser à la faute parce que tu esour
pas tu provoques les fautes normalement
là lesell sont c'est des cadeaux quoi
c'est c'est des fautes directes
quoi c'est tant mieux pour pour Maxime
pour le moment mais après je m'attends à
des faut direct tu es Maxime à tout
moment aussi là on sait pas ce qui va se
passer ENF tout tout peut arriver c'est
impronosticable
c'est un
problicable intéressant son coup B5 au
demurant ouais j'aime bien ouais voilà
par contre c'est par exemple c'est pas
le coup principal de l'ordinateur mais
c'est un coup qui pousse à l'erreur
c'est différent oua là ça va tu vois
d'ailleurs il y a pas de critique sur le
coup quoi bah non non c'est un coup qui
fait mal qui met en danger l'adversaire
il lui reste 3 minutes pour jouer 30
coups avant d'avoir la seconde par cou
qui arrive et d'ailleurs il gaffe
instantanément et T joue à
tempo on va voir ça suffit hein mais
c'est intéressant par ça vite à 6 qui
renforce la structure donc c'est bien
joué puis c'est joué vite ça aurait été
un coup sûrement sur tour B1 il aurait
changé d' fa A6 il se trouve que c'est
une gaffe al il est 8 à 6 en tout cas
mais c'est pas com c'est il voulait quoi
l'ORD tour juste par curiosité il
voulait dame pr E5 prend E5 et cavalier
F6 pas invisible quand même tu changes
la tour tu vas prendre B5 et tu prends
G5 parce qu'en fait c'est ce que tu
voulais sur dame C3 etou voulait faire
ça ça ça ouais c'était terminé en fait
prend B5 échec ro C7 ouais c'est et tu
as une finale très jolie parce que tu
attaques le fou et G5 très facile quand
même ben surtout qu'il a l'idée il fait
B5 avant il laisse dame pour C3 pour
faire çaou bon après on va voir hein
comment on dit c'est unonosticable ça
peut tourner encore à droite à gauche
ou il a quand même raté un truc assez
facile mais il a donné son piombé pour
pas grandchose là du
coup dame qui part à
l'attaque alors dame prend le4 prend B5
et prend dame prend et tuas pas dame B7
PR8 D qui gagne il 3 il a raté mat
3 joli Jol pr
B2 et D et ro pr il avait 4 donc il a
raté 3ok il défend mais céit pas si
facile machin il double les tours il met
la pression sur B c'est un pronosticable
on sait pas tout est possible ça va en
tous les sens il va y avoir un chaos
dans les prochains coups à priori ouais
ouais il a raté ma 3 quand
même attentionam pr quand même qui re
c'est pas terrible ce qu' a fait Maxime
quand
même bah c un peu B5 pour rien quoi du
coup il a donné il a B4 il l'a plus quoi
ouais tellement dommage et puis le dame
prend cavalier c'était pas si dur à
trouver F3 pas mal pas mal de Naka
peut-être faire alors attends mais il y
a peut-être la 4ème rangée qui peut
s'illuminer k G3
ou c'est cavalier C3 c'est le coup que
j'avais mais ça me faisait peur att faut
bien avoir un coup hein sinon peut pas
faire grand chose c'était mon m avec les
tours des4 prise prise d'AM ici et je me
disais peut-être je peux faire roi
C1 ah mais il y a peut-être P prend G2
il a pris F3 de toute façon fou prend F3
mais cavalier C3 maintenant H 2 et tu te
barres et tu te barres peut-être là-bas
ouais ouais ouais ouais bon pas une
bonne tête mais qui
sait 3 ce qu' fait il laisse H2 pour
faire roisser mais bon tu es pas
mécontent d'être là-bas quand même et tu
as des dames des H8 mat aussi maintenant
al il prend pas H2 il fait tour C5 il
attaque le cavalier est-ce qu'on monte
une tour en B3 est-ce qu'on
fait on doit monter une tour en B3 de
toute façon quoi
d'autre mais apparemment pour c'est
complètement foutu oui bon on verra mais
je suis pas sûr
heinite il veut quoi ah mais si c'est ça
c'est pas beau ça mais c'est une finale
avec de pion de MO
non un pion de
moin deux mais c'est pas une finale mais
bon je sais pas si c'était bah c'est la
même chose que T B3 en gros quoi ah
c'est
aussi
bon parce qu' quand même pas mal de
[Musique]
temps terrible par Maxime
horrible A5
maintenant je crois que c'est mort cette
fois-ci c'est très simple a plus
d'attaque ils ont pass là-bas qui vont
avancer et une minute 30 pour jouer 20
coup mais simple quoi incroyable quand
Maxim bah c'est dommage d'avir fait B5
en fait pour faire ça après allez on va
voir on sait jamais il y a la pendule
j'ai peur de dame G7 ça c'est bien joué
ça
simplifie mais pour le coup quand vous
regarderez la précision ils sont à moins
de 80 % quoi 74 contre
78 je ve dire quand ils font des sont 98
quoi donc ça montre que la partie était
pas de grande
qualité est-ce que Maxime peut tenter
les derniers pièges c'est pour nul
dernier
[Musique]
piège faut gagner il faut pas que faire
nul pour gagner à la p organiser quelque
chose quand même une menace faire des
menaces ouais
ro C3 allez pour C
D4 j'aime bien quand même même si
finalement
non J4 maintenant il peut-être faire
cavali54 faire tour pour
répéter
ça fait mal
ça par qu'il peut pas faire autre chose
que T C5 ce que j'allais dire il y avait
trop de fou des5 dans le Range
ouais bon prendre du
pion
ah tu c'est même dur d'imaginer une
menace quoi
ouais t B5 et rien stand
ah terrible
mauvaise partie mauvais match mauvais
tournoi en fait horrible mais juste F
ouverture je pourrais jamais comprendre
en fait c'est pour moi inexplicable en
fait comme décision après on notre vidéo
de demain
ouais TR une bonne
nouvelle
ou bah du coup on peut peut-être aller
voir fait c'est
fait
climatisé
euh
ok euh donc qui a les blancs je sais pas
quel St les enchères il a ses 2 minutes
enfin pas tout à fait une minute 30
d'avance
euh c'est chaud en il égalité matérielle
mais c'est un peu comme si les blans av
un pion de plus au
final car qui quand même d'AM et fin là
attention
t F2
quivite
centraliser revenir voilà attaque le
fou que les BL pas du tout envie de
prendre le pion H2 la colonne h à la
tour pour l'instant comme bouclier
prendra ce pion juste en finale plus
tard si
jamais ça va être dur pour
NAD enaka qui rayonne ouais alors que le
niveau des parties il est famélique
quoi mais c'est V que les de les deux
Français éliminés très tôt dans le
tournoi finalement
ouais comme tu avais bien senti en fait
ouais mais il jouit tellement
mal
c'est pas mal à ce que vient de
faire
Fabi ce qui menace dame prend F2 mais il
c'est fini en
fait dame C2 ouais mais il y a dame 1 là
il a pas vu mat en 2 il a raté mat en 2
Z2 il avait pas se dépatouiller en fait
de cette situation donc Fabi va se
qualifier et retrouver Naka du coup non
Abd va jouer contre Naka et Fabi va se
qualifier pour la demi-finale non
finalement les trois meilleurs sont
qualifiés sur le c'était très
clair qui était plus fort ouais Fabi un
peu moins large mais au-dessus
euh qui
va voilà qui va avoir sa chance contre
Naka qui qui peut le battre qui peut le
battre à voir on rappelle he Maxime
éliminé
ah bon on va faire une pause je sais pas
de combien de temps
mais à tout de suite les amis allez à
toutes
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from Chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolf magnet kit
and swap them ever you like make your Mo
get an exclusive discount on all metal
postersop now with the code ch
[Musique]
displate.com
c'est de c'est de retour mesdames et
messieurs avec
nadirbeck pièce blanche contrearou qui
lu joué sa pé trof al lui il a pas joué
qui pr 5 au 3e il a jouer avec D4 et euh
il joue une vantere relativement
agressive on peut avoir une mauvaise
structure côté blanc mais l'initiatif
voire même là peut-être un pion de moins
mais diriger tout vers les loit
peut-être l'attaque alors qui est ton
favori Fab pour ce match ikaro non
sûrement moi jeaais bien remonter tel un
phéniix ça pourrait hein parce qu'il
joue pas trop bien mais il est encore là
cela
dit la jeunesse pour lui et dans cette
fin de journée c'est une journéeintante
avec beaucoup de
matchsme
[Musique]
pourrait 5h5 de jeu
déjà qui déjà beaucoup de d'émotion dans
cette journée est passé
par
plus pasix pour gagner le tournoi oui
peut-être
peut-êtreuttre 7 vie le
Shiko il devrait plus être là
déjà et pourtant il est toujours là bien
là ah si commence à Ger sa petite tête
peut-être il reprendre de la
forme on va voir en tout cas on est
impatient de connaître le nom du 4e
demi-finaliste et demain on va se
délecter Fab
ouais on a hâte on a hâte alors dès
demain on des magnifiques demi-finale en
en plusieurs sets d'ailleurs ur parce
que là bon cétait un peu court ces match
en deux parties ils seront en quatre
parties match aller match retour et 3è
set peut-être àarmagedon je ne sais plus
exactement VO ça connaî he Fab alors ça
connaî et ça va être une encore une
position avec les foot reposé que
nordybeck avait bien joué contre Fabiano
c'était pas cette ouverture ou quoi
mais c'était pas cette ouverture c'était
peut-être ouverture mais mais mais il
est bien maîtrisé ou après sûrement pas
parce qu'il y a un P H6 en H7
h c'était pas tout à fait Mme position
exactement en tout cas plutôt préférable
pour les blancs mais à voir iaro qui
semble bien connaître qui a joué à A5 un
coup qui peut-être amener la tour à A6
pour venir coulisser et défendre cette
6e rangée et son
roi est-ce queb ne connaîtrait plus en
tout cas il le joue
pas
est-ce qu'on peut tenter de faire F4 F5
vite vite
vite bon F4 faut regarder sior peut
faire fou F5 prend B7
ah oui
forcément petit pion dans la besace ça
fait
plaisir c'est vrai que c'est dommage
Carlsen qui a pas éliminé la menace
comme on nous le dit
ikarou il quand même
essayer
on va voir on va voir fa
t se place au
centre
re un peu dommage que ce match soit qu'
deux parties alors dernier match pour
ouais pour pour ce qualifier au top 4
aurais pu être en qure
parties fa Mar mais c'est vrai que c'est
quand Mme hyper important tout est
construit pour cette demi-inale et que
ce match soit du même niveau que ce
qu'il y avait avant alors qu'il y a un
enjeu quand même
démultiplié j'ai toujours pas vraiment
compris le format avec des match
pourquoi les armesagéis à chaque fois
enfin j'ai rien compris pour le
moment j'ai vraiment pas la rêve du
format en fait je trouve que les armes
àénons c'était vraiment pas
terrible pens vousop il y en avait trop
mais d'ailleurs ça a été dit dans le
truc en anglais he gens qui se posaient
la question même les joueurs en a pas
trop je crois que ça a pas plu en fait
peut-être s'il y a un partout dans tes
matchs de Calif bah tu fais nul au
classement moi c'est ce que j'aurais
pensé c'est la vie quoi oua ou tu fais
comme au grand chassour un point ou deux
points ou un point tu avance et puis à
la fin tu fais leur tableau là tu fais
le top 2 qui est qualifié mais je vois
pas trop ce que ça apportter c armes à
Gidon à part allonger le temps allonger
le truc mais alors d'une manière
hallucinante
par en fait tu es ouais a qure parties
en même temps quatre matches en même
temps tu es au moins sur qu' a à chaque
fois AA jamais de truc
court j'aurais plutôt vu des
allers-retours vraiment rapides quoi
comme il faisait à
l'époque du M de de Blitz ou quoi où tu
faisais deux parties direct en fait tu
fa deux parties en ça dure 1 heure
quoi quit même s'il veulent en faire
plus qu'ils en fassent quatre enfin j'en
sais rien mais je suis un peu étonné de
ces armes magadons personnellement
ouais finalement c'était assez frustrant
mais je crois que c'était frustrant pour
les joueurs
aussi d'près ce que j'ai compris j'a
bien le coup de l'ORD CELI que j'avais
aussi tour B5 attaque les de pions tu
provoques C6 tu repars en B3 peut-être
et tu coupes la tour à
6 j les coup t B5
ouais c'est assez logique je
trouve bon après faut aussi dire qu'on
est un peu biaisé par par la qualité de
jeu qui est pas du tout au au
rendez-vous mais
ça tu peux rienin non mais faut accepter
que ça puisse arriver mais que
l'événement puisse se suffir à lui-même
alors tu préfères qu'il a des grosses
parties ça bon
ouais mais aès quelque chose que j'ai
souvent dit mais pour moi
personnellement s'il y a pas de public
une compétition sportive c'est jamais
intéressant de toute façon donc tu es
vraiment très tributaire d'avoir des
quelque chose d'incroyable
ah peut-être qu'on aura quelque chose
d'incroyable par la suite hein ça c'est
possible mais genre tu es très très
tributaire fait tu as rien qui peut
sauver ton
événement
ouis il faut que ça joue bien faut que
joue très bien soit hyper intéressant si
ça allit pas en fait ton événement il
est
mort qui laisse d pr à 5 il veut prendre
C2 mais il laisse a 5 et D5 du
coup mais oui n'hésitez pas à donner
votre avis vous aussi sur les arm c'est
une question qui s'est posée comme j'ai
dans le live en anglais il y en a qui
ont aimé il y en a beaucoup qui n'ont
pas aimé et d'ailleurs enfin pourquoi
pas faire un armagon mais alors pourquoi
pas le faire en blitz 5 minutes contre 4
ou 6 5 voilà max quoi ouais des petits
points de bonus quoi un truc comme le
bonus défensif au rugby quoi ouais mais
d'ailleurs moi je pensais que si tu
perdais le match en deux
tuais peut-être marquer zé et que si tu
gagnes tu allais marquerz on va dire de
je pas truc au hasard si tu perds
en en Armagedon mais tuavais pas marqué
zé aussi faire 05 ou 1 et que fera 1 et
demi ou je sais pas un truc comme ça
quoi non mais ça a été un peu trop long
dans le temps quoi quoi qu'il en soit
ouais beaucoup de pauses mais bon com on
dit quand même faut bien que les G soi
reposé pour tu as eu beaucoup de mini
match en deux parties finalement qui ont
duré 2h 2h et demi pour pas grandchose
quoi ouis mais bon les j étaient bien
reposés normalement normalement
peut-être pas assez d'ailleursutê les
Paes étaient pas assez longues au final
ça peut expliquer la qualité de jeu un
peu en de
ça par certains moments et puis et puis
ça souffre aussi malheureusement de
revoir toujours les mêmes joueurs qui
rejouent ensemble en
boucle moment donné même là en fait
c'est encore des enfin tu vois moi
j'aurais préféré voir ou alors faire
deux groupes et puis après ou c'est ce
que je pensais aussi même les Masters de
tennis ouais ouais tu as maximum de fois
le même match et c'est pas censé arriver
en fait parce que tu as une poule qui
joue ensemble l'utre poule en final il
il se croise pas il faut que les deux
mecs de la même
poule le tous les deux leur demi-finale
pour se retrouver en finale ça peut
arriver hein mais c'est pas fait tout à
fait pour
quoi dis C original au moins ah ça c'est
sûr que cé original mais c'est justement
pour ça que la question est posée hein
parce que c'est c'est un nouveau format
pour moi il est pas du tout
concluant mais après chacun chacun son
point de vue c'est quand tout ce qui est
nouveau de toute façon ça vaut le coup
d'essayer
hein
ça vaut le coup d'essayer mais César
magadon au norw ça marche pas trop non
plus je sais pas j'ai l'impression que
c'est trop c'est trop gadget je sais pas
comment dire ça donne trop l'impression
d'être un truc qui est pas pas naturel
pas naturel
ouais non je le faire à la rigueur pour
des tournélimination tu es obligé à un
moment oui mais c'est ça là c'est ça
c'est c'est tu as l'impression que c'est
un peu rajouter comme ça après quand
c'est à élimination oui bien sûr
pourquoi pas pour les demifinales ou
quoiou oui oui oui mais je pense que ça
fait beaucoup plus de sens
puis sur quatre parties ça fait déjà
plus de sens que sur deux parce qu' les
retours aux échecs quand même vu que un
partout c'est quand même vraiment
largement le score le plus
logique l'IM que tu forces un peu
l'armagedon sur quatre parties machin
c'est en de7 gagnant potentiellement il
y a de enfin je trouve quand même que
c'est plus
logique estce que compr nos Français
infuence pas négativement la personion
de l'événement aussi oh là pas du tout
je pensais déjà après le premier
jour forcément plus français c'est un
peu dommage pour nous
ouais mais on pour moins s'enflammer
mais euh mais ça change pas que ça ouais
non c'était pas c'est pas du tout ça le
truc
là non mais c'est dommage parce que leur
formule là même en loser bracket tout ça
où je suis pas vraiment fan tu vois ils
auraient pu faire un mélange parce que
c'est vrai que leur tu vois une fois que
tu es au demi-finale ça va être plus
sympa on espère et du coup là tu as une
phase très très très longue pour y
arriver les joueurs en plus ont déjà
joué ensemble plusieurs trucs et tout
donc essaie d'être bien sûr tu prends
exactement le même format mais avec qui
per de ouf ça change tout bah ça
complètement en anglais quand mêmef s'en
fout de
mvl là c'est pas une question de mvl qui
per mvl qui per ça marche parce qu'on
fait hper le truc mais je veux dire
ouelle fois vous êtes un peu à côté mvl
ça change rien si tu es toujours
tributaire d'avoir ton joueur qui gagne
pour que le truc soit intéressant c'est
que ça va pas en fait genre allez un
exemple Roland Garos bon je sais pas
pour ceux qui aiment bien le tennis en
général tu aimes bien parce que tu aimes
bien et bah si tu as un Français qui va
loin tant mieux tu en as pas tu en as
pas tu vas quand même regarder parce que
ça reste sympa quoi en fait céit obligé
que de d'avoir un français en finale
pour que le tournoi soit bien bon
ben puis là en plus il reste quand même
des beaux joueurs sur le plateau oui
Magnus euh Carana et pu
pereouou dis si carou est là tu dis
c'est les qu meilleurs mondiaux quand
même sur ce que tu vois si Abdou fait la
surprise est quand même champion du
monde de rapide donc donc surprise donc
en soit tu auras forcément un très beau
plateau man dé en train de jouer le
title Tuesday ouais mais c'est c'est ça
tu as cette impression que il y a
quelque chose qui va ouais je peux c'est
c'est difficile d'expliquer mais il a
une impression de n'importe quoi en
fait c'est comme ça les échecs sont un
peu en crise en ce
moment les échecs sont un petit peu en
crise mais après ouais je trouve que par
contre quand tu as les bo4 avec
l'armagedon à la fin là c'est c'est plus
logique écoute on verra
CIT une tentative intéressante en tout
cas mais je crois que les joueurs
eux-mêmes ont pas trop aimé d'après ce
que j'ai compris ils ont quand même pu
cuisiner des
poutines
et on regarde pourirc ou perdre on
espère mais je crois que la partie là
elle va solder par une petite nulle
malheureusement pour nous après on
regarde parce qu'on regarde on est là
pour suivre le tournoi donc c'est la
dernière partie qui joue et avec un gros
enjeu comme on disait le
vainqueur va se qualifier pour pour pour
les demi-finales et là quand même on
sait pas trop le tableau encore
demi-finale he parce que là aussi très
intéressant a une règle marrante ouais
c'est que le premier du Touri va décider
contre qui joue et là faudra aller sur
le live officiel he ouais donc c'est
West leso he qui va décider s'il
préfèreter Fabiano carwana ou le
vainqueur de ce match al contre qui
voilà quel est le style qui se fite le
mieux avec lui leur historique tout ça
il va doir beaucoup réfléchir pour
choisir ça pourra influencer la suite du
tournoi en tout cas c'est c'est un
avantage de finir premier par rapport à
second parce que bah tu as tu as le
choix C de chance tu as le
choix
ESS deit choisir carwana je
pense
bah après il a de bon résultats contre
ikarou puis ça peut peut-être être Abdou
c'est vrai
aussi disons s'il y a Abdou je prendrai
Abdou et si c'est Caro qui gagne
je peut-être quandmeou com il joue ici
mais
bon dur à dire c'est pas un choix facile
sur le papier bon tu sais que c'est pas
un match simple qui que ce soit en face
je connais pas trop son historique avec
Fabi
quoi qui fait une saison de fou C année
belle saison s très vite qualifié pour
les candidats qui a remonté au-dessus
des des
2008 qui qui a qui a accumulé quelques
victoires en tournoi ici ou là en plus
pour son palmarès
euh peut-être le jour de l'année en fait
hein probablement je crois qu'il a la
meilleure performance ho sur l'année IKO
juste derrière et Magnus un peu plus
bas prend C tr prend C3 et
C5 c'est pas mal jouer prend C5 il veut
sûement tour C
vite récupérer C2 donc il s'enlève son
pion arrièé il avance un petit
peu bon Caro qui fait pas une mauvaise
partie dans celle-là faut dire on a pu
de critique dans les rondes précédentes
quand ça jouait pas très bien là bon il
fait rien de mal non non là le le niveau
de
jeu et plus euh conforme à ce qu'on
attendait de toute façon un joueur du
Cali Cararo il peut pas aussi mal jouer
que ce qu'il a fait dans le match
d'avant euh le problème c'est qu'il a
fait ça pendant tout le tournoi hein
ouais mais à un moment donné tu te
réveilles normalement ou bon ouais
c'estra qu' un moment quand tu es encore
en vie après tout ça tu peux peut-être
avoir finalement le
réveil tador qui nous dit un champion du
monde qui nous joue pas et qui est vu
comme derrière Magnus Carlsen par tout
le monde des suspicions de triche à gogo
et un circuit vide de sens avec des
formats pas attractifs tu m'étonnes que
les échecs so en cras un peu tout tout
résumé Vador
ouis tu as un peu tout
résumé et du coup là il y a des
changements qui ont tenté d'être raorté
sur ce tournoi ça c'est quand même
positif après on sent
que pour une raison xou y a pas encore
la quintessence qui a été trouvée
on verra avec les demi-finales peut-être
que le le format sera
mieux ça sera mieux mais ouais ça sera
mieux mais est-ce que ça sera assez pour
rattraper tout l'événement dur à dire
parce que est-ce que les gens vont
continuer à suivre tu vois que si tu
viens une fois deux fois tu tu bon que
c'est pas forcément que ça va changer ça
va monter en puissance
plusant
moi comme je disais juste avant pour moi
déjà ne pas avoir de public c'est un non
sens je tout le monde y est passé par là
le public c'est quand même un une
obligation et le rythme public et rythme
pour moi c'est c'est deux obligations à
à toute compétition en
fait au-delà du reste
hein ça peut un peu te
sauver le rythme que ce soit sympa ouais
qui te met dans l'ambiance et cetera
Legends aussi mais c'est parce que ils
remplissent des stats des machins enfin
même quand tu joues pas trop bah je sais
pas tu le stat g avec les gens avec leur
PC les machins ça te donne envie en fait
ti ça t'entraîne ouais je sais pas ça
t'entraîne tu les vois tu vois au lieu
d'avoir leurs interviews tuas qui qui
fait de la cuisine des poutines avec
Maxime sa mère ou je sais pas qui qui
voit un peu les les supporters autour du
stade qui font leurs chansons leurs
machin donne envie je sais pas comment
dire
ça va faire nul sans
sourcier mais une bonne partie pour le
coup ouais pe de
connerie après le format qu'il vont
reprendre avec les 7 en 4 c'était déjà
le le format du champion ch tour de
base il mon il reprennent le le truc ou
après ce qui m'inquiète un peu c'est que
c'est un truc qui a full
flop mais
bon on
verra on espère que ce soit bien en tout
cas comment tu gères un public niveau
triche je vois pas où est le problème en
fait il veut dire si les gens viennent
te dire les coups ou je sais pas c'était
quoi votre
la question ben je pas comme si on foot
tu un gars qui dév sur le stade
tire c'est un peu plus visant lol que
les échecs non je pense pas les échecs
c'est très vivant aussi il faut juste
donner les moyens de le rendre
Viant mais bon enfin si c'est que un
problème de public dit les coups euh il
y aura il y a des solutions enfin déjà
tu donnes pas accès au téléphone aux
gars et puis voilà ou euh les Gurs jouer
avec un casque
ou coup bah tu tu écris dans le
règlement qu'elle est redevable d'une
d'e d'une amende de 50000 € et puis on
verra s'il va les donner tu aachètes ton
ticket tu signes un contrat enfin ouais
c'est vraiment un problème tu donnes un
coup tu tu fais perdre le joueur à qui
tu l'as donné toi tu vas me payer 50000
balles puis je serais très content ça me
rembourser mon événement
enfin non je c'est l'argument le plus
débile que je que je lise à chais
trouver des trucs oui c'est
c'est bon
ESS de tendre l'oreille pour savoir ce
que dit le
public tu mal à taille du
risque il fait 25 degr ou il fait assez
chaud dans la pièce ça m'étonne qu'il
soit en pull d'ailleurs on vous
dit
tourb
et le bruit les joueurs sont capricieux
et ben ils viendront pas jouer passeront
à côté de 500000 balles en 5
jours il y en aura d'autres qui seront
bien contents d'être là je
pense par expérience que les joueurs ils
adorent avoir du public mais après façon
quand quand tu mets l'argent tu mets
l'argent quoi
T 4 ok il a voulu juger cette
finale non oui hein il a un pion de
moins mais normalement il va faire un
blocus sans trop de problème sans trop
de problème à
priori les blanc peut faire un pion
passer peut-être sur la colonne
h bon
euh je pense pas qu'il puisse avancer en
fait je vois pas
comment bon bon il va essayer siil peut
hein G4 3 G2 r G3 je commencerai par F3
quand même pour fixer la structure oui
faisons enfin je veux dire G4 R2 R3 euh
R3 je veux dire H4 G4 G5 H5 H6 bon voilà
déjà ça en a fait le
max44 ouais mais je crois qu'on va
bloquer
là ESS de mettre le RO en
D4
bon après ça a bloqué
bon Abdou qui a raison d'essayer c'est
lui qui a le pion de plus il peut rien
lui arriver et il va essayer de de faire
craquer les
carreaue façon tu joues
hein
on voit que c'est les joueurs qui
calculent c'estc c'est quand même pas le
meilleur des activités pour un public
échcs depuis près rien des coups sur
chqu qui a l'avantage et menace mais
pourquoi quand on le fait ça marche
alors si c'est pas possible en fait
pourquoi quand on le fait ça
marche non mais juste ça me dépasse si
quand on le fait ça marche pourquoi
c'est pas possible en
fait mais
je ça me bute en fait en fait je
comprends comment tu peux
gagner tu le F bon tu montes hyper haut
ouais bon pas comme ça ouais bon ça
c'est
en fait tu montais hyper haut tu mettais
le P G4 H4 machin tu montais à fond tout
si tu réussissais à tout monter après à
échanger des trucs B peu importe tu
repassais le roi en D4 une fois que ton
ro est en D4 il pouvait plus défendre 4
et C4 en même temps tu bouff 4 tu
bouffes 4 après tu vas pouvoir
gagner mais même pas sûr
hein mais moi j'aurais vraiment fait G4
et G3 ah moi aussi ouais mais ça c'est
sûr que ça enfin là c'est c'est sûr que
c'est fini ouais bon il a pas super bien
joué mais
euh d'un autre côté je pense peut il
peut encore G4 3 G3 sur G6 bon il a pris
donc il laiss F des4 prend
g7on çaintéressait pas priori non mais
je comprends ce qu'il veut faire en fait
il a dû voir l'autre truc il a dû dire
que nul était assez facile il veut
tenter un truc un peu plus
piégeur
bon en gros il veut prendre G7 et
pousser h
ouais sur G6 je pense
qu'ilion passer h non mais c'est pas B
ce qu'il fait en
vrai
bon
j'aime bien ce qu'il a fait en fait
j'étais mauvaise langue j'avais pas
compris en
fait c'est pas con il a posé un vrai
problème pratique évidemment il est
possible de le
régler mais il force une défense
quoi
peut-être
F5 ouais mais bon je sais bien je fais
fou D4 je prends G7 ouais tu prends G4
je mais
après je fais H4 en fait quand tu prends
G4 ouis je enfin pour je voulais faire
F7 dégager le fou prendre J4 H4 au moins
déjà bon si tuout le fou3 mettre le pion
H6 après te je crois que tu pourras
quand même t'en sortir en donnant E4 en
fait ouais E4 on s'en fout tu garderas
ton
mais bon c'est toujours
relou tu dois faire un choix et tu peux
te tromper que peut-être5 D4 Jes F4 je
[Musique]
F5 le truc c'est que même si retrouve
avec G5 F4 etutre il a plus que C4 je
pense que c'est nul quand
même pas s mais pas sûr
qui font un peu autant on a vu hier
qu'il avit perdu une finale justement
contredov avec le CAL 2 dans la
calach qui partait de pas grandchose
donc peut-être pas à l'aise pour cette
défens là on le voit qu'on ça stresser
physiquement
IL6 pourquoi pas des4 et F5 bon ben
finalement c'est la position C5 ouis sûr
mais ouais mais ouais mais c'est ce que
je ro F4
is tu vas pouvoir tu vas pouvoir faire
F6 à un moment faire F6 à un moment
donné on va voir bon c'est encore gaffe
mais genre la position elle est complexe
et je ah ouais ah du coup il va mettre
le F D3 c'est ça la différence ouais s
monter fallait faire F4 direct c'est
bête comme erreur
il a pas dû comprendre encore que
c'était un
problème ah c'est moi j'ai compris
pourquoi ouais bah s'il y a plus de pion
4 tu es plus content tu es plus content
qu'il soit pas làou et du coup le F en
D3 ouais ça va tenir tout se pas de P F2
passer
ouais qu'est-ce que c'est
dommage B C de
j'imagine des trois pas ch enfin tu fais
quand tu veux mais oui c'est une énorme
erreur d'abat pas avir commencé par F4
c'est mant faire F 3 F7
ou pourqu il donner pion j'ai pas on le
bouffe j'ai pas compris maisant c'est
gagnant je comprends pas par mais tu
mets le drit en G5 F6 ah il doit pouvoir
non mais tu mets le r G5 tu fais H5 et
tu fais6 ouais ouais ais mais il doit
vloir mettre le le fond en D3 et ah oui
mais tu vas faire H6 F4 F5 tu vasacer
ouis mais c'est pourquoi donner au4 par
plaisir de donner au 4 c'est assez
incroyable aujourd'hui c'est assez
incroyable ok
G5
H5 je pense H5
ouais essayer de défendre sur la même
diagonale alors
non
peut-être ça a toujours fait nul qu'il a
hyper bien jugé que je dit de la merde
mais ça vu comme ça ça me semblait bien
pour faire F6 mais peutêtre pr en fait
il a le roi qui vientus c'est ça son
idée de
défense donc il fallait gagner
autrement je sais pas si on a autre
chose que ce plan
là
ok faut F1
ah et là tu vas pouvoir faire F5
ok il est dur quasiment introuvable donc
ou il avait il ils ont bien joué là en
fait est-ce qu'il a un dernier
piège o est-ce qui peut avoir envie
d'amener son
roi je pense que tu peux pas vraiment
repasser par
B4 non mais ok bon bien réfléchi enfin
il se trouve que ça allait pas mais que
là pour le coup non non non c'était bien
joué mais il bien jouer de la part de
pator enfin aussi d're AR à obtenir ça
ou non non non là c'était une belle
partie
bien défendu la règle de la diagonale et
moi je pensais qu'il réussirait à faire
F5 mais en fait il peut pas c'est pour
ça qu'il fallait faire tout l'autre plan
mais c'était hyper dur hyper
dur ça visuellement tu crois que c'est
fini
et donc a prori on va aller vers une
petite
nuulle dans une par là c c'était une des
meilleures intéressante il y a pas de
gaffe déjà on comprend ce qui s passé on
pense qu'ils ont raté pourquoi
ou après qui
auraura les blanc dans la prochaine on
va voir va faire quelque chose se dirige
encore vers un armé
Ganon ça sent l'ARM
gadonin il ve faire pousser le pion h6
il va revenir à
F5 c'est la règle de la
diagonale faut qui
bloque peutêtre ro C6 je sais pas trop à
quoi ça sert mais pour le bloquer qu'
fasse le grand tour jeis même pas où tu
vas aller avec le grand tour en fait
donc PIR aller jusqu'en E7 mais
bon que le RO noir IR E6 ro Blon r
G5 non là tu vas pas passer avec les
Blancs
nul belle passe d'arme ouais belle nul
les amis on se retrouve très vite
pour la partie de retour à tout de suite
vous voulez streamer des échecs comme
vos créateurs préférés tels que bstream
Naka ou les sur Botz let's
go le programme de Community streamer de
tess.com est fait pour vous débutant
dans le streaming ou déjà expérimenté
peu importe c'est le moyen idéal pour
élargir votre audience en connectant
votre compte àess.com et profiteer de la
visibilité offerte à d're plateformes de
jeu il vous suffit de relier votre
compte à
jess.com/settings/connecting-ons mettre
échec comme catégorie sur twitch et
commencer à streamer bénéficierez d'une
expérience sans publicité sur Chess.com
et apparaîtrez dans notre liste de
streamers en direct votre profil
Chess.com affichera votre stream twitch
qui sera aussi mis en avant durant vos
parties enfin utilisez la commande
community streamer dans le chat et
faites grossir votre audience sans plus
attendre
[Musique]
[Rires]
les amis on est là on attend l'arrivée
des
joueurs qui se font
attendre carou a dit un interview qu'il
avait probablement joué sa meilleure
partie bah c'est ce qu'on pensait
comme
quoi pas toujours n'importe
quoi il a dit aussi qu' ça saouler les
armadon comme quoi
marrant critiqué tout c'est marrant la
même chose que les
joueurs non mais il disait que ouais si
fallait que ce soit comme en en Norvège
c'est un impact
minime
mais il a dit it what it is mais ouais
les joueurs ont l'air un peu blasés en
fait aussi c'est vrai de tous ces
tournois j'ai l'impression que c'est Mo
en train tu as un ressenti global dans
les échecs qui qui est un peu le même
pour tout le monde en
réalité joueurs spectateurs et
commentateurs en fait il y a que les
organisateurs qui continuent bah du coup
j'ai l'impression qu'il tatonne quoi
mais bon
ouis
car qui va produire son
effort il a dit aussi qu'il pense qu'
c'est tout BF maintenant pour lui mais
qui devrait plus être là et que bon il
est là il est
làçon on sait qu'il a une grosse
résistanceou
ok
oui re son point le plus fort
d'ailleurs
E4 par écossaise peut-être non
espagnol
D33 D6
et on peut jouer avec C4 ou pas sinon
c'est
C3 que c'est3 plus classique euh ben
écoutez faire rock 1 K 2 des coups
[Musique]
normaux B3 ou fou C2 à
voir C2 en fait ça l' plus logique mais
voilà il y a des 5 alors quand tu vas en
B3 c'est plus dur à
faire ça c'est bien
connu je pense qu'il prendre du
pion priori se il hésite peut-être
prendre du cavalier mais ça me ser ça me
semblerait plus logique de prendre du
pion en tout cas personnellement je
serais plus à
l'aise
du
cavalier qui veut une position moins
symétrique a cette prise là donc
évidment un peu moins
d'esace tu Penson peut espérer une
petite nul là on
pe l'enchaînement des
coups génial dans un
nouvel
c'est plus probable après bon veut
peut-être jouer un peu faire un petit A4
B4 fixer St dame mettre une mini
pression mais c'est vraiment mini
quoi je pense on peut é changer les
dames quoi prend prend
F6 je CIS qu'ikarou il veut juste aller
àarmedon et puis entendre parler de la
journée quo oua je pense aussi ouais
alors j sa qui demande si les demis sont
demain euh ouis elles sont demain les
demi ouais et encore elles sont demain
et après-demain c'est en plusieurs
manches donc demain il y aura la
première manche des demi après dememain
l'autre manche voir peut-être les armes
à gedons euh c'est sur de jours tout
ça ce soir c'est malheureusement le
dernier match qu'on a qu'on aura avoir
mais peut-être un armag dans la venir on
espère en tout cas
Fab ok alors il veut se diriger un peu
vers la ce C5 avec les
Blancs si jamais ça unqu tu peux faire k
B8 qui
D7 all est à 5 aussi à 5 pas que tu
passes très bien qui est à 5 c'est quoi
les heures bah demain c'est comme d'ab
18h il faudra pas manquer rendez-vous ça
va être exceptionnel à partir de demain
c'est là quelque part que ça va vraiment
monter en
puissance ça c travil préparatoire
l'échauffement pour arriver au grand
moment CHC fr peut nous garantir soit
bien 18h demain
c'est sûr que c'est 18h mais ça paraît
très logique quand même de commcer à peu
près chaque jour à la même heure pour
regarder un fil directeur tout ça
que
oui il a fait F6 maintenant
nordbec j'auris peut-être joué le coup
d'avant pour pas G5 ou quoi mais bon il
le fait
là
ouais ça va faire une petite nulle la
FAB ça devrait ça devrait mais bon ça t
jamais pensez ça de la partie d'avant
bon il quand même eu nul mais en passant
par des phases intéressantes donc donc
qui
sait
copous emène au bout de la
nuit j'en reviens pas quand même de la
gaveff de Maxime qui c'est fou H3
ouais celle-là elle est grosse
mais reg ça tu peux louper euh tu
devrais pas mais bon c'est une mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu celle contre
Abdou avant et la la partie 3 contre
ikarou ça allit pas du tout
quoi
pas du
tout
h bon en tout cas ouais
c'est pas hyper emballant tout
ça on
verra non BAE un peu en énergie aussi
désolé les gars on est un peu fatigué de
be moi je suis malade et là c'est vrai
que c'est un peu un peu long voilà on va
pas se mentir ça fait 7h de Live
déjà que c'est
pas mais bon on est on a hâte d'être
demain pour le vrai début du tournoi au
final
finale les
demi tu penses voir queles affiches
demain fa regarder sur le sur la chaîne
en anglais
c'est la décision de
DEC le réveil d'ou comme il a l'air de
se réveiller làraiment joué une grande
partie r
précédente
finalement vaut mieux l'éviter et
laisser à Carlsen la responsabilité de
l'avoir maintenu en
vie aurais jamais dû gagner cette partie
il fallait la
laisser rater le mat
voilà le tour fou contre tour en vrai si
tu veux ne pas le gagner tu tu tu te
trompes
ouis
mais moi je pense qu'il aura vraiment dû
le faire enfin je me répète mais ben il
peut être puni par
et comme Sinar a été
puni
je suis assez d'accord avec azrod Maxime
il jouait vraiment pas bien dans ce
tournoi donc je pense pas que même si
c'était qualifié il aurait vraiment pesé
Maxime c'est un joueur de rush quand
même aantarou je pense c'est un joueur
qui peut renaître renaêtre de ses cend
autant Maxime quand il joue bien il est
très très il joue très très bien s'il
joue mal il joue très très mal ouais
c'est
ça
en même temps on parle comme si se
qualifi on ne sait pas il a rien de
fait la première là rien nous dit qu'il
va gagner cette partie même probablement
pas nul reste le plus probable il faudra
encore gagner l'armé Gon et puis dans
cette partie peut peut-être encore se
passer deux trois choses ici ou là on
verra complètement Fab
complètement on espère en tout cas qu'il
se passe des
choses
partie qui s'emballe pas mais qui va
peut-être s'emballer un peu plus
tard position solide en tout cas de part
et
d'autres ça
bon si les blancs font trop rien les n
vont faire C5 C4 qui est B7 qui est C5
rentrer petit à petit ouais que les
blanc peut pas juste s'endormir et rien
faire de la partie
quoi ah c'est du petit tikaron quand
même hein ouais is
is
emprunter comme je disais he il s'est il
s'est marié il y a peu il commence à
virer avec la patronne
peut-être qu'elle commence déjà à faire
son
effet je commencé à faire des vidéos
avec elle et tout il est complètement
patron mais pourquoi il fait ça parce
que c'est la patronne tu dis patronise
moi je fais des vidéo quoi puis
is mais tu peux pas ce que tu
veux c'est elle qui dirige
Heon pas le moment
quoi peut-être justement c'est le moment
pour être tranquille après avec les
candidats
oui d'accord tu je laisse là pour direon
c'est bon truc mineur et puis tu j'ai
des mal
d'avanceutilis au bon
moment il va jouer à Sam marante en fait
il ou pas finalement où à samarand ah je
ne sais
pas
patron général fais voir si de la f qu'
met la liste à jour des
joueurs.com alors
aussi la f fa des visites dans certains
pays
délégué Turquie tout ça c'est
intéressant pas du monde quoi ouais mais
bon c'est quand même en dessous he c'est
en dessous c'est en dessous je
sais je vois pas en fait enfin c'est
aujourd'hui c'est l'anniversaire de de
gazic Victor la personne du jour après
un moment site de la feed
euh voilà il propose de calculer
différemment le ho tout ça c'est
intéressant mais tu en penses quoi
d'ailleurs cette réforme du
hopab écoute ça m'a pas passionné ça me
concerne pas je vois pas pourquo on fait
cadeau de point ho à des gens qui les
ont pas mérité mais après bon si ça fait
plaisir à tout le monde donnezles enfin
je c pour on donne des pourlo en fait
bah oui je ça va encore dévaluer le ENF
je comprends pas je comprends pas mais
bon bah ils ont dû beaucoup réfléchir
pour arriver à cette conclusion
brillante et et c'est sûrement très bien
en
fait bah disons en fait ce qu'ils font
avec le ho depuis un moment de toute
façon c'est c'est spécial
dans le sens où oui avant fallait 2002
pour être classé Fed puis 2000 puis
chaque année s points de moins bon
maintenant tu as plus besoin de rien
tout le monde est feed maintenant on
donne des points cadeau bon je sais pas
quel est le
BUT est-ce qu'on veut juste que les
joueurs battent des records pour faire
les malins et dire ah regarde très très
fort 3600 ho
fantastique je sais
pas
bon finalement il se passe pas
grand-chose tous les PS disparaissent
les uns après les
autres est toujours parti pour ça cette
partie à moins d'une
gaffe est-ce que ça va pas faciliter le
le truc pour devenir grand maître bon
c'est c'est déjà
factuellement nettement plus facile mais
dire peut-être B tant mieux il y aura
500000 grand mètres c'est très bien
enfin tout le monde sera grand maître
ouais c'est bien pourquoi pas en fait là
tout le monde va être 2000 puis tout le
monde 2500 puis tout le mondeêre Grand
Maître bah c'est bien quoi c'est le
progrès
quoi attends je suis en train peut-être
de trouver un site dédié là
ouis je vois une photo mais il y a pas
ikarou dessus c'est vrai qu' sera
inscrit j'imagine qu'il aurait sa petite
tête sur sur laffiche plus que goche
quoi il est quand même plus
vendeur information force de
players registration deadline tout ça ah
ils ont c'est bon deadline
extended pas de d'y aller un petit
peu un petit peu augmenter non je vois
pas d'IK dans la list je vois je vois du
Magnus
ger dou
yongan Maxim
dou je pense y a firouja qui devrait
jouer j'ai vu sa tête sur une fich passé
une fois je sais même pas si officiel
est à jour en fait des inscrits c'est
bon il y a quelquun qui est classé 1500
il passe 1650 du coup 1er janvier bravo
bravo beau
progrès ça me bute quand même ce truc
c'est complè pense stupide non ah bah
ouais mais là je connais quelqu'un qui
qui a peine 1050 ben je crois qu'il va
passer 1450 d'un coup c'est mais c'est
quêtement con ah
ouis mais lui-même il se rend compte que
c'est con ou il est heureux bah il est
heureux de rien il s'en fout
complètement en fait quand tuas 1050
qu'est tu t'en fout quo enfin tu
comprends que tu as rien fait pour t 400
points que tu as rien mérité que c'est
juste on te les donne on te les donne
mais ça a tout faossé
bah sûrement mais tout le monde sera
grand-mre c'est
bien bien sûr des résultat bah je sais
pas parce que ça joue quand même
beaucoup à l'ARM magadon et donc je
pense que l'ARM magadon c'est le truc
qu'on est le moins sûr quoi
ouais donc je peux pas dire gars gars is
dead enfin pour moi on n'est pas bien
sûr c'est full armagadon en fait ça ils
ont fait nul ouais bah du coup ça va
être unon les qui l'air dégoûté c'est
enc ça me fera allez hop là on encore
descend l'ardoise hop là t
amis vous voulez streamer des éches
saviez-vous que vous pouvez pimenter vos
parties en ligne et vous analyses avec
des emojis il vous suffit de cliquer sur
l'icône emoji puis de sélectionner votre
emoji et de cliquer avec le bouton
gauche de la souris sur les chiquers
vous pouvez choisir parmi une multitude
de notations de coup d'animations
d'émoticone et même vos person alité
préféré du monde des échecs les émoticon
et les emojis disparaîtront au bout de
quelques secondes en revanche les
notations de coup et les animations
spéciales reste sur les chiquier jusqu'à
ce qu'elle soit effacée pour se faire il
suffit de cliquer avec le bouton gauche
de la souris sur l'emoji ou de cliquer
sur le bouton tout effacé
essayezles tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
[Rires]
les amis la dernière partie de de la
journée le dernier Armon de la journée
quelque part ah oui oui il y a eu que de
ça en fait il y a eu que de ça ouais
fait c'est même à se demander à quoi
servent les deux premières parties c'est
bizarre pourquoi il a autant de nul
d'ailleurs
c'est étonnant en
soi les niveau sont tellement proches
c'est vrai qu'on on a passé notre
journée à regarder des armagadon
ouais mais oui donc c'est un problème en
fait parce que l'armagedon bon c'est
quand tu as vent tout fait qu'à la fin
bon faut départager les gens et puis
voilà mais
c'est c'est pas tellement des écheacs
parce ça fausse le truc tu mets une
différence à la pendule tu forces un mec
à jouer pour le gain l'autre qui peut
être mieux qui va jouer pour faire nul
et ceeta enfin tu fais jouer les gens
contre nature avec des trucs
déséquilibrés
euh bon pourquoi pas mais non mais c'est
sympa mais en dernier en dernier recours
quoi bah
ouais enfin c'est comme si tu jouis tout
les match de foot au tir au but tout le
temps en fait et autant de temps les tir
au but que le reste du match quoi enfin
ais la pause est longue en plus entre
entre les deux mais écoute on est
reparti pour un armag Gon ça ça ira
mieux demain avec quatre parties quand
même dans le match moin cette sensation
demain il y aura pas Deon quoi qu'il en
soit même s'il y a de de il y a de de
non ilon quand même quand même a gag le
7 je crois faud vérifier je crois qu'ils
peuvent faire de deux non mais ils
peuvent maisadon oui il peuvent pas
faire de de moi je pensais que de de tu
faisais 22 tu rejouais le match
lendemain et ben là il y a unur pas et S
a ahà 3è set non d'accord pas du demain
on va prendre des beaux Armon alors il
aura pas un partout il y aura de de quoi
de de ça Armagedon et re de ça Armagedon
et s'il y a un set partout c'est deux
parties et
rearmagedon il y en a tout le temps
c'est très intéressant parce que tu
auras déjà joué àag en poule donc tu
seruras à peu près les enchères que tu
as déjà eu tu vas te jouer dans le match
1 tujoueras dans le match 2 et peêt dans
le match 3 donc là tu vas être très
finim pour savoir la seconde près quoi
dire
quoi commence toujours pas en fait mais
non faut quand même bien laisser le
temps au g de se
reposer pourre quand même bien frais et
bien bien bien être en forme pour cette
partie vraiment décisive et importante
pour l'ensemble de leur saison
et oui ça serait dommage d'échouer si
près du
butir tout donner depuis des mois et des
mois pour arriver là
j'étais convaincu que ça reparait
maintenant en fait bon ça va pas tarder
bon l'arbitre nettoie bien là regardeè
la poussière hop là qui est bien
dépoussiéré quand même pas que soit
perturbétre une poussière si tu en F4 F5
qui empêchera de bien
jouer
alle les voilà voilà les joueurs qui
sont bien là qui Adou bien leur
piècesir les pièces
blanches noir je sais pas exactement
combien il a il a mis à son
enchère
alle les GS sont bien en place je pense
vraiment que c'est une affaire de
seconde avant que ça
démarre allez c'est parti 935 chez chez
nordbec Al ça rejoint espagnol mais
j'imagine cette fois va faire un choix
un peu plus agressif que K prend le 4
ils ont la même position il fait le
fameux C4 C4 ouais VO il change quelque
chose quand même euh bon ben C4 c'est
pour éviter D5 et B5 tu fais un petit
Tron D4 mais finalement tu le contrôles
par le Cali F3 il a bien pris soin de
faire H3 pour pas Leser fou G4 pour
l'instant tout ça c'est contrôlé et il
va sûrement essayer de jouer D4 un peu
plus tard ou A3 B4 à voir
bon selon comment ça se passe les ns
peuvent peut-être songer un plan comme
roi H8 qui G8 pour faire F5 en tout cas
il vient vers D4 avec un cavalier beau
ce cavalier D4 C belle case bon je pense
qu'on a envie de le
prendre on a envie de faire de trois
grimaces avant Fab on se
questionne on a envie de
grimasser en tout cas ça jouit assez
vite un côté côté
oubek
changé
5 il sait ce qu'il fait la nirbec h n on
est plutôt pour nirbec hein moi en tout
cas mais moi j'ai j'ai j'ai envie de ça
et j'ai envie d'ikaro qui bat Magnus en
demi quoi pour le punir ah oui
qu'on a les deux trucs intéressants
quoi moi je suis pour sa maintenant dans
le tournoi le
chasseau je te remettre bien sur Twitter
merci JésusChrist d'aviré le tournoi et
tout en plus il a gagné le concours de
de Poutine
quoi il a complètement écrasé au
concours de Poutine ouais il a fait bien
croustillant il a pris les ingrédients
au hasard et céit vraiment fameux quoi
et il les a défoncé en concours de
Poutine d' le mec tu a même dit
hein j'ai besoin de recert de Poutine
original je fppelle à vous ah ouais vous
ouais il a déjà sa reconversion
quoi c'est bon à la poutine je crois bah
c'est des frites mais où tu mets un truc
dessus quoi pour les pumper on va on va
dire donc a du fromage et tu tu peux
mettre un petit croustillant un petit ce
que tu veux une
sauce en fait chez nous c'est pas la
même chose la poutine
alors bah c'est canadien enfin c'est
mais ça existe aussi la poutine en
France ah bon enfin moi je pens je
pensais que juste on les avait copié et
que non mais c'est chez nous c'est une
friture de petits poissons ah oui rien à
voir si vous avez vous pourir les fêtes
en commentant les mondieux alors moi oui
JCS mars
ouais moi je ça va je vais échapper à ça
peut-être mais ça peut être sympa les
Mondiaux mais ça dépend oui en fait
c'est quand même organisé avec des
tournois ave 25 rondes ou quoi
c'est après ça va en janvier il y a pas
grand-chose et puis après il y a un peu
de proest League moi ça m'amuse la
proest League ça c'est marrant pu c'est
une fois par semaine ça dure 2 heur ça
va c'est cool
ouais le tata style après avoir
ouais enfin
s malheureusement sans moi j'aurais pu
essayer de prendre mas cayas mais je
crois que je vais pas pouvoir
dommage moi je su sur mes sponso de jeux
mobile
ah mais oui bon pire façon il y aura des
recap un
peu sur sur la chaîne j'imagine parce
que il peut avir de belles partie
complètement et de bas je suis quand
même plus sur sur les jeux mobile sur
jeux mobile
ouais intéressant ces jeux
mobiles te donne pas ton avis je
sais non mais disons que ça peut pas
être
pirechecs et c'est nettement mieux payé
et quand je suis nettement c'est
nettement très nettement c'est
excessivement nettement
et puis tu découvres un jeu quoi je sais
pas tu cliques quoi c'est plus marrant
et c'est très très très très très très
nettement mieux
payé mais genre de
fou qui a bien trouvé ses 5 qui change
ce fou qui donne un
échec
une question sur le format idéal pour le
CH du monde rapide Blitz bon je pas je
pense tu auras une meilleure idée que
moi mais en fait ça peut pas être juste
un Open de 21 parties où où ça se décide
à la fin quand on est crevé et que et tu
as déjà joué contre tout le monde tu vas
jouer contre des mecs du fin fond qui
sont je sais pas où enfin ça ça va pas
donc soit tu fais un truc Calif et carte
finale demi-finale finale ou 8e ou je
sais pas quoi j'imagine soit tu fais un
open mais moins long et puis voilà mais
en limitant peut-être plus les places ou
je sais pas qu'est-ce que tu en penses
toi je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
toi merci tu es plus spécialiste toi tu
suis chaque année depuis 3 4 ans ouais
ouais ouais le truc c'est qu'en fait ça
mériterait moins de ronde et puis
peut-être après prendre les sens
meilleur et faire un truc plus élitiste
bizarrement là c'est trop court en fait
en fait il faud changer du monde de
rapide en 3 jours h c'est que là il y a
h joueurs et ça 7 jours bon tu sais pas
pourquoi c'est aussi long ouais et de
l'autre côté tu as tout le
monde de joues et c'est champion du
monde à la fin le titre fin et c'est ça
D 3 jours quoi i c'est juste un oui
c'est juste un petit c'est les échecs
c'est irréel ouis et on est toujours à
côté de la plaque c'est hallucinant mais
après oui c'est sympa à suivre après ça
dépend aussi comment Maxime joue et
cetera oui oui si on peut s'emballer un
peu bon en tout cas dans cette partie
kou ouais je pense unb qui a fait F5 un
peu vite qui se fait surprendre par ce
coup C5 là qui ouais qui lui a fait mal
et là il se'est fait rentrer un peu dans
la position le T 6 bien placé qui vient
de taper un peu le pion
C6 c'est dommage qu'on dire bec qui
avait un bon début de partie et qui a
fait absolument n'importe quoi Mo j'ai5
mais là qui joue tente de
ouais de compliquer d'arnaquer quelque
chose c'est bien
faire la course candidat gouash domingaz
al gche c'est la course pas au ho hein
mais il a un tournoi sur mesure en Inde
Dominguez il est parti jouer un hôtel en
Espagne alira apparemment il fait rien
mais bon il aura le droit de jouer d'ici
la fin de l'année s'il trouve quelque
chose à faire pour le moment en tout cas
il est englué dans ce tournoi et c'est
fini il est plus englué là il peut
rentrer bien joué le G5 quand
même mais c'est vrai que même pour la
course donc au circuit feed c'est très
mal fait que éligiblebles ne pas pas
annoncé à l'avance que n'importe qui
puisse faire un tournoi en Inde là
justement pour Gouch et que ça puisse
lui attribu des points pour le circuit
c'est c'est juste fou quoi comme si du
jour au lendemain tu dis ah tiens Mo
j'ise mon grand chlem de tennis
et c'est les échecs ça doit être annoncé
à l'avance quand même c'est les échecs
Fab la fite doit dire ça ça compte ça
compte pas et cetera et
cetera c'est les échecs je sais pas trop
quoi dire les échecs j'avais fait la
vidéo les échecs son en crise hm hm il y
a peut-être maintenant une dizaine de
jours de ça où j'expliquais ben un crise
pourquoi parce que ben déjà lutte contre
la triche c'est un énorme problème et on
est très loin de le régler et que ça
triche ou que ça triche pas c'est même
pas la question dans une suspicion
constante de tout donc c'est qu'il y a
un problème de fond grave euh le cycle
de championnat du monde bah en crise
aussi et euh bah pour toutes les raisons
que tu as évoqué et puis crise aussi
parce que bah les tournois intéressent
plus personne parce que Ben bah ils les
ont pour avec leur format
mettre les mêmes qui jouent 8000 fois
par an donc les échecs en crise côté
joueur côté administration et côté
spectateur en fait il y a plus rien qui
va enfin on a fait notre petit rayon de
soleil ce weekend le seul mais tu vois
qui est pas du tout enfin qui est pas
qui est un peu qui est repris quand même
en vrai tu as pas mal de gens qui
commencent à à nous rejoindre là-dedans
mais pas les gens influ pas les gens qui
ont de l'argent pour le moment après les
gens qui ont de l'argent sont il
intéressé à donner de l'argent aux
échecs pour les échecs ou pour d'autres
raisons avant je me posais la question
maintenant je me la pose plus trop en
fait de plus la poser c'est déjà y
répondre alors B je la pose plus parce
qu'à un moment donné c'est trop
redondant et
trop ben tu te dis ouais c'est pas
possible en fait pas possible de faire
les choses mieux avec beaucoup moins de
budget et que ça intéresse pas les gens
qui mettent de l'argent par les fenêtres
c'est que ils font autre chose en fait
ça ça peut pas exister ça existe dans
aucun milieu ça existe dans aucun
domaine c'est il y a forcément un
problème plus
profond mais bon je le vis bien je te
rassure
hein qui va redescendre sa tour F il y a
un échange en 8 sûrement pour le pour
l'extirper faire tour Prem tour pr fou
fite qui va se clouer on est jamais trop
Friant de ce genre de coup mais euh
est-ce qu'on a vraiment le
choix est-ce que cette crise va mener à
une perte de revenus pour les joueurs de
haut niveau bah le jour où les joueurs
de ha niveau aur moins de revenu on sera
peut-être on commencera à sortir de la
crise en
fait c'est-à-dire que tant qu'on reste
dans ce ce Ce mesena à ta la crise va
faire que
sagravait don je
parlais répond je
dis F8 ça allit pas être trop à cause de
fou fou F2 et Bou des4 estce qu'il en
vient pas de 6 si il peut répéter mais
il a changé d'avis je crois que reprends
chiant en fait
ouais
bizarre bizarre ou pas je sais pas mais
carou qui essaie de presser qui s 2
minutes 30 d'avance à la pendule qui
envoie un peu ses pion à dame mais des
trois jou qui un peu se fou
G7 c'est bien joué des3 allez NAD
bec si d prend il veut faire F3 en
fait du Fou des qu échecs pour ramener
son fou en
jeu
tu as même des idées des fois pas mais h
de faire des dames G3 pour échanger
okg3 quand
même avec le RO
H1 je crois que le championnat du monde
de Blitz rapide l'an prochain sera en
Autriche
OK je crois avoir vu ça
passer c'est pas trop
loin si c'est un peu dans les montagnes
ou quoi ça peut être même sympathique
quoi pour pour passer les fêtes de de
Noël qu' des Sénat tu exagère un peu non
bah les tournois c'est des messes en
fait qui les sorganise j'exagère pas
quoi c'est factuel bah ils sont pas
rentables du tout ENF après je sais pas
mais c'est ça s'appelle réellement du
messena c'est juste le nom enfin c'est
il y a rien de mal à dire
messena il donne de l'argent quoi B tu
donnes de l'argent ENF tu as le droit de
donner de
l'argent ça s'appelle du MEN ENF c'est
c'est juste apprendre à parler français
quoi c'est pas une exagération quoi
c'est la réalité
économique
actuelle c'est ni bien ni mal enfin
c'est je pense c'est plutôt mal pour les
échec en fait actuellement
mais c'est bien pour les
joueurs
là pour le coup ce tournoi c'est pas du
messena c'est c'est financé par chesscom
et les les sponsors sponsoring
ouais après à voir s'ils auront des
bonnes retombées voir est-ce que le
sponsoring est rentable ou pas c'est
c'est une autre question mais c'est du
sponsoring c'est pas du
mesena il y a displate aussi quelques
sponsor vous avez pu voir
ch tous ceux qui passent derrière les
Pumas tout ça
là j'ai fait Puma
Fab donc il a pas une rencontre j'ai vu
entre Pep Guardiola et Magnus
Carlsen céit la pub qu' avait tout à
l'heure quand on bon ben nous le truc
c'est queon prenit autre pause hein
pendant la pub mais il a pas de dame pr
F3 et sur tour prend tour h 5
surche
alors ve faire ça comment prendre
prendre est un peu fatigué le
fa4 pas mal pour petite 347 enc plus 28
coups
s'accroche sonampion
C5 son en jeu ça si la sauve c'est plus
la baraca là c'est
s'il gagne ça avec les Blancs c'est plus
la baraca
ouais la réussite
ultime mais nobeck en fait je crois que
c'est vraiment ses points forts que
j'aime bien c joueurs c'est que c'est
pas un chockur en fait non non puis il
s'accroche il prend sa chance
pratique
ouais ikarou qui va assbrer
finalement
prês de passer entre les gouttes plus
d'une
fois gooutous bec finalement le mouiller
contrairement au goû de
française
sche mais
bon
bon là
c'est c'est professionnel
ou tous les réseaux de mat potentiel et
compagnie B là tu vas prendre à 4 tout
pions les
[Musique]
deuxid il pe aller vers tin et pousser à
fond le le a
quoi lâche ça et Caro ou car qui est qui
est désabusé ça se voit secoue la tête
il su à
fond
ça pourrait mettre plus en PLS les de
pionutre
chose noir je capable de me en
PLS tu donnes t'en fous il bien joué il
va se mettre derrière l' ou l'autre il
va pouser derrière d pous
ou maisas il a été précis quand même
ouif je crois qu'il plus manières d'êre
précis
mais
je crois que cassé ou on a la suite là
do été joué
Z V là j'urais bien tour
G8 faire ce
qu'il bah il peut ne rien faire en
fait
bien jou g
vite dernier piège qui March peut-être
même
pas possible de faire nul
maintenant H5 t G7 la prend pas c'est
tout
G6
et la petite
nulle éliminatoire pour
ikarou qui sort de ce tournoi F
finalement au prix d'un enem et ultime
armagéon
perdu américain on a nos qure joueurs
qualifiés en demi donc nierbeck Abd
satorov West leso Magnus Carlsen et
Fabiano
carwana on va vous laisser le plaisir
d'aller écouter le stream dans sa
version originale peut-être un raid un
raid éc pour aller écouter l'in de westo
qui va
choisir son adversaire qui éent tout
l'intérêt de cette formule ouais ça va
être le moment le plus passionnant
finalement quelque part donc on vous
laisse aller sur Stre américains où ils
ont les images malheureusement on ne
pourra pas suivre en français mais on
suivra bien évid voilà pour bien se
délecter et bien être au courant de de
la suite des événements merci à tous
encore et à demain pour les demi-finales
qui s'annoncent par